[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
all right
what up everybody how you living how you
doing how you feeling it is arguably the
best night of the year it is the NFL
draft and this is Gridiron draft night
right here on the BR app and be our
YouTube I am lefco coming to you for the
10th freaking straight year doing this
which is unbelievable uh honestly I I
couldn't be more happy and every single
time we do this it gets better because
the names get bigger the dude that is
wearing a suit okay he came in dressed
to impressed I'm in here in a hoodie
fathers and a t-shirt you know him
former Defensive Rookie of the Year a
star All-Pro Micah Parsons looking at
himself how you feeling I'm feeling good
uh obviously I heard the wrong Mo well
you know what I heard I had to dress up
you know but it's cool it's cool look
good feel good first time on this you
know I'm here to impress a little bit on
where I want to get my did you do you
normally watch the draft Yeah I do
you're like every year and you so you
played with these guys yes okay yeah you
know what you're doing yeah I know what
I'm doing for sure okay I'm a big draft
believer you know uh the draft's always
interesting it's like you end a journey
to start a journey so in life like it's
like you just hitting the restart
because they don't even know what
they're prepared for you oh they have no
idea yeah it's tough so you know for a
lot of people that think like oh like it
should translate it doesn't translate at
all it's like you're completely
resetting because it's Peewee like high
school football no it's high school
football college football no and NFL is
nothing like well he was Defensive Rook
of the year so he knows uh a dude that
I've known for a very long time a great
friend a dude that is not afraid to give
his opinion uh played college ball and
he's just he knows all of these dudes Mr
Michael Felder in the bleachers what's
going on guys where's Mom where's my one
run one right here here we go look at
that what do we think what do we think
of the draft big picture I think that
the the most interesting thing for me is
when the Draft starts like we know who's
gonna go number one but after that we
got some questions and I think the draft
really starts when you get a
non-quarterback coming off the board
that's when teams has to start getting
creative that's what teams have to start
making tough decisions and where those
quarterbacks are going to go of all the
years this is the one where I have no
freaking idea right I don't know I don't
know how the teams feel about the
quarterbacks so that's why we're relying
on a big old brain and a quafted perfect
hair of a dude that has been working at
PFF and now he is ready to open up his
wings and fly into all of your screens
it is the one the only Mike Renner in
the place to be we are using your big
board today uh you're 30 000 feet
perspective of this draft what do you
think well I'll say I know where one
quarterback's gonna go I know where
Bryce Young's going he's going to
Carolina after that it is anybody's
guess but the thing I love about the
draft and why I do this for a living is
that no matter what happens you got
better today and that's something to be
proud speaking of better we have your
props these are your prop bets I don't
know if it's too late for you guys to go
the window take us through your favorite
props for this draft my favorite props
to the draft and I'm not saying all of
them are going to hit you're just trying
to hit you know over 50 here take a
little chance so I like will Levis under
6.5 that one was a while ago I think
that one might happen I'm watching for
in when you say under like before before
so yeah
once the Raiders are on the clock if
Will Levis hasn't been drafted I'm
losing that bet Peter scaronski under 10
and a half I think he's the best
offensive lineman in this draft the
safest offensive lineman in this draft
there's a lot of teams that need
offensive linemen around the NFL
Broderick Jones though over 13 and a
half to me is the biggest project in
this draft we'll see when he goes but I
think we may see a number of tackles go
ahead of him I like Quinn Johnston the
TCU wide receiver under he has something
that no one else since wide receiver
class has that's size I like Don Kincaid
the first tight end drafted NFL still
covet's receiving ability over all
around ability and no matter what the
position is and to me he's the best item
Prospect since Cal Pitts and maybe a
little more polished leaving Pitts was
coming out I like over four and a half
QBs yeah you think that means headed
hooker goes first attended hooker
sneaking in the first round somewhere
here and they're like under four and a
half wide receivers drafted I just don't
think after Quentin Johnston after
Jackson Smith and jigba Zay flowers and
Jordan Addison don't think we see a
fifth sneak in there okay uh it is not
just going to be us four I'm sure you've
seen the social media post they put all
the faces on there we have some special
analysts that are going to be joining us
as well with some big old resumes on the
left wide receiver fever for the
Philadelphia Eagles AJ MF and brown in
the middle a new member of the Atlanta
Falcons one of the greatest voices
you'll ever hear in your entire life
Calais Campbell Calais just say anything
right now real quick
I'm happy to be here baby oh yeah and
then to the right uh he has had an
incredible career he has put a new spin
on why you should take the franchise tag
I like that Kirk Cousins is going to be
breaking down uh the quarterbacks it's
not just because I'm an Eagles fan Micah
Parsons but last year's draft show we
had Jason Kelsey on the show and while
the draft was going on the Eagles traded
for AJ Brown and this is what happened
during last year's draft show so take a
look Micah
oh my God
do you see that I don't think that was a
good trade at all right
that trade went through I I don't know
how that tree would be no we're looking
at you big left go
this is big the Eagles just try how
about that one 18th pick and a third
round pick for one of the best young
wide receivers in the NFL AJ Brown yeah
this is huge this is instantly an
upgrade for the offense I mean I can't
tell you how much this is going to make
us better uh Howie is uh he's the man on
a mission right now man he's making
things happen and uh I'm a big fan here
we go baby oh there we go he was
supposed to retire AJ uh did you ever
see that clip man did you ever see that
oh yeah I did I love that clip oh uh
well look I could come here and talk
about how great you are and how that was
one of the best moments of my entire
life I do think though that Micah you
you thought that was a bad trade though
I don't know how Tennessee is crazy I
don't understand that I don't know I I
would yeah I know he don't he doesn't
like that he the best receiver on the
team and you let him go because he won't
get paid and then he outperforms what
you were trying to pay him like come on
Tennessee that's that's why I didn't
share was they getting rid of everybody
right now come on come on and you send
him over to Eagles don't start sweating
now because you're getting angry no I'm
I'm still angry to this day about that
trade you know it's still beef right now
it's still beef so anytime a wide
receiver gets drafted AJ Brown is going
to break it down AJ we had you come up
with the top five wide receivers uh take
us through your top five
okay and number one I have uh Zay
flowers
and number two Jalen Hyatt and number
three Jackson Smith uh number four John
Domingo and uh Jordan Addison the number
five uh I'm I'm hoping we see five goal
today you know those guys on my list are
really good football players and and
I'll almost say whoever's gives a
flowers
might be to still still drop from the
wide receiver standpoint I love that and
AJ well when the Eagles draft at 10 and
30 if they make those selections we will
be hearing from you then as well uh
Calais Campbell uh is going to be doing
the trenches for us so some of the best
offensive and defensive linemen Calais
I'm curious the big guys you know the
meet in the middle who are some of your
favorite prospects who are the ones that
when you put on the film really jumped
out to you in this process
all right well number one is uh Jaylen
Carter I mean he's you know by far you
know uh well I'm gonna say by far
because they got some other beasts but
to me he's the best uh deepest line you
get in his draft uh I mean when you see
on the field where he dominates ways
double teams he's natural tonight for
making plays quick uh explosive you know
all the above you know then you got uh
Will Anderson out of Alabama you know uh
I mean he's I mean the most accomplished
Alabama player of all time you know for
d-line which is pretty much it's pretty
crazy I mean all the great players are
playing there uh but I like about him is
his get off you know and he has you know
it kind of has like Von Miller kind of
uh flash to me you know just that sex
appeal where he could do everything uh
and then uh you know that uh you know
Wilson kid Tyree Wilson you know I think
he's uh you know stud he's kind of like
that that big body Stout strong
explosive uh physicality you know and um
you know I mean those three guys man
those those guys make it go you know for
the d-line you know I feel like this is
a big class you know there's a lot of
other guys that can play but those three
are the criminal crap uh we're gonna
when we talk about Jalen Carter later
we'll hear Micah Parsons because he
loves Jason Carter and uh Calais will
also check in with you after the Falcon
select at eight and then last Mr Kirk
Cousins is going to be very busy we just
don't know when he's going to be busy he
could be busy in the first five picks it
could be throughout the first round uh
we're not sure about these quarterbacks
I think are you sure about these
quarterbacks what what order do you have
these guys
I don't know how sure I am about these
quarterbacks but I'd also tell you that
uh the last you know 10 15 20 years of
this draft it's pretty difficult to be
sure about first round quarterbacks so
uh you do the best you can and you hope
you get someone who's going to change
your uh your franchise for the next
decade but uh in my top five order I'm
not going to have any surprises here
Bryce young number one for obvious
reasons I think his tape as you talk to
experts who have studied it all spring
they would tell you that it's kind of
him and then everybody else and CJ
Stroud next I've watched a couple of his
games being a Big Ten guy myself and he
makes some some throws that uh Tight
Windows that you know made my eyebrows
go up pretty impressive armed Talent
Anthony Richardson has the super high
ceiling and incredible athlete didn't
have as much college experience but uh
certainly as exciting and has traits
that make you say that this guy could be
really special will Levis was the one
who going into last season really was
supposed to be the top pick had the
previous year tape that was so
impressive and then this past year
wasn't quite as sharp but there are some
reasons for that I think that go beyond
just him and then Hendon hooker really
elevated himself throughout this past
year he's coming off an injury but Elite
arm talent and uh certainly can throw
the ball as a first round pick should
all right so here's the main thing about
this show Kirk thank you so much I we're
going to be going back to uh pretty much
right now because the television
broadcast they're welcoming people
they're saying hey welcome to the draft
hope you're great the big reason to
continue watching our show is we're not
waiting for TV there's a lot of
reporters out there that are already
breaking the picks in fact it came out a
few hours ago that Bryce young is going
to be the first pick so we're going to
start our draft right now because we're
not going to wait for television
throughout this entire night we will
often have the picks before the
television broadcast so let's make a
video Let's officially welcome Bryce
young to the Carolina Panthers with the
first pick in the 2023 NFL draft that
sound the pick is in
oh I'll see you very soon
Carolina Panthers 7-10 last season
second in their division didn't make the
playoffs and they are going to be going
with Mr Bryce young as soon as they
start rolling that footage I'm gonna get
going we're gonna go Renner we're gonna
go Felder Mike is going to give his
Insight which I know is going to be
hilarious all night long and then we're
going to hear from Kirk Cousins about
this pick
it is ridiculous how accomplished this
guy is
yeah like when you see everything he's
done so here it is sham sharanya is
going to be the one that breaks this
look at that Mr MBA Carolina Panthers
are selecting Alabama quarterback Bryce
young as number one overall per sources
uh
man
23-4 through a touchdown in all 27
starts over two seasons never been done
um
all right so can I just ask the
production are we gonna Roll video first
or am I just going to go to Renner
okay
you know what I'm doing an executive
decision can you come back to me please
so that I can talk over that video and
then I'm going to toss the runner
hey what's up everybody how you living
we're gonna we're gonna do this one more
time this is the reason we do it now
Bryce young officially the number one
pick for the Carolina Panthers of all
the quarterbacks in this process he was
seen as the one that was light years
ahead of everybody he is being talked
about as genius level on the board was
offered Scholarships in eighth grade
shockingly but not shockingly born in
the same hospital as Kobe freaking
Bryant Mr Mike Renner the pick here the
choice to trade up to one and take him
your thoughts of the value to me he's as
accomplished he's right behind like
Trevor Lawrence in terms of
accomplishments over his entire career
this guy was a five-star number one
quarterback recruit in his class 20th
recruit all time by 247 Sports so he was
coming out A matter day with Incredible
hype goes to Alabama very first year as
a starter wins a Heisman slays the
dragon that is the 2021 Georgia defense
with one of the most impressive
quarterback performances you'll see at
the Collegiate level and the only reason
he doesn't win a National Championship
is because both his top two wide
receivers left that game as a game prior
without ACLS unfortunately that's the
only reason because he had them dead to
rights in both of those games until
Jameson Williams went out no Duds on
this tape there's no game to point to
where it says that 510 204 is a problem
from his tape at Alabama works the
middle to feel better than a lot of or
most of the short quarterbacks the Kyler
Murrays the Russell Wilson's at the NFL
level the only thing I'm worried about
with him injury yeah 510 204 looks like
a slot wide receiver what's it going to
be like when he takes a hit because he
can't really slide I don't think he
played baseball growing up he died he
had first Dives if you head first dive
at the NFL level you're getting popped
by guys like this over here yes that's
the only thing you're really worried
about on the field he's nasty what grade
are we giving them oh we're giving that
an A plus right there give it to him I
love it and listen here's the thing this
is the reality when you look at Bryce
young I see a guy that didn't have to
run check with me games and what that
means is he's not looking at the
sideline for help right he's someone and
the end of that Auburn game might be
some of the best that you're going to
see he's someone that when he gets to
the in when he he's at the end of this
game they need points he understands
where to go with the football what type
of thought that he needs to make he gets
all those things done this is someone
that can make every throw does it have
Anthony Richardson no but guess what
this is still going to be an A plus for
me because this is the best quarterback
the best quarterback who should go
number one overall it's Bryce young you
see him there he can use his Mobility
still keep eyes down the field and go
make plays absolutely love Bryce young a
plus
I don't have a grading system do I need
to hit it again what grade would you
give oh I think it's the eighth grade
for sure okay can we talk I want to have
that weird conversation with you about
the size you're a Defender and now here
comes a guy who as soon as he's drafted
which it will be now he is the smallest
quarterback in the NFL what do you think
yeah you know I think this is a great
overall pick great Prospect but at the
end size does matter
um some of his worst games was against
nasty defensive lines Carolina doesn't
have a terrific offensive line a lot of
this tape he's very comfortable he he
has to get used to getting uh being
uncomfortable be able to make those
throws feeling uncomfortable games that
they struggle he was uncomfortable a lot
with blitzes uh nasty defensive lines
also bigger defensive lines where their
password was able to get around
Alabama's usual top offensive line so uh
it's a very good pick but it's a lot of
doubts for sure especially with the size
but what he doesn't lack and what uh
like he said he's just as good as Trevor
when it comes to like being
accomplishments and what he's
accomplished but
um what he does do very well is when
he's looking he doesn't stop like he
doesn't look down pull the ball down
he's consistent looking down ball
staying in position so he doesn't you
know fumble a lot a lot of quarterbacks
still start going like this when they're
trying to run and things but his pocket
awareness is you know out of this world
he's staying right in posture his
confidence is out of his world so it's
definitely a I don't think it's a guy
where he'll give up very easily you know
he's been doubted his whole life so
um this is just something he'll just
have to overcome I want to go to Kirk
Cousins uh weighing in he is our
quarterback specialist your take on his
tape and and what's in store for Bryce
young now that he's headed to Carolina
yeah it's pretty consensus that he
should be the number one overall pick
his tape really looks like a point guard
he's just very natural play in the
position he's great off schedule he has
a great feel for the game I had a chance
to meet him in Phoenix during Super Bowl
week and was just really impressed with
the with his demeanor I think he's
comfortable in who he is the fact that
he's 5'10 the fact that he's a little
slender he accepts that he's pretty
self-aware and I think he'll step in
that locker room right away and just uh
rub people the right way and I think
they'll enjoy working with him I also
think that um this is a team game and
it's so important to be in the right
situation and I think Frank Reich is the
head coach and as the play caller is a
real positive for Bryce I think having
Andy Dalton in the quarterback room with
him is also a real positive and he
started over 100 games in this league
and is going to be able to pour into
Bryce and just be a great support system
for him all the way through my old
teammate Adam thielen is now there and I
as a veteran quarterback would lean on
Adam for his perspective and what he was
seeing and what he thought about Raul
sir coverage and I think he'll be a
great sounding board for Bryce so
um I think they're in a good spot I also
think of the NFC South it's a great
opportunity for him to go in there and
try to become the best quarterback in
that Division and um you know we'll see
uh how they do but I think he's in a
good spot
Kirk thank you so much so that is the
pick Bryce young officially with the
Carolina Panthers the new era begins
Dave Tepper has his quarterback you
wanted to chime in there I was just
going to say now the feeling thing you
mentioned now you just got surrounded
with weapons I think this was the
correct move for the Carolina Panthers
when you make that big a play I think
you have to take a swing like this at a
guy like Bryce young who's like a
culture changer you know he plays with a
chip on his shoulder even though I
described he really shouldn't because
he's you know this highly touted of a
guy right but he's that kind of guy that
can bring that locker room together and
basically lead you into the future
because you've been going quarterback to
quarterback to quarterback there in
Carolina never really finding the guy
you got the guy it makes it so much
easier to build everything else once
that's the case some of their off-season
additions not just Adam thielen also
added miles Sanders from the Eagles also
added Hayden Hurst at tight end
different weapons and if you think about
it last year they went out there and
they took eke with a first pick so they
already kind of have that tackle this is
the new era one thing that I like about
him as a teammate story that jumped out
to me all that nil money what he did
every single week he took out his
offensive line to dinner with his nil
money and paid for him just little
things that make you want to protect him
what were you going to ask no I was just
going to say here's the thing with for
me with him and again go back to the
check with me check with me stuff yeah
interesting but I also look at the way
that they got a lot of dogs in that
Alabama locker room they got a lot of
dogs they got a ton of dudes in there
and all of them listened to Bryce young
all of them respected his leadership
knew he was the face of this football
team and they respected it and so for me
I think that goes a long way to him
coming into an NFL locker room and
having to be the guy in understanding
the pressure that he's under and
understand that he can rise to the
occasion it is now time to start the NFL
draft because now listen we knew that
Bryce was going to be sure so now this
is the set the other part of this draft
that I love to do is not just breaking
down what happened but what could happen
Mike I'm coming you first Houston right
now what would you do if you are Nick
casario and you're drafting for Houston
and bright this is off the board see the
problem oh no we're like I want to hear
Michael okay yeah see we got to come up
with it okay so you're right I'm going
last names only Parsons okay
um no
uh the Texans are a really good team
like if you look at they even gave us a
nail biter towards the end
um I think their defense is really good
you know I don't think they're really
missing a lot but they are missing that
true quarterback you know they're
missing that that guy on the offensive
guide that's going to deliver
um not make you know bad decisions down
the field so I have to go CJ Stroud you
know you go see Jason I would definitely
go CJ Strife if I'm Texas right now
you you can't really put your faith in
the QBs that you have right now I mean
during our game they had a guy coming in
doing rpos check with me that another
guy's coming on third down to pass the
ball you need a guy that's just going to
be in the game consistency you think CJ
is that guy you need to be that leader I
mean he's LED Ohio State he's made those
big appearances I mean I think he's
really showed that he can be that guy
against Georgia the most dominant
defense gave him 45 yeah uh no one's did
that all season
um so you know uh it's just I'm going
with CJ Stroud they need that it factor
in office they need a guy that's going
to deliver the ball on point on cue yeah
I think he's the most accurate
quarterback
um I think they make they have to make
that choice Renner so there have been
different both defensive ends have been
mocked to them and rumored will Levis
have been rumored CJ strong I think
because of that S2 test people kind of
assumed he was dropping what do you
think and where would you go I think
this is Will Anderson and I'd like the
process because I worry about if I'm
drafting a CJ Stroud if I'm drafting a
will 11 this here
you've seen how rookie quarterbacks have
transitioned the NFL late even Trevor
Lawrence was having a rough time they
got the number one overall pick the next
year if you draft one of those guys
chances are you're picking one two next
year because it's you know they're an up
and coming roster but look at the rest
of the AFC the lcafc is loaded you are
easily the bottom if not the second
worst team in the AFC starting a rookie
quarterback all of a sudden then you're
drafting one two next year and then you
have a weird decision on your hands
where I just drafted this guy I don't
know if he's going to be the guy and I
have Caleb Williams maybe look at me in
the face Drake May Nexus 2B class looks
legit like they Bryce young type of
prospects maybe two of them
I I can't hate the thought process of
maybe passing on this and then trading
for a whether it's a Mac Jones Trey
Lance someone else who's a veteran that
could be available
and going that route Felder I'm curious
I've been hearing this a lot Demico
Ryan's is the coach now he needs his
Nick Bosa is that a Will Anderson is
that a Tyrese Tyree Wilson just from
what you've seen yeah where would you go
I mean I I If You're Gonna Go defense I
would go with Will Anderson I think that
he is he's got this crazy body type like
where he's built kind of like a wasp
like high cut up top slim and then got
big legs like this guy's he's that's
what he's built like so I think that's
going to be really interesting to see
what he ends up what they end up doing
because I do think that they need a
quarterback just like Mike like Parsons
said yeah they need a quarterback but
the rumors are that they don't like CJ
Stroud which is going to be he is the
favorite right now in Vegas right now CJ
Stroud is the favorite in Vegas to go
number two well let me ask you this if
they don't pick CJ Stroud are they going
to regret it
that's that's the question because he's
on the board for you are you going to
regret it if you don't take him what do
you think there's a high there's a high
chance right I mean you go back to 20
where there is a similar situation
Washington 2021 2020 where Washington's
looking at Chase young right over Justin
Herbert right over to uh
over Pat Mahomes too that too and it's
like well I think Chase young is like
seen as willians like those are sure
things sure but even sure things
sometimes if injury strikes what not
turned into not sure things at that
level
he's there
um
he can be better is he a Chase Young
in your mind
bro be real you can't you I I can't put
him on that I don't think you can
compare Chase just because his injuries
like you could look at his first year
and say but do you see will as like
potential of having like a Bosa you got
to compare him to Bosa okay you know
Bosa came back after HCL and won
defensive player of the year so you know
that's the kind of the standard you got
you gotta say can this guy be Bossa and
both I mean even he was rookie of the
year right yep defensive so you're
looking at a is he going to be I feel
like you know do you think he's gonna be
Defensive Rookie of the Year Will
Anderson he has a chance okay DeMarco
ryanco Ryan the pick is in according to
the internet and
CJ Stroud is the guy
so I just want to say quick MVP I love
the reporters that break the news before
they happen on TV Connor Hughes you're
the man SNY we're going to give you a
shout out the Texans go see Jay Stroud
and it makes you wonder which team was
trying to get CJ Stroud to fall but he
doesn't fall they go second overall
second team All-American two-time big
ten offensive player of the year a team
captain he is the leader of the team he
is an MVP and he broke Drew Brees's Big
Ten record for the most touchdowns in a
two-year span with 85 Renner the value
at two I I think he can be flourished
there and Bobby slowik's new offense
that he's bringing over from San
Francisco probably gonna look a lot like
what Kyle Shanahan was doing which is
working the middle of the field with
timing and accuracy what did he do two
years ago with Jackson Smith and jigbo
lighting up you know Utah in the bowl
game for over 300 yards timing and
accuracy over the middle of the field he
is as good as it gets in the draft class
at just that very much a point and shoot
type of quarterback you're seeing some
of these deadly accurate throws on his
tape down the football field 9.7 yards
per attempt first career 85 to 12
touchdown to interception ratio off the
charts production it's just can he do a
little more than that because the game
is evolving to where the point and shoot
the pure pocket passers are going the
way of the dodo we want guys that can
create on their own and when it whether
it was under pressure whether it was
outside a structure that was the thing
that was missing from Stroud's game a
lot of the time but then the Georgia
game yep final game of his career looks
like a completely different player you
tell me I get the Georgia CJ Stroud I'm
drafting them number two and I'm happy
as heck about it but if I'm getting the
rest of the guy like maybe struggled
that time to get some lower Big Ten
teams a little worried but he's still
young only a junior coming out what
grade are we given we're going to give
that we'll go a minus a minus just
because you're concerned about that that
Georgia game by the way 348 passing
yards for four touchdowns and 34 rushing
yards which is what you want to see what
do you think yeah the rushing part for
me like I look at this guy and I see
like he could be like a Proto John Elway
like realistically like when we're
talking about what he brings to the
table remember La was an athlete people
people always forget that but this is a
guy that's got a lot of those same
capabilities a little bit smaller
obviously but he has to be a little
smaller because he's got to be able to
move the thing I want to see out of CJ
Stroud is I want to see him move a
little bit more and you mentioned that
Runner he he really did not want to move
and I felt like a big part of that was
he did not want to get labeled as a
running quarterback so he forced himself
to stay in the pocket he forced himself
to to not use those legs that he has but
then when he did it look at that look at
all that green that's a lot of green to
swim like he could do it he can do it he
just didn't want to do it so if you ask
him to do it I think he can do it for me
this is an apic and I just look at that
and I think they would have truly
regretted not picking him and he would
have made them pay for whatever team he
went to the fact that a Penn State guy
loves this pick means a lot you like
this guy yeah I'm one for one right now
like I said I love him uh you know it's
confidence you know like I said like we
y'all people bring up the S2 and yeah
I'm glad that you know these teams
didn't make the same mistake that you
can say the Jets made or I don't want to
write off Trey Lance because I still
think he can be that guy
um but you know you're you're taking
these bad things because you want these
players to drop and then you leave
someone like Chicago to get them I think
Justin you're talking about Justin
Fields yeah I think he makes a huge leap
from the from last year and he made a
hugely this year with processing getting
better and you see that with CJ Stroud I
see that same thing with CJ Stroud and
I'm glad the Texas took him because I
think Justin Fields is a guy like dang
he's gonna be like a pastor Mahomes how
do we let this guy who's able to move
and throw
far to pick 11 for the Chicago to trade
up and now have DJ Moore with them
Claypool Mooney and you know potentially
some another great player that's about
to come up here I have talked to former
quarterbacks they have all loved CJ
Stroud I talked to Pat Mahomes he loves
CJ Stroud Kirk Cousins I know you love
CJ Stroud as well what do you see from
this guy and how do you think he's going
to fare in Houston
yeah he's a true pure passer he's
probably the best passer of the football
in this draft uh we talked about it
earlier he makes a lot of tight window
throws I watched his couple drives at
Happy Valley against Penn State he made
some wild throws dropping the ball in
the bucket throwing tight Slants first
cover zero the ball just comes off his
hand quickly and accurately I don't
really mind that he's a point and shoot
passer because quite frankly in the NFL
you have to be able to do that and if
you can't the off schedule ability is
secondary to your ability to be a pocket
passer and so accuracy is really that
first and most important trait and he
has it I also think this pick really
shows and I think the rest of these
quarterback picks will show just how
valued the quarterback position is in
the draft Jay Gruden once made a comment
to me about how difficult it is to find
offensive tackle specifically left
tackles in free agency because if a team
has one they don't let him leave their
building and quarterbacks are much the
same way you're rarely going to find one
in free agency I did leave Washington's
building and and go to free agency but
it isn't very common to happen and so
you have to go get your guy in the draft
and many times that will lead to people
reaching for quarterbacks but usually
the upside is worth the risk and with
his arm talent and with his tape I think
the pick makes a lot of sense the
challenge in evaluating a lot of these
guys both Bryce and CJ is they play with
Superior Talent week in and week out
Alabama and Ohio State have the best
rosters in college football that's
always going to help the quarterback
he's got o Lyman they're going to get
drafted he's got multiple receivers that
are going to get drafted in the NFL
especially these teams they're going to
the first couple picks not only will the
talent not be better than their opponent
there's a chance most weeks they might
actually be inferior and so that is a
big adjustment for a guy coming from
these two programs but um when you have
his ability it's a tough uh tough deal
to pass on CJ Stroud officially picked
number two and the new face of the
Houston Texans and D'Amico Ryan's first
quarterback now we get to a team that
really no one's able to predict Arizona
rumors that they might want to move down
pick up more picks Kyler Murray coming
off of an ACL injury rumors that DeAndre
Hopkins might be on the way out it is a
new era Jonathan Gannon is the head
coach former D.C of the Philadelphia
Eagles and a new GM as well uh we sit
here they've been mocked Mr Renner to
get Will Anderson possibly also Tyree
Wilson where are you leaning if if they
do go D end here yeah I'm going Will
Anderson I have John Carter as the top
ranked player available but obviously
his off-field so it's probably gonna
drop it you know what can we see your
big board just to see the best players
available now that we're two
quarterbacks down and then will Anderson
like I see those guys in a similar tier
you're getting a good player no matter
what there's not a lot of risk involved
because they're already like NFL ready
in a lot of ways so if you're the you
know Arizona Cardinals who on paper one
of the worst rosters in the NFL so many
needs I was doing the needs and I could
not stop writing down positions when I
got to the Arizona Cardinals just pick a
valuable guy right just pick a guy who
knows going to be good at a valuable
position chalk up a w because this
roster is in need of w at this point uh
Felder I'm curious I have also heard
rumors that Kyler has wanted them to
take Paris Johnson the offensive tackle
from Ohio State would that be a
possibility for you here feels like a
reach but you got to protect your
quarterback right you've got to protect
them and so if that's what you're going
to do if that's what they're going to do
then maybe find a way to trade back
especially if somebody's in love with
Will Levis or somebody's in love with
with Anthony Richardson so I think that
might be on the board might be why
they're going to take some time on this
because they're going to try to work out
a deal do we have a trade okay there we
go I didn't know if a trade would happen
now becomes two interesting things who
and what are they coming up to get
Arizona is trading the pick so we know
it's a trade so do you know Runner
Texans are moving back up the Houston
Texans who had a second pick at number
12 are moving back up I can't remember
the last time a team did back-to-back
picks and so in the top five in the top
five so they go quarterback and then
would they be trading up here for a Will
Anderson yes yeah that's your prediction
yes Will Anderson there we go you like I
said D'Amico needs his guy yeah wow and
with that he will get
a Defensive Rookie of the Year with Will
Anderson he doesn't have Bosa you know
he doesn't have deal with Eric Armstead
he had a boatload of top players come
out here he's definitely going well and
they take Will Anderson
the Houston Texans just changed the
entire construct of their team they get
CJ Stroud at quarterback they get Will
Anderson on defense that's how you do it
that is how you do it and they were able
to do this by trading the 12th pick that
they got in the DeSean Watson trade to
go and make this possible Will Anderson
is now going to be playing that Nick
Bosa role in D'Amico Ryan's defense and
they still got Malik Collins two-time
unanimous All-American two-time nagursky
a bednarik a Lombardi a two-time SEC
Defensive Player of the Year at Alabama
he was known as The Terminator Runner to
make this move what do you think of the
value here yeah I love it I think you
know like you said demeka Ryan's gets
his guy he said you know you can have
the number one number two pick here let
me still get that blue chip defensive
player that I just know was going to be
a dude and you see him here he has that
way of moving that the Elites at the
next level have that the Khalil Max have
that the Von Miller's have that the
Micah Parsons have that's just easy for
him and he's still kind of raw like he
doesn't have a ton of pass rushing moves
but still gets the job done plays with
great leverage and in that Alabama
defense as well he was like a scheme
kind of played within himself in that
scheme wasn't allowed the freedom to
attack the way that at the next level
when you are a dude you are kind of
afforded and I just think the sky is the
limit for this guy the Texans really if
you're a Texans fan after multiple years
of the DeSean Watson Saga and just being
uh unappealing Team to watch this is
this is like heaven for them show me the
grade we're gonna give that an A plus
wax poetic dude I love this guy I
absolutely love it he's a dude I listen
I told you you got that wasp body this
guy is really strong at the point of
contact he's amazing against the Run we
spent so much time talking about what he
does in the past game and I'm glad that
you mentioned he played within the
construct of that defense which didn't
allow him to do all the things that he
was that he could have done if he if
they if this is a different coaching
staff they probably just cut him loose
but instead he has to play Within this
defense that Alabama system Bingo which
means he has to there's times he had the
wrong arm okay guess what I'm spilling
that play wide there's times that he had
to play contain and hold the edge he
plays hand up he plays hand down this is
a guy that can do everything he's seen
there working within the concert he
could have got off on that play he could
have but he didn't he understood that he
needs to what he understands he needs to
play within the confines of that defense
and they do a really good job I mean
this is someone when I when I look at
him play obviously the names that we've
already said Steve they they stand out
Nick Bosa Von Miller those are guys you
got to compare him to this is an A-Plus
I think they're getting a guy who's
gonna step in step up and he's is going
to make this team better oh and by the
way they also just got CJ strong 34 and
a half sacks Mr Parsons second all-time
in Alabama behind Derrick Thomas this is
what you do when you watch this guy what
do you see uh you can't teach effort and
I mean his effort Run game pass game a
lot of Chase down sacks a lot of Chase
down behind tfls
um and you know that's something like I
would love to have this guy on our team
you know he's a he's that type of player
he's going to give you nothing but
effort nothing but his best and that's
the type of you know I think if I'm
Demico Ryan I'm looking at that that's
why I trade down to get a guy like that
I don't want a guy that's going to take
plays off he doesn't take plays off he's
dominant in the past in a run I mean I I
definitely say it's an A plus grade
myself
um and you know one thing he's really
good at and I think he's gonna get
better at is just being more dominant
with his hands at the attack you know at
this level you're just not gonna be able
to dip under the way he's dipping yeah
they're gonna lean on you they know how
to balance that they know how to
counter-attack that especially a good
one so I think D'Amico gets him there
obviously coaching some of the best
defensive linemen uh so I definitely
think you have a definite defense Rook
of the Year possibly I just want to
check in with Calais Calais your
thoughts on Will Anderson
yeah man I think this is a huge pickup
you know uh you can't teach playmaking
ability I don't care how good of a
player is physically you know this guy's
a knack for making plays you call
instincts and when I see them on the
field you know he can make plays going
inside going outside with power he has
all kinds of moves in his bag and uh
he's just a playmaker man and to stand
out with all that Talent around him I
mean well I watch the games of Alabama
he was by far the best player on the
field you know for two years in a row
and so I love I love uh I love the pick
you know I think he's a stud you know
they got a whole lot better
Runner what do you think thank you
Calais I'll just say this the trade
compensation came out yeah
break it down they gave up so they gave
up their first 12th overall yeah 33
overall
and next year's first though and third
and third if I am wow Arizona I am
jumping up and down that next year's
first if they're starting CJ Stroud and
he doesn't hit the ground running
I mean Arizona could be sitting here in
the same spot that Houston is right now
with a ton of draft Capital right at the
top of the draft I love will Anderson
that's a lot to give up for one will
answer and you know what if they do
let's say want to go offensive tackle
that 12 spot
Pete's going to be there I mean yeah all
that that's literally you know what I I
think oh
baby oh that stopped me in my tracks we
knew they had to pull the trigger on a
quarterback right wow there had been
rumors that the Colts might want to
trade for Lamar Jackson well guess what
they found a dude that is explosive in
every realm Anthony Richardson an
absolute freak of nature for Florida six
career runs of 45 or more yards and just
13 starts set the quarterback record
with a 40 and a half inch vertical the
man is electric I thought maybe they'd
Go Levis here but render the value of
Richardson at four what do you think I
love the pick this one I'm going right
to a plus because of the fit here he
goes to Shane steichen's office oh they
ran they ran the quarterback more than
anyone else in the NFL last year and he
knows how to implement that threat and
there is no bigger threat right now in
the NFL at the quarterback position
running that I'd be more afraid of than
Anthony Richardson this guy ran a faster
40-yard dash than Kyle Pitts at the same
size Cal Pitts number four overall pick
as well at a tight end though this guy's
floor is like a high-end tight end with
an athlete of this caliber the average
12.4 yards per scramble over his career
Kyler Murray only averaged 11.4 he is
electric when he gets out into space his
feel for the pocket I think it's
underrated he had one of the lowest
pressure to sack conversion rates in
this draft class he knows how to evade
pressure he's confident when that
pressure comes it's just the accuracy
that's the only thing if you can tell me
that you can fix this guy's accuracy you
have an elite quarterback at the next
level only less than 400 career pass
attempts felters that worry you or how
do you balance the worry and the
excitement very inexperienced
um compared to some of the other
quarters guys or multi-year starters but
the big key for me when I look at him
obviously the first thing that comes to
mind is Camden right a huge guy but the
big key for me and we talked about this
accuracy and I'm gonna go ahead and give
it I'm going to give it an a
um we talked about the accuracy issues
it's about footwork it's all those
things but the key for me and I mean
goodness gracious watching these things
yeah right look at the way that did you
see that guy make a business decision
he was like no no no not me not today
dog no no no no
and the cool thing for me about Anthony
Richardson is he understood the
assignment he understood what he needed
to do he understood that he had to prove
that he could be a better more accurate
Pastor during the draft process he
showed it at the combine he showed it at
his pro day and so we see all those
things take place he he understands what
he needs to improve about his game and
self-awareness is one of the best things
that you can have as a prospect and I
love that about him uh Micah you're
you're gut feeling here him and Jonathan
Taylor if they're running the option
right at you man that's a tough one to
figure out yeah
um I don't I don't necessarily love the
pick okay like he said I don't I don't
want to be I think the Justin fields and
the Jalen hurts and those guys made this
pick more valuable than it was you know
that interesting threat of the legs and
what's going on in the league right now
guys it's going to be more people to
evade things like it must be a
reactionary to a trend in the NFL right
now yeah I think this is a reactionary
pick I don't see it no other the year
what I think I would see a pig like what
scares you about Anthony Richardson just
a lack of experience you know he doesn't
have multiple Years starting you know
and this year it wasn't like a absurd
dominance where it was like a Joe burrow
year right or like it was like a Dwayne
Haskins year right you know I didn't see
that type of dominance in the air a
visual hot and cold yeah and you know
and and some like you said sometimes not
all the QB player but sometimes at a
fourth pick you want someone that's
going to come in and like he's our guy
you know and we know that and like Mike
said earlier they could be in the same
position as the Texans where they're
like oh well if Richardson doesn't go
well now we're sending out a pick next
year where Drake May and uh Caleb was
right there for us so you know I'm not
seriously extraded but I you could
always prove me wrong I'm not tearing
them down I just think you know he
really wanted to show his true value
they're in the same division him and CJ
so they're going to be compared uh we
should have just asked Kurt was going to
happen because his quarterback rankings
have now gone one two three Anthony
Richardson Kirk how what do you think of
this guy on that Turf in Indy with
steichen's offense
I think everybody's takes there make a
lot of sense I think that steiken's
offense the RPO game is going to be a
positive for him especially early in his
career I think the Cam Newton
comparisons are fair I also think that
uh his upside it probably even goes
beyond cams in terms of what he ran the
40 and what he did at the combine the
armed Talent it probably is even more
than what cam sealing was but as Micah
said you want to see that absurd
dominance that Cam Newton had at Auburn
and I don't know that that that was the
case for him at Florida whereas Cam
Newton was absurdly dominant at Auburn
and so that's sort of the interesting
part of it when you look at his absolute
best plays it's off the charts when you
look at his absolute worst plays those
are also off the charts in the other
direction and so you have to weigh that
but the draft sometimes is about risk
and reward just ask the Texans who
traded up to to make that move I think
when you feel like there's upside and
there's a chance of doing something that
could change your franchise for a decade
you're willing to deal with the risk and
and go for it and um I think that it'll
certainly be an exciting player to
follow in the next several years
absolutely Kirk thank you so much uh wow
so Anthony Richardson goes top five the
Texans trade up take two picks in the
top four and now we're sitting here at
Seattle who I have seen for the last
three weeks Jalen Carter Jalen Carter
Jalen Carter Felder do you think that's
where they're going to go here I
it's a question of need and I think they
have more value and more of a true Edge
guy and that's Tyree Wilson to me so
we'll see how this shakes out Jalen
Carter heck of a football player he can
probably play from a zero to a five but
they need someone that's probably better
playing from a four all the way out to
even maybe that wide nine so this is
going to be an interesting pick whether
they pick the player that they think is
better or they pick the guy that fits
into what they need this is a Seattle
team that everyone thought was going to
be awful everybody thought they're gonna
be awful and they end up going to the
playoffs taking on San Francisco losing
a divisional round I know you love Jalen
Carter like a lot yeah what is it about
him that you would take all the
off-field things and not even worry
about it it's a true dominance like I
don't care you know
understanding where Jalen comes from
that type of stuff is going to happen
and he's just gonna need great
mentorship and Seattle is a place I feel
like handles guys like that and you have
the guy who handled USC's team in the
prime he handled everyone
you're talking about a guy that can
control those type of behaviors and send
him in the right way and then you're
talking about who are they going against
in their division you're talking about a
49ers team who dominated them yes in the
Run game yes not the past game The Run
game I think you have to go carter if
you're talking about run
and pastor's ability to get to those
Brock Purdy's trade lands and slow down
McCaffrey I think inside out he could
play Zero or three right wherever it is
I think Jalen Carter could be that guy
he's that guy Renner if it's not Carter
who else could it be man if it's not him
I don't really know who else you go at
this point around corners I don't think
they really draft Corners that highly
they usually hit on guys later in the
draft Tyree Wilson I could see but I
think his foot injury could cause him to
drop still like only just got medically
cleared this month it really feels like
Carter after that maybe you could go
offensive line but you just got your two
tackles last year there's no cheers
that one's the one that's like a wild
card where he goes because you saw
Gino's contract is such that it's more
of a one year and then hey we'll see and
so they could go that route but just
Jalen Carter makes too much sense he's
too good to pass up at this point when
you're you're competitive right the NFC
is open it is not like the AFC there
there is not this sort of juggernauts uh
left and right at the quarterback
position hey Mike that NFC ain't open
bro
don't just sleep on us like that like
Seattle's interesting because of all of
the picks they have from the Russell
Wilson trade so this pick was a Denver
Broncos pick uh they had the fifth and
20th pick in the first round they also
have two picks in the second round so
this is a Seattle team that made it to
the playoffs and has four picks in the
top 52 they could really do damage if
we're looking big picture here Renner
where else do they want to fill in if
this is a Jalen Carter yeah I think
anywhere along that defensive line they
need to address cornerback they need to
address also could go forward thinking I
know they signed Bobby Wagner but he's
obviously probably a one-year deal could
go linebacker as well and then they also
need a wide receiver everyone's sitting
in their second first round picks
probably where they attack wide receiver
but where they need one achiever is a
slot and there's one slot receiver in
this draft class that's about as safe a
pick as it gets and it's Jackson Smith
The Jig but so I don't think anything's
really off the board here for them there
are still a good number of needs on this
I'm going to give my first opinion
I feel like there's a lot of different
pass rushers that might be there at 20.
I don't think there's a Jalen Carter
that could be there at 20. exactly and I
think there this seemed like and I don't
know if you feel this way Micah there
was like six or seven guys that were
seen as special we've seen four of them
come off the board I think Bijan
Robinson's one of those guys I think
Jalen Carter is one of those guys after
that
like you were one of those guys I feel
like there's a drop off in terms of
Elite Talent yeah I think overall this
class I don't think it's asleep as last
year's class or my class I think last
year my class at least it was like you
can go wrong inside the top 15. wow wow
okay okay in many people's mind the top
cornerback in the draft but I agree with
Renner here they normally go later in
the draft four corners but how about
this the Seattle Seahawks are going
Corner in Devin Witherspoon out of
Illinois
5 11
181 Seattle trying to channel back in
the legion of boom consensus
All-American Big 12 Defensive Player of
the Year defensive back of the year
started off as a zero star recruit
defended 17 passes last year only
allowed one catch of 20 or more yards
Renner Levy Smith said toughest guy on
the team pound-for-pound no one works
harder what do you think though taking
him in at five here I love this guy's
tape here's the top ranked corner on my
board I copped him to Darius Slay just
because the way he plays man coverage is
just he doesn't back down from anybody
he allowed one yard in press coverage
this past season one yard all season now
in the Big Ten wide receivers you can
whatever but one yard is one yard on
over a hundred covered snaps in press
coverage only 206 yards all season long
and 40 of them came on a busted play
this guy got after it and when he did
lose he was back in your grill John you
the next play he hits he's got enough
speed enough athleticism size is the
only thing here 511 181 at corner
doesn't usually go top five doesn't
usually Seattle it's not really Seattle
but they've kind of changed they're not
pure cover three the way they used to be
right in the old you know Legion they're
doing a little different and he's a
great compliment to Tariq woman who's a
size freak you get the guy who can guard
the speedier shifter guys on the other
end and your profit great I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go a flat a it's gonna go away
there we go listen I'm gonna go B
because of the value
but the big key for me is I love what
he's able to do we talk about him in
plain and press talk about him playing a
man but the reality for me is I thought
he was really good in zone coverage I
thought he's probably the best Zone
Corner that we saw and obviously you're
going to see him play some press but you
see him you see him bail right there
this is a guy that can track the ball
really really well he runs down his
troubles you see that right there I love
like if you he didn't give up on that
play he ran down his troubles he was
beat I love the fact that he can Blitz I
love the way that this guy triggers I
just think it's a little early for the
position but again that's something we
talked about off air position is an
interesting point because it's where
people value people but I love the way
that he triggers it's really cool to
watch a guy trigger he's a one-stepper
is what we would call him right he's a
one stepper where when it's up to hit
when he when when he's ready to break
one step and go back in the other
direction I absolutely love it question
for you is the fact that they took him
over Jalen Carter what do you think uh
I'm not mad at it I'm not mad at it
because now we know Seattle's DBS are
set for the next seven eight years yeah
they don't have to worry about a corner
I mean this guy even though he may not
have the same impact that Jalen had he
has the same impact in the backfield now
you have two young Ball Hawk Corners you
you don't have to worry about them
they're going to be sitting on the back
brushers more time yeah dude you're
going to sit on the back burner you
don't have to worry about a big payday
trying to bring someone in and then
you're talking about a guy uh 49ers or
one of the known teams in screens he's
going to come down and hit he's going to
be dominant on the outside uh which
they've been missing so I'm I'm really
not mad at the pick I think this is a
great value pick if you know you have a
guy you have a guy and he Compares slay
I think more Ramsay I think you can play
him inside or out because the way he's
able to hit and Blitz so I I think you
have an all over anywhere in the back uh
and and when you factor in adding in
Julian love and free agency now you have
three corners that can really match up
uh I want to go to AJ Brown who might
have to face off with Mr Witherspoon
when you're watching his film thinking
about going up against him what do you
see of him as a prospect
I think what stands out to me that is
he's extremely physical uh he's a
well-rounded complete DB you know those
guys are really tough matchups uh you go
against every Sunday
I like to compare him to slay as well
you know good in and out his breaks you
know just it's tough but just not I said
tough but uh just tough just
a long day in the office man and you got
to respect those guys I think this is a
great pick to go against to go up with
uh Tariq Woodland you know they got a
couple pieces coming back Jamal Adams is
coming back I I definitely feel like
there's a good pick for Seattle just
like I think your backsplash above the
stove was a great pick too really classy
stuff
[Laughter]
I appreciate you AJ Brown we'll be
coming back to you soon oh so if I'm a
lions fan yeah I'm sitting here and the
last few drafts Droid one they were able
to get Aiden Hutchinson he fell to them
a few drafts ago they were able to get
Penny Sewell he fell to them Detroit's
just been kind of taken the best player
that's kind of Fallen what can you
really say Aiden Hutchin fell to them
yeah I know it was a second pick
Detroit has won I love their off season
as well CJ Gardner Johnson there's just
a lot of energy right now yeah they have
to be sitting here going we might get
Jalen Carter at six yeah oh wow right
like wow yeah wow Dan Campbell kneecap
guy kneecap go bite your kneecaps yeah
wow that's scary stuff man and I mean
they got Aiden they got James Houston on
the edges I mean I wouldn't be mad at
that but I would be they loaded back in
on Corners this off season so I could
see a d-line pick here they love the
trenches well I've seen Christian
Gonzalez possibly a little bit because
because they they let a Cuda go they let
her go so you know
it's tough taking another a top 10
dinner tops okay so I think this is I
have a trade and I have a feeling that
it's the Philadelphia Eagles I have not
heard anything I know there's a trade
I'm just saying that if this is the
Eagles coming up and getting Jalen
Carter bro I'm gonna rub it in your face
so hard and I would be respectful about
it I mean no Arizona is training they
must they got all those picks they got
they're either getting Carter or uh
they're taking Carter yeah or they're
going to take Wilson they just lost SWAT
they lost Zach Allen the free agency
you're right coming up and getting Tyree
Wilson who they could have taken there
at three which makes sense right Brenner
do you already see it no I have it but
interesting for the Lions because they
have another first rounder two second
rounders and a third rounder so to move
back and get more picks so we're gonna
see the turn you're right Detroit has
six and eighteen and in the second round
they have 48 and 55.
wow
oh man so Arizona back a lot of movement
listen we thought this could be a crazy
draft we have no idea I don't think our
what Micah I told you it's not a big
draft class so you've got to get this
special guys you got to get the special
you think they're going Tyree I think no
Jalen Carter's on the board taken wow
you can get this guy and the pick is in
I'm so nervous
Paris Johnson here we go okay so this
there have been rumors that Kyler Murray
wanted an offensive lineman apparently
this is the one that he liked a lot and
the value of getting Paris Johnson at
six is a lot better than getting him at
three and also scooping it up the left
tackle for Ohio State and CJ Stroud is
coming to Arizona consensus first team
All-American 26 starts 13 of them at
left tackle 13 at Right Guard he is
known as the father of the Ohio State
offensive line to trade back and to get
him at six Runner what do you think of
the value there yeah I'm going b-minus
now they played it really well it was a
lot better than drafting him at three
right yes but I do think they kind of
backed themselves in the corner where
they had to go get a guy in Paris
Johnson who
I think it's going to be good I think
he's also a project he had one year
starting at left tackle played Right
Guard the year prior and you just see
him a little loose with this technique
there you see his hands all over the
place feet and arms do not quite work
yet in unison out in space but the guy
is a A plus kid he is going to figure it
out he's going to do whatever it takes
to make himself one of the best tackles
in the NFL they kind of got a little bit
of a log Jam though now in Arizona
you've got Josh Jones who look great at
left tackle filling in for DJ Humphreys
DJ Humphrey's coming back from injury
this year now you have three guys who
are left tackles kind of only Humphrey's
never played right tackle Jones was bad
when he played right tackle weird fit to
see how he goes in there but when your
quarterback makes a demand and you got
to keep him happy and you're a new
regime I guess you got to go do it you
wanna hear something awesome 1999 fifth
round you know who got drafted by the
Arizona Cardinals Paris Johnson Senior
this guy's dad awesome what do you think
of trading up again here at six I think
the value is interesting that's why I'm
gonna go ahead and go with that B minus
well because wow I wonder what that but
the pick is good the pink is good now
the question becomes what is he right
because is he going to still play left
tackle or are they gonna have to kick
him down inside the worst case scenario
is you're paying this much for a guy
that might end up playing golf and
that's the part that's going to be
really interesting for me because I know
I talked to Joshua Perry Joshua Perry
played Ohio State he follows him very
closely but half of the footage that we
have of him is at guard so I'm very
curious to see what it looks like and
that's the reason for the pick so I'm
very curious to watch to find out where
they play him where he has success yeah
and that's going to be the question if
they gave up too much or if they if they
got enough of enough of a value Mike
give me one second Calais Campbell
apparently when you guys made your
grades was a little bit shocked Calais
thoughts on the grades that they gave
for Paris Johnson and also Paris
yeah I think you guys are you know you
ain't giving enough respect I mean this
guy's a great athlete you can see at the
point of attack he's strong he has great
movement um you know I mean I know his
technique was a little bit out of whack
but that's things you could coach if you
give me a good offensive line coach you
can get better at that each and every
year and the fact you play right guard
tells me you can play right tackle as
well so you just position flexibility
and your right tackle has to be pretty
down I mean you have to be pretty good
too like I mean this day and age I mean
we're gonna go find the weak link and
we're gonna go Rush him so he has to be
stopped there as well so I think this is
a great pickup I think he's a great
talent I think with proper coaching you
can develop him and to be a really good
player uh Micah you might be going and
trying to rush to get by this guy what
did you think when you watched his film
I think Paris is really good uh I love
the fact that he could play anyone
online yes I mean that availability and
mobility in the league right now is
tremendous I remember when uh Tyron
Smith came back and we had a bump Tyler
Smith back down the guard who was really
good pick first and everybody said that
was a bad pick and he turned out to be a
really good player for us he was able to
do it because of athleticism the
athleticism the way he's able to move
the way he can swing is great for teams
especially not knowing what type of
picks Arizona could still get because
they still have another pick also his
arm length what was your arm length yeah
I mean my arm length's like a 32. okay
his is 36 and an eight I agree I hate
people yeah I hate to say it say it I
hate people like him for sure stick it
out and keep you at a distance and he's
athletic enough where he can think oh
I'm here now I'm bringing it back now
I'm sitting he can play he can
manipulate the game right so I think
under the right structure yeah I think
in the right coaching he could be a
really good player and I mean at this
point you got to protect Kyler he can't
keep running what's what's also
incredible about Paris Johnson he was
the number one uh offensive lineman in
high school he worked out with Willie
Anderson Cincinnati Legend Bengals
Legends yeah he's been Paris has been
like the number one guy his entire life
Kyler has been like the number one guy
his entire life but uh look Kyler might
not start the year let him kind of
adjust into it pretty good pick uh all
right Raiders are on the clock is there
a team more perfect for Jalen Carter
than the Raiders yeah do they I've heard
a lot of Christian Gonzalez to the radar
what do you thinking Felder I mean I'm
he's there this draft is crazy it's nuts
and we said what do we say after the
quarterbacks those first two
quarterbacks go we get the draft really
starts and so for me
yeah you come into this night thinking
we're going to get Christian Gonzalez
and then all of a sudden you're like
oh there's guys that we didn't think we
were going to be able to get that are
available Wilson uh Carter they're still
there you can well you can still get you
know there's still offensive linemen
that are there too I think we're gonna
see now that one's already off the board
I think we start to see those guys come
off too so it's a game of it's it's a
game it's a draft the draft is about
runs and we haven't seen a run on
defensive Talent only we've only had one
defensive player picked right Will
Anderson so and Devin Witherspoon Excuse
me yes and in one defensive back pick
one defensive lineman one defensive back
so the big key for me is if they're a
team that that needs all they they've
got a ton of needs we saw that on the
thing they were 29th against the pass
defensively they were last in the NF or
30th in the NFL in sacks yeah they were
26 in points allowed and they're sitting
here with Tyree Wilson and Christian
Gonzalez on the board Renner uh the role
of Dave Ziegler what is and Jalen Carter
how do you make a decision right now
yeah the interesting thing is like the
two teams that we thought were like
great situations for John Carter they
passed out like the Lions and the
Seahawks were both situations so there
may not be a lot of other teams willing
to go to bat so he may slide a little
bit more than we all were thinking but
Tyree Wilson to me makes the most sense
here if I'm you know if I am putting
next to Max Crosby because he is that
long versatile that can learn from
Chandler Jones Chandler Jones is a very
similarly tooled player that turned into
one of the most skilled Edge rushers in
football all of a sudden Tyree Wilson
gets to share a locker room with that
guy every day pick his brain that's
invaluable for a guy who needs some
development still raw and has everything
though that you could want from a
defensive end Prosper what do you think
I agree uh the only thing with uh Tyree
the foot I think right I think uh
you know Raiders been missing a lot so I
think they play as safe with this pick
so what's safe
I think Corner Gonzalez Porter
especially helping that back in you
still have Crosby who's been dominant
you still have Chandler Jones shows no
reason to rush on to uh you know Edge
but the only way Jalen Carter makes
sense it and I think they might stay
away from it because it's like can you
handle Vegas with everything right so
you can you gave us a speech earlier
about how it's important to have
somebody to check your ego and all that
stuff do you really think it would be
tough in Vegas like is that a real is
that a real issue yeah but it also comes
out of self-discipline can you have that
self-discipline I know I had character
and I was like imma do everything in my
possibility to stay out of trouble right
and because I only get this opportunity
one time and you know you do got guys
like Max crab you I look at Max as like
a big bro he's a great dude and he even
talked to me about stand on the right
path yeah and you know everything Max
has been through I think he can get his
hands on Jalen but it's still a risky
situation it's Vegas like anything
happening in Vegas and they've been
missing so I think they might play it
safe and go DB here
um knowing you have a domination
would be a great pick for them this is a
team that has to reset anyways and
they're figuring things out but
Christian Gonzalez okay here we go let's
do it let's see I'm so nervous
Tyree Wilson they are not afraid of the
foot and they get what some people there
are some people that say Terry Wilson is
the best pass rusher in this draft
the Las Vegas Raiders
sitting there at pick number seven and
they go with 66 271 Tyree Wilson first
team All-American First Team all Big 12
32 tackles for loss and 28 starts
a pass rush win rate of over 22 percent
which is unreal some foot injuries there
were rumors maybe he can go at two he
goes at seven Runner what do you think
of the value here yeah Wilson has the
uncoachable things you want for
defensive end I think it's fairly good
value
but the things he has are the things you
just won't find in every draft he has
over a seven foot wingspan wow he has a
guitar or a a want to that is unmatched
the guy plays with his hair on fire
every single snap did not come off the
field for Texas Tech goes into contact
with bad intentions and then the way
this guy finishes plays is unique among
guys that size I have not seen a man at
the Collegiate level tackle as well as
he does outside of his frame being that
big usually those guys are a little
clunky in space no he is smooth he
finishes at ball carriers routinely
still a project though you know still
working along he's a fifth year guy
coming out transfer from Texas A M to
Texas Tech over the course of his career
and it kind of was every step of the way
got a little better a little better a
little better until now he's a top 10
pick if he continues that in the NFL you
could see something special what do you
think Felder what's a grade by the way
we're going to go with a I'll go B plus
b plus okay I I love this guy I think
obviously not a lot of folks are
watching Texas Tech football that's why
people are surprised when they see his
name pop up yeah but for me uh when we
watch and play you're gonna get to see
some stuff I'm glad you guys brought up
Chandler Jones because I think that's a
really good comp here where it is a guy
that has that link that is a guy but the
cool thing look at this amen and you
know it's real he got his pants are up
above his knees he knows he's got some
speed he knows he knows how to play and
I love that right there coming down
that's effort that's understanding
that's energy I love that here what
you're gonna see look at this guy make
yourself a little skinny nope nope nope
okay I'm still gonna keep working and
that's the that's the effort that you
were talking about Runner it's the idea
that this guy never stops he's got a
he's got a clock that just keeps going
and then you see there that tackling
ability as we saw so I think Chandler
Jones is a great comp I think the big
thing for me I'm gonna give this one an
a because remember this is a guy that a
lot of people had going in the top five
yeah you're gonna be able to get him
where seven okay let's go what do we
think about this player Micah uh
definitely a working project
um he's he's playing a lot in a
two-point if you're going playing a two
point you got to be a little bit more on
the speed side yes but definitely the
tangibles you look at is there uh you
could say the Chandler Jones I mean it
fits well with their prototype with Max
Crosby right they like tall defensive
ends uh I think that'll be a nasty three
head rotation he could learn from these
guys that's the difference like he has
Chandler and Max you can learn from so
that's a huge win for the Raiders and
you're looking at like Chandler he
probably he has two one or two years
left on his deal so you got a guy who's
gonna learn from them from a year and
then walk right into a dominant job and
be a dominant factor and you're facing
twice a year
Patrick Mahomes and Justin Herbert you
need to get after the quarterback 84 and
a half inch wingspan Calais Campbell you
watch this guy I'm watching Tyree Wilson
lift up the commissioner right now what
did you think when you put on Tyrese
film
I mean so I start with violent hands the
man plays with violence yes and then you
see him standing up and like you know
I'm a six eight guy you know I came out
in the lead I was 272. he's uh you know
271 yep and I see this athleticism I'm
like man this dude is frequently
athletic because if I stood up like that
you know I'm falling down by 50 of the
time but this guy comes in and is
throwing guys spinning around you know
getting to the ball carrier and he's a
great tackler you know I feel like um
you know uh I mean this this guy is
really the top two top three you know
talent in the draft and for you to give
me that seven you know that's a great
pickup Runner uh thank you so much
Calais I it's so funny when you think
about height and weight and you go wow
he's like the same he's like around the
same weight as Calais but the difference
in skill what were you going to say I
was gonna say so he mentioned they're
the same size coming out class obviously
Trends then more towards the middle as
his career goes on on the interior I
think you get Wilson to see the field
when Chandler Jones on the field when
Max Crosby's on the field right now
because he has that interior versatility
played some on the inside so it's not
just like a oh wait two years until
Chandler's gone it's like a hey tomorrow
we can get all three of these guys
attacking quarterbacks
okay I'm freaking out because I just
keep looking at Jalen Carter on the
board and the Eagles are coming up some
can we look at renner's Chicago
you think so oh yeah oh you just you're
just nervous
Chicago
You're just nervous let's look at the
big board because Atlanta is up Atlanta
has been mocked throughout this process
uh maybe they go Corner maybe they're
the team that takes Bijan Robinson we
still have two quarterbacks left uh will
Levis Hayden hooker not in this range
Jalen Carter is the one that's falling
right now Atlanta really doesn't need
offensive line help they do need
defensive line cornerback you still have
Christian Gonzalez they did trade for a
Cuda which could be a move here uh
Renner what are you thinking right now
I'm thinking I saw who it was you did
do
okay it's the B word
[Music]
all
week
wow this is actually my worst case
scenario right now as an Eagles fan if
it goes Bijan and then Jalen Carter
right before Oh that'll be real sad
um all right wow I
Atlanta the last few years has invested
in stars on the offense first of all
they went Kyle Pitts then they went out
and got Drake London and now they get
the running back in the draft Bijon
Robinson unanimous All-American doke
Walker Award winner averaged over six
yards per carry in last year nearly 1600
rushing yards 18 touchdowns and he also
had 19 catches and they said he caught a
lot more in practice to get him here at
eight Renner what do you think this has
Arthur Smith head coach there's
fingerprints all over it you go back to
his time with Tennessee and when he had
Derrick Henry and how he had that
offense humming he goes to Atlanta they
were the Run heaviest team in the NFL
last year and weren't even like ahead in
a lot of games when they're running a
ton that is their identity they want to
run the football they're going to run
the football they want that threat they
want that guy in the backfield at every
single other defense every time he's out
there has to account for and that's
Bijon Robinson he is to me as clean a
running back Prospect as you'll see
whether it's Vision contact balance he
broke 104 tackles last year that's the
most of any player in the last nine
years in college football
home run speeds maybe not Elite but he
ran in the four fours like there is just
not an aspect to his game that I would
worry about when translating to the NFL
and that's why Arthur Smith wants that
guy behind a now good offensive line
that they have in place
they got the makings of the one League's
best rushing attacks and what grade are
we giving it we still can't go too high
because that immediately makes them I
believe a top 12 highest paid running
back in the NFL to get drafted where he
is the value I'm gonna go I'll go be
minus with that he's a damn good player
you're getting a dude yeah it's just
you're passing on other dudes yeah
that's the thing you're passing on Jalen
Carter 3 400 career rushing yards fourth
all-time in Texas history behind Ricky
Williams Cedric Benson or Earl Campbell
and he did that in just three years is
he a Felder guy I love him I absolutely
love this player I don't love him at
this pick but I love this player he
reminds me I see we've had LaDainian
Tomlinson up there I go with Reggie Bush
Reggie Bush that's why he wears number
five yeah Reggie Bush was ahead of his
time Reggie Bush did all the same stuff
that bijan's doing they just know how to
use him now and that's the difference
they didn't know how to use him and he's
going to be a lot more valuable in the
NFL because he's someone that can play
in the slot he can play in the backfield
he can play in a two-back field he has a
lot of ability and you see him there
he's strong through contact I love I
love his game I I have I'm gonna go
b-plus because you are getting something
that you can use and by the way Arthur
Smith he played offensive line he's
worked on that offensive line you know
who Arthur Smith play college football
with
me really yeah yeah wow yeah
I've also been told that I kind of look
like Arthur Smith so maybe we'll pull up
a picture of him later and go a little
split do I look like Arthur Smith I
don't know uh you went to the same
school as saquon yeah I've heard him
also compared to saquan what do you
think about him on the Falcons uh I like
to pick I think uh in the you know in
the past
you know three years David very devoted
to his offense last year they take a top
10 wide receiver Drake London yeah
before that Kyle Pitts at four and now
they're taking Bijon obviously they're
trying to surround their team with young
talent and loaded in I mean you know
people hate the you know I could see
where I you would take you don't want to
take a running back early especially
with the train running backs aren't
valuable but at his point guys like
saquon McCaffrey every down backs are
valuable right he catches he runs he's
elusive he he moves well you know you
could use play action with him he's at
every down back yeah those guys are
those top 10 selections so I'm not
necessarily mad at it I see why
everyone's upset with it but I mean he
hasn't faced a lot of adversity with
injuries healthy he's the best back on
the board I don't hate to pick and now
now you could finally stress the field
now you're not they can't focus in on
Drake and Kyle like right before you
can't just say well you I know you can't
beat me in a running game and you give
someone on opposite end with Cordell
yeah you know so now I love where
they're going with this offense
dangerous and it's looking dangerous so
Atlanta has gone young offense in the
draft and they loaded up in vets and
free agency Jesse Bates at safety uh
they went Bud Dupree Jeff acuda and one
of those also was Calais Campbell Calais
Campbell joining us now you have a new
teammate in Bijon Robinson you know I
kind of I can see him running the other
team's defense in the ground and giving
you guys a break huh
yeah you know what I mean I say this
Arthur Smith's gonna get the best out of
them so I feel like for him he went to
the best place he can go to I know you
know running backs aren't usually
drafted in the top ten and um you know
when they are they better be special you
know and I I was a part of the Jaguars
when they drafted Linda for that fourth
right and we went to the NFC
Championship uh FC championship game
that year you know and that was that was
pretty cool we were at you know 10
points you know in the fourth quarter
against the Patriots you know when the
Eagles end up winning it that year uh
and so it's kind of crazy how like these
you know the years are kind of similar
you know wow you know I took a chance
going to Jacksonville now taking the
test score to Atlanta and I see the
potential I see the the talent that's
there and I'm like man I think this is
gonna be a huge pickup but I think this
guy is special I'll watch him on table
might go wow like his contact balance
his vision his uh you know change the
direction and then he has speed that
initial burst which is huge and I know
Arthur Smith's going using the right way
and I feel like if you know in football
and playoff football you know uh is run
the ball play good defense even though
you need a quarterback who can make the
proper throws in his crucial moments and
uh go get the two minute you know points
on the board you know I think we have
that with Desmond River so I think this
is a great pickup Calais is saying I'm
gonna start with the Super Bowl run
Micah hold on hold on hold on hold on we
have a trade we have a trade and it is
the Eagles what do you who told you that
don't worry about it inside sources we
have it oh my gosh
are you telling me the Eagles are gonna
move up and take the best player in the
draft Jalen Carter I am all right now
you're talking about another guy who
knows how to control oh hold on a second
is it happening Micah it's happening
we're sick I'm sick
the Philadelphia Eagles baby moving it
up one pick to take Jalen Carter I'm
sick wow I can't believe Chicago did
this wow I am just sick wow I am just
sick one more time wow the first team
All-American guys oh he was able to dunk
in fifth grade I am just sick apparently
he would have been like Zion if he kept
playing he went to the same high school
as Warren Sapp he blocked two extra
points and one field goal oh guess what
on his tape Micah he played next to
Trayvon Walker and Jordan Davis and he
was the most disruptive guy on the field
and now you get the face of twice a year
Jalen Connors how do you feel I'm just
sick you're sick I'm just sick can I
tell you that your sickness is making me
feel even more I'm excited I'm just so
sick to my stomach right now not only
does he have veteran Predator uh next to
Fletcher Cox Jordan Davis for like the
next five years that is not just having
the Kobe Dean oh yeah Nicole we're just
Georgia North yeah I just think it was
like Jordan but I'm just sick I'm just
sick to my stomach right now I'm just
sick to my stomach I can't believe that
many teams passed up on me yeah it's
gonna be okay it's gonna be okay
I'm just truly just sick right now wow I
just uh you know what before we do the
pick let's go to AJ Brown uh AJ Brown
hey how you doing Eagles fan Adam lefko
here uh Jalen Carter is now your
teammate and people say he's the best
player in the draft and how he moved up
to get him at nine your thoughts
I would definitely say
Micah I know you want I know you just
just be a Philadelphia Eagle at this
point is great this great organization
come on he got Fletcher Cox Hassan
Reddick uh Jordan uh Davis uh to go to
go along with
man the defense is is crazy right and
then the value of it they Harvey who
just got 85 million and now you're
coming now you're going to pay someone
for 20. you know the value I'm just so
shocked 19 18s let Jalen Carter fall
tonight for this come on man come on bro
just just come on over sure
the value that I pick is crazy you like
Javon Hargrave a 10 plug sack D tackle
go you get signed for 85 and you get the
value of 20 I mean that's the eight plus
pick like AJ AJ do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
your thoughts on uh Jalen Carter what do
we think about this guy
yeah I mean he was the best player in
the draft in my opinion you know I think
uh I mean I watched him all over the
table last year this year and I mean by
far he stood out amongst a whole bunch
of great players too I mean it's crazy
just to see his uh his his play-making
ability is a lateral quickness his
violence his ability to uh I mean he has
he has every every tool in the toolbox
to me I feel like uh the rich got richer
because the Eagles already had such an
incredible d-line and then they bring
this young guy in kind of you know learn
from and kind of replace Fletcher Cox
you know over the next couple years and
uh you know I mean honestly he's the one
guy who I feel like he's probably you
know one of the best deal I mean I've
seen in probably like four or five years
and uh you know I think he's gonna be
one of those guys that can be on a gold
jacket one day you know that's a big
statement it's early he is preventing
the NFL but when I see him in college
and well you know and I watched a lot of
college football you know he has a
chance to be that guy
can I can I get an ISO really quick
can I get an ISO
Micah Parsons is so sick
AJ Brown is ecstatic Calais Campbell
just said that this guy could be wearing
a gold jacket
need a cold shower over there I'll do um
this is this is one of the greatest
nights ever uh Renner the value uh for
Jalen Carter at nine I have to Echo
everything clay has just said that he's
the most talented all-around dtfc in
eight years doing this he he just he has
everything he has to get off he has the
hands he has the power it's just are you
gonna get the effort right because
listed at 300 by Georgia goes to combine
314 three weeks later it's pro day 323.
and you're going to get a guy who's
going to show up to work every day but
he's in the perfect spot to do it he's
with his teammates that were there at
Georgia when he was at his best and the
Kobe Dean Jordan Davis the three most
impactful guys on that Georgia defense
that was the best modern college
football defense
Harry Roseman continues to prove that
the draft ain't that hard you just have
to pick up you just have to pick up the
edges when they fall and he picked up
the edge when it fell to him your grade
A plus my Lord
Felder yeah I mean what do you want to
say like this is amazing like it's
unbelievable yeah I'm gonna give it an A
plus I'm waiting for his grade to go
down
but the reality for me um watching him
play is he was a guy and I had Aaron
Donald I see we have KK short on there
yeah I got Aaron Donald on there and the
big key for me is his his ability the
plethora of moves obviously he's someone
you do have to you want to monitor that
effort but he's got teammates there guys
that he already knows in the building
they're gonna do it so I'm gonna go
ahead and give it my a plus I want to
hear what Micah thinks because obviously
not only are you gonna have to play your
team's gonna have to play against him
but when you watch him as a player what
did you think just as a player let's say
you know what let's take the Eagles off
the board yeah let's let's not even talk
about it Carter
even I'm not one I might be sick to my
stomach because I wish the Cowboys could
have got this guy but
I'm I'm extremely happy right for the
situation yes yeah he's going to go into
a situation where you can't double team
you got Josh sweat you got Hassan Ray
you still got Frederick and they stay in
a five-man front and the value of what
the Eagles have done you let go of a 90
million dollar a year I mean not a year
yeah 90 million dollar contract guy and
get a value now you have a guy locked
for the next four or five years for 20
25 million I mean just the value of all
I mean I thought he was the best player
in a draft I mean but like you said what
what guy are you going to get out of him
I think he even had a leadership his
friends to have his back yep he's not in
this situation alone and that's a great
like and people forget that point like a
lot of people mess up it's because you
don't have anybody in the NFL right
they're not it's not like cause where
you're with your friends you're and
you're it's like back in college hey
let's make sure we had workouts early
we're gonna wake up we're in a dorm room
together you're living alone you're on
your own and some people struggle with
that transition because in high school
you got someone College you have someone
and approach is like oh I'm by
myself yeah right so you know the fact
that he has that leadership his guys
with him who's going to stay on top of
them I just think this is just let's go
to his teammate one more time AJ Brown
you got more to say
yeah I can definitely just add on to to
what Michael say I speak on behalf of
the Eagan Eagles organization man we
have some great guys in the d-line room
Fletcher College Brandon Graham Josh
sweat man those guys are leaders we have
great mentors so I think it's a great
pick for us uh
his play on the field is going to speak
for itself but you know those guys have
done it at a high level and those guys
gonna Mentor him and like he said he
does have friends in the building so uh
this is a huge pick for us I know Micah
uh
I know you're from Philly you might as
well just come back home baby
we'll welcome you open arms because I
know I know it just looks too good you
got to be a part of this you've got to
be a part of it and we got The detackle
Equalizer I'm not I'm not I'm not too
scared right now we got the D Taco
equalizer he gonna neutralize everybody
in front of him Zach Martin is
we got the equally I sound good and that
is one person
wow we still got Hall of Famer amazing
Jalen uh AJ thank you so much Jalen
Carter uh that was that was uh truly an
iconic moment I didn't think it was
possible I kind of wanted Bijan but I
didn't think Jalen Carter would be there
and he is yeah uh now we don't know the
what they did to move up one spot to
fourth in 2024 that's all
that's insane huh
they gave up a fourth next I think they
go Peter
bears go Darnell right offensive tackle
from Tennessee wow
I'm mad at that I was thinking Peter I
knew they were going to go Ola I was
thinking Peter as well I was thinking
Peter coming from Northwestern already
10th pick Bears move down to make it
Darnell Wright first team all SEC you're
right did not allow a sack in 2022 and
one of the guys he didn't allow a sack
to was Will Anderson 42 starts played at
right tackle left tackle and Right Guard
double digits at both tackle positions
for an offensive line that needs to make
time for Justin Fields this guy to me
was the most physically impressive
tackle I saw on tape his ability to get
off at 333 pounds he's no spring chicken
there to be able to get off and find
linebackers like that in space you don't
find that every day and he plays with a
little nastiness he figured out how to
use his hands a lot better this season
three years as a starter before this
really wasn't considered a top prospect
because his tape was that bad all of a
sudden this year goes up against Willy
Anderson that Alabama game allowed one
pressure all game long you really took
it to another level is just are you
going to get that guy and is he going to
continue to improve because there are
still some things that he needs to
improve upon but this is a swing for the
fences when you have the rushing
threatened Justin Fields this is a guy
who can collapse Ace line a side of the
line all on his own and
I it's a little high for me oh it's a
little high so we're gonna go B but I
think he's a guy that if if he hits if
you hit on this pick it's a it's a
high-end hit he has all pro type of
potential yeah uh he reminds me a little
bit of um ikikano remember that nasty
guy coming out of NC State yeah that's
what he's got it he he channeled in that
nasty streak in this last season that's
why he really has climbed up draft
boards this is somebody that I thought
might be there later on in the draft uh
for for teams in the 20s but now he's
already there's a he's a top 10 pick now
and this is gonna be really interesting
to see how this takes how it shakes
itself out but the Bears there are three
things that you can do to help your
quarterback you can but you can build up
your defense so that they get he gets
the ball back quicker you can get him an
offensive weapon or you can go ahead and
they got they just got DJ more right yes
so they went ahead and said you know
what we're gonna do we're gonna help
help him out up front we're gonna help
the offensive line I think this is an
apic he is a really good football player
I thought he would stick around a little
bit longer I'm very I'm very interested
to see if we this is is this the run is
this it are we going to start to see
skoronski come off we're going to start
to see Broderick Jones come off this is
going to be really interesting to see
how this shakes itself out Micah before
I go to you I want to go to Calais
Calais you had a chance to watch Star
now right what do you think of him as a
tackle Prospect
yeah I think he's a great player you
know I think uh it starts with his
ability to I mean pass block you know
and and he has you know contact balance
uh good leverage you know uh just a
great athlete and then I mean I see him
in a run game too I felt like uh you
know he's a Muller to run game and I
felt like this day and age you know when
you want to go early for a tackle you
want somebody who can play both running
and pass you know and have that balance
to do both uh I think he's just physical
you know that nastiness you got to have
his office alignment especially top 10
picker let me get top 10 pick I want
someone who's just nasty ruthless you
know try to finish guys left and right
and what he did guess what I understand
I think is really what's you know what
made him a top 10 pick you know because
that guy is just so special and dominate
everybody for any given one pressure you
know it was quite spectacular but I
think the biggest thing is he he's a
white tackle you know uh and I think
that you know these days white tackles
are just important is left and uh you
know he sure he can do you know in the
Run game screen game
um in pass game I mean he's a beast
you've heard a lot of thoughts here
Micah Parsons yeah what do you think uh
Great Peak uh like I said Chicago was on
a mission you did exactly what you had
to do
um before the draft during the draft you
won a guy like this you know Justin
Fields isn't just a pastor he's a runner
too and Chicago likes to run the ball so
I I'm not mad at this pick he's a great
run blocker he's a great uh pass blocker
and if you're able to shut down a guy
like Will Anderson you're you're okay
you know what I'm saying you're talking
about team who just gave up two firsts
to go get a guy yeah you know that's the
type of level of guy he was able to slow
down and if you could do that NFC you're
okay uh you can say it was early but
he's a first round Talent sure no doubt
about it so you know they got their guy
so that's all that matters pick is in
this is a team that we weren't oh there
it goes and there it is the Titans Go Mr
skoronski the offensive lineman from
Northwestern Tennessee is a team that is
going through rebuilding right now and
they know what they need it the
Tennessee Titans a lot of rumors they
might go quarterback what could they do
they go a unanimous All-American big ten
offensive lineman of the Year 33 starts
at left tackle the only tackle in
college football with 830 or more snaps
oh and six or fewer pressures allowed
going to this Tennessee team Runner what
do we think getting him an 11. in my
notes I call them the offensive tackle
version of Bryce young the only problem
I have with them is the size he has 32
and a quarter inch arms the that would
tie the shortest arms of any tackle in
the NFL Braden Smith currently that
holder for the Indianapolis Colts to the
right tackle I think he can play tackle
though the way he uses his hands is so
crafty so Advanced you just know you're
getting a darn good offensive lineman
with Peter scarancy and if you're the
Tennessee Titans who have seen their
offensive line with Taylor laon
obviously getting injured not being on
the roster anymore Jack hocklin
obviously going a few years ago you've
just seen it degrade from those Prime
Derrick Henry years need to get back to
making that a strength because that's
the identity of their football team and
swarovsky's just another like I said
earlier you chalk up a w when you draft
a guy like Pierce karonski you know
you're getting a good player maybe it's
at guard ultimately but even then he's
going to be a damn good one great I'm
gonna go with an A plus for that one
that's a great yeah 11's pretty special
I got one thing here for you Felder uh
it's in his family yes his grandfather
was on that Packers offensive line for
Vince Lombardi that won five
championships and two Super Bowls this
is a guy that it's in his blood and now
he's going to a team that when they were
great with Rabel it was all the
offensive line what do you think of him
oh I I love this pick I mean this is a
guy I had him as the best tackle I
thought it was the best tackle reminded
me a little bit of Jordan it reminds me
of Jordan Gross I don't know if you guys
remember the Panthers yeah but he played
but how long did he play 10 years yeah
and he was very very good and the
Panthers needed him so that's why I go
though Jordan Gross on here think he is
going to play tackle I think the because
he's so crafty with his hands because
he's so crafty with his footwork because
he has the ability to not get over his
skis and obviously you see there pass
that off pick it up and I think that the
big key for me is that he's gonna go
somewhere that yes they need him yes
they want to use them in their office in
the Run game but he's also going to be
good in the pass game so this is for me
with Peter skerowski I am going to go a
plus he was my number one tackle I think
he's really good I think he's got such
great play skill play discipline and I
think that's important when you're going
to be trying to again get back to
running the football the way they had
before work ethic is Elite out of baware
the pass rusher that's also in
Northwestern said facing him in practice
was like playing chess he knew
everything that I was going to do yeah
what did you think about this guy on
film I thought he was a great guy great
pick I'm not too worried about his arm
length or anything like that because
we've seen Rashawn Slater come out and
go All Pro Bowl same team so you gotta
understand he's the guy who obviously
worked with Slater he understands what
it takes a guy who's seen it already so
I'm really not mad at the pick and
especially losing Taylor who won
releasing Taylor one he also released a
couple other guys rebuilding that
offensive line for Derek Henry if you
decide to keep him it's a great value
pick uh a plus pick for sure Mr Calais
Campbell your thoughts on skoronsky go
into the Titans
yeah I think he's uh he was the uh the
most uh polished left tackle you know I
think he's got the experience right and
you see his game you see his Poise you
know he doesn't really fall for a lot of
the head fakes he just stays in position
moves his speed gets his hands on guys
and he's a you know he looks like he's
already All Pro uh holder now I won't
say he's all pro player but when he gets
his hands on guys he's gonna let go you
know that's that's a that's a try you be
in the NFL because we got to break your
hands down get him off you somewhere
another and I just see you can send some
guys you know come off too easy so uh
he's the guy you want to make sure you
don't let him grab you uh but on top of
that I think he's just um you know just
I mean a pair of pass a pass blocker uh
physical uh you know I think he's uh you
know the most solid and uh safest left
tackle you could have in the draft
and at this point to get that at 11 is
pretty special Calais Campbell thank you
so much Detroit is on the clock uh they
have two first round picks they have 12
and 18. if you remember they were at six
Arizona came up took Paris Johnson
they're now at 12. do you already know
Runner no I do not okay but I do think
Christian Gonzalez who a lot of people
mocked him at six yeah to still be on
the board here you can get you can get
both of the things you want exactly
let's take a look at renner's big board
you think tight end this early okay I
mean we can't say this earlier when
we've seen guys like Noah fan Hawkinson
guys like that go early in the draft if
you were to go tell them would you go
Kincaid or mayor Kincaid Kincaid I think
Kincaid like he says the best tighter
than draft I seen this man
single-handedly take over games yes
inside out yeah going against nickels uh
High Point in the ball I think Kincaid
after losing Hawkinson I think and
you're talking about building on this
team you got Swift you got jmo you got
these guys around I wouldn't be too mad
at a wide receiver tied in right here
especially because how good your defense
play towards the end of the year I'm
gonna say that I'd be shocked if it
wasn't Christian Gonzalez I just feel
like of all the players that I've seen
in mocks for top ten he's the only one
that hasn't been drafted am I shocked
uh wow wow
the Lions go Jamir Gibbs there was
discussions about whether running backs
should go in the top ten we have two
going in the top 12. Jamir Gibbs from
Alabama five nine 199. second team
All-American only one drop in 52 targets
zero fumbles in Alabama at 195 touches
let Alabama in rushing receiving and
kick return yards the man is absolutely
electric I wasn't expecting this were
you expecting this I was not expecting
this I thought he could sneak in the
first round I thought he probably would
the second the back end 12 is not
sneaking in the first round that is a
full first round stamp on him he is
electric though but the thing is he's a
little redundant to DeAndre Swift in
that office they're both passengers
first space backs but you're not going
to find too many more space backs better
than Jamir Gibbs 436 speed only two
drops on 105 catchable in his career can
go out and split wide and be a basically
a lot wide receiver if you want them to
even though they got a pretty darn good
one there in Detroit
it's high right you have other needs on
this roster besides running back but you
have the dominant offensive line in
place this was an offensive line last
season that was a top three unit in the
NFL it is not going to take a step
backward whatsoever with the talent they
have the young Talent there guys like
penne Sewell Jonah Jackson still
ascending as players they're trying to
take that running game to a level that
is Unstoppable Shamir Gibbs can maybe
get you there but I do just think they
were so there are other needs on this
defense besides that are they may be
regretting come next Fall process his
talent and the need what's the grade
we're gonna go man I'm gonna go C plus
okay uh Jamir Gibbs I want to say Felder
this man ran a 4-3-640 a one five one
ten yard split but I have to say this is
a team that already has DeAndre Swift
and they signed David Montgomery yeah
both of them are on the team makes you
wonder are they going to use him maybe
as a slot wide receiver in some way what
do you think of this pick well this guy
kind of reminds me a little bit of Alvin
Kumar right he has his this ability to
be all he's a gadget piece all over the
place you can play him in the slot you
can here's the thing you keep mentioning
they have DeAndre Swift put them both in
the game yeah what's wrong with having
two DeAndre Swiss put him put them both
in the game and the cool thing about
that and I like I would love after I
wrap up after I do my grade I would love
to hear the Microsoft on this but if you
put them both in the game with the tight
end that's that's 21 Personnel it's 21
Personnel that means you gotta keep your
base package on the field except for
both of these guys they can run and make
catches so this is now it's a problem
for linebackers or for a defensive end
or if it's a safety that's got to have
peptical one of these guys but they can
sit there and be at the number three in
theory from outside to inside one two
three but that means you might be like
messed up on a linebacker I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go with b-plus here a little
early for me thought he was a guy who's
gonna sneak into the first round right
but he didn't sneak in he came in and
kicked the doors down but Mike what do
you think about that like them being
able to manipulate it I think he's
definitely a matchup problem anywhere
you go I mean you can't name two
linebackers who's gonna stick with him
no I could probably maybe count two or
three me Fred maybe Leonard or you know
some gadgets maybe Jamin Davis with his
speed all right you know but I mean
overall he's a massive nightmare but the
value of the pick I'm not like I said
like they said I don't think that early
was that you know I standing with a pick
especially when you have DeAndre Swift
and you have other needs and there's
other talent but like I said I don't
think this draft is so loaded with that
much talent or who they truly believe in
yeah
we state that we say corner but they
sign like six guys in the back end so
you're like man if I can't get value out
of these guys and I mean DeAndre switch
gonna be up for a deal next year so
you're possibly thinking well we let
Jamal Williams go well now we know we
got Jamir against for the next three
four years if that's the mindset they're
thinking of future in the program but uh
not a totally obsessed with the pick but
I think it was uh I think he's a great
player be around for a long time and
he's going behind one of the best
offensive lineman in this so there's no
drop off for what he's been sitting
right can I just say this too can we
just give some respect put some respect
on Georgia Tech's name too yes two years
of Georgia Tech can we just do that too
I know he went to Alabama All-America
yeah but he was he was really good at
Georgia Tech and it's a very different
system than Alabama so I think there's
some scheme versatility to his game
uh Bryce young went well Anderson went
uh Jamir Gibbs now goes that's three uh
what's what's impressive too what's very
interesting to think about Detroit's
draft right now is they pass on Jaylen
Carter they pass on all those Corners
then they go back down I'm wondering if
they're thinking about their 18th pick
and they've done the math and they're
like we think some of these guys might
last or there might be right based on
what do you thinking Renner but wouldn't
you think Jamir Gibbs would last thing
that's what I'm wondering is if one of
these other teams if they were worried
was going to take Jamir Gibbs but uh
their division rival the Green Bay
Packers are now on the clock uh Aaron
Rodgers that is the big story officially
now in the New York Jets uh before we
talk about the Packers if we could bring
in Kirk Cousins uh I'm just curious Kirk
what has it been like for you as a
quarterback to watch Aaron Rodgers
officially leave this team get traded to
the Jets what was that like to watch
Harry's happy
well it was kind of a slow process right
I mean he kind of toyed around with it
for a while and the team talked about it
and you weren't sure if it was going to
happen or not people would ask me you
know what do you think is going to
happen in your Division and I said I
really have no idea and then he made it
clear he was intended to move to the
Jets but the trade didn't happen so it
took a while but um it was kind of
inching that way and with Nathaniel
Hackett as the OC in New York I think
it's a really good fit for him you happy
he's on the division anymore very
comfortable there
yeah I mean certainly you know anytime
you you have a Hall of Famer who was an
MVP two of the last three years I mean
that's that changes the neighborhood
quite a bit when he leaves the division
so well
um you know we'll we'll take it it will
be Jordan loves team thank you so much
Mr cousins uh some of the guys at the
Packers have been uh rumored to maybe go
after tight end Dalton Kincaid is a
possibility here offensive lineman there
are still a bunch on the board Wright
scaronski have have been taken off but I
I feel like there is some depth here if
they want to go Broderick or something
what are you thinking I got so the top
four players in my board obviously will
let us at the top but then you have
Jackson Smith and jigba Christian
Gonzalez Lucas Van Ness Dalton Kincaid
all four of those guys have a role in
Green Bay if one of them at the pick and
the pick is in and it's Mr Van Ness wow
oh I can't wait to hear Micah this one
uh okay the Packers
officially
the pick that they got in the swap for
Aaron Rodgers is in second Team all Big
Ten
no starts but he did have 13 and a half
sacks grew up outside of Chicago well
now he's going to play for the pack
blocked two punts did not start but he
pretty much played starter level steps
snaps this is one of your favorite guys
in the draft Lucas Van Ness now going to
the Packers yeah I'm a big fan of his
game and he's an ascending player 272
you look at four five eight forty his
get off and how low he can sink into his
bull rush is just rare and gives him a
high floor in my opinion you don't find
too many guys with that ability that
kind of flexibility to just continually
walk guys into the pocket he just did
not get stopped on those bull rushing
reps and still young only a true Junior
coming out not played a ton of football
you see this guy's career art could go
through the roof if he gets some more
tools to his toolbox still pretty raw as
you mentioned not really even a starter
there at Iowa this past season but a
really unique athlete the Packers love
unique athletes on the edge and now have
two big long explosive dudes that are
just gonna perhaps the park from both
ends and him and rashan Gary not a huge
need but a guy that I I think really
fits what they want to do defensively
now yeah Joe Barry now has Kenny Clark
Preston Smith rashan Gary and now Lucas
Van Ness a lot of big dudes for a
defense that was 26th in the NFL against
the Run what do you think about this guy
oh yeah are you happy as a package I'm
very happy as a Packers fan truthfully
because I think that's two guys like
that two big long defensive ends the way
they have it now it's just a great way
to build a roster in my opinion yeah no
I love the you brought up Rashaan Gary
being being long being a big guy too uh
playing that position so I think that
fits for with him I don't think he's I
don't know if he's as talented as Gary
but again you see the production you see
you did see the production I love the
fact that they can kick him down inside
which they've done a few times I like
how long he is he does play have to play
with some good length I'm surprised that
he went this early if we're being quite
honest yeah I am surprised but I
understand if that's what you're going
for you you got to take your picks and
as Micah has said constantly hey it's
not a super deep draft not a super deep
first round so if this is a guy that you
like you thought you were going to get
them later you go ahead and get them now
so for me on this one I'm gonna go
b-plus on the this pick and the big key
for me is just I
man I don't I don't it it is it's I get
listen I'm kind of speechless man like I
don't know why
because I thought he was good right but
then to see this kind of meteoric Rise
after he ran that four five eight yeah
like he didn't play at four five eight
not when I watched him it didn't seem
like he like I'm sure he did a great job
training for the combine and working on
himself and doing all those things but I
didn't think he played that fast I
thought he played that heavy played that
strong but I didn't think he played that
fast I'll give you another reason why
because the Packers would want a guy
like this Dayton Cole come at sister
Bears tight ends good Trash Talk get you
the inside info can Trash Talk him a
little bit you tell me when he's lined
up at six Tech he's not gonna give Cole
come at the biz 458 at 272. uh Micah the
floor is yours I don't love the Pig I
mean you can say you put him next to
Kenny Clark whatever I mean I don't
think he's necessarily big enough to be
I mean he is I mean if you put some
weight on it but then it takes away from
the 458 that don't necessarily put him
on the same scale as Rashawn Gary Right
talent wise Rashawn Gary is a pro bowl
10 plus sack of year guy and we're
talking about a guy who not necessary
hasn't started a game and he's not a 10
second year guy in my eyes I mean even
on some of the sacks a lot of this cover
stack where I feel like you're really
kind of stunned just because of the
value to pick and where he was taken I I
when we talk about drafts I mean at this
pick right here we're three picks away
from where the Eagles trading got AJ
Brown now that's where you talk about
value pick and you're talking about u11
I was 11. so this is 13 right there
yeah and that's what I'm saying like are
you saying this is the same value of AJ
Brown are you saying this is the same
value of like Rashawn Slater yeah like
and then like you know it he he can
become a good player I guess are you
talking about the needs you just let go
Aaron Rodgers do you necessarily take
another defensive player why don't you
get another weapon for Jordan love
Jordan love yeah you get him a Titan you
get him a weapon that's gonna
set Jordan 11 the right place all right
we have a trade Patriots were on the
clock they have traded with the
Pittsburgh Steelers the Steelers were
sitting there at 17. they jump over
Washington and the Jets to make this
trade and they are on the clock right
now so the Patriots and the Pittsburgh
Steelers are making a trade uh this Joey
Porter Jr oh I was gonna say it's got to
be Broderick Jones right the last tackle
of the bunch if you jump in Jets who
need a tackle commanders who need a
tackle that's a very good point because
that it's all about runs and I've heard
from a lot of people that there's a few
tackles what were you going to say Joey
Porter Jr is like a love story Pig oh
yeah
project Jones is a makes sense pick I
mean they took Penny Kick It Off The
Love Story pit the pit yeah sales
whatever penny pick it turned out to be
pretty good yeah rookie year was pretty
good but that's the Love Story pick
Roger Jones makes sense you need help
with Naji you need someone that's going
to protect Katie at the end of the day
you gotta protect offensive guys you've
got to get pushed up front and he's one
of them guys yeah you're right it is a
love story paint yeah it's a love story
it is I enjoys my guy but they need help
more on that offensive line I get it
like I've been I've been doing marks and
I've just been doing it I'm just like no
shall we Porter Jr he goes here this is
where he belongs yeah this is where he's
from I need Joey to wait 12 more picks
that's what we need
so now I'm sitting here like I think
Broderick Jones makes a lot of sense
right now absolutely uh and now I'm
sitting here after this so let's say
they do go there at 15. Christian
Gonzalez is still on the board Nolan
Smith is still on the board we're also
watching the will Levis fall yeah so now
I told you that yeah I wasn't going to
argue with you yeah
I was even surprised with Anthony
Richardson but off rip I knew it was
gonna be just like last year right we
knew Stroud and young were the guys we
got two guys Anthony Richardson will
Levis was either that maybe pick with uh
Indianapolis non they wanted to start
fresh and new they weren't just going to
keep bringing guys in right but outside
of that there was no real need for QB so
and then also I haven't had the wide
receiver we haven't had the Jackson
Smith and jigba yet and I think that'll
come up soon but I'm going to say it's
Broderick
um you know what you go out there and
you do the love story of uh Kenny
Pickett and you need to finally get him
some help because the offensive line for
the Pittsburgh Steelers in recent years
has been rough to say the least
Broderick Jones the pick for the
Pittsburgh Steelers at 14 uh 19 starts
all of them at left tackle uh ran a 497
40-yard dash fastest among all offensive
line at the combine and listen to this
32 games played you know how many
holding penalties penalties he had Micah
Parsons
zero wow Renner your thought of moving
up to lock in Broderick Jones a little
different than Tyler Smith last year I
think I like yeah it was last year but
Jones to me is the most impressive
athlete out in space in this tackle
class yeah his best reps are him
climbing to linebackers pulling out on
screens you see natural athleticism for
a 311 pounder that just doesn't last
long in the NFL draft right these guys
go highly because that's what the elite
tackles at the NFL look like now only
really a year and a half of starting at
left tackle there's a lot to clean up
when he went up against more skilled
rushers guys like Isaiah McGuire from
Missouri BJ ogilar from LSU who will
probably see drafted somewhere on day
two he had problems those guys gave him
fits those guys probably won those
matchups so he's a little bit of a
project if you're looking for help for
Kenny Pickett right now right but again
this is a this is an investment this is
uh playing for the future here knowing
that with that division right now you're
probably a tick behind teams like the
Ravens teams like the Bengal those right
but you got to get to them get to a
place where you can compete with them
Roger Jones gets you there in time great
we're going to go with a I'll go a minus
for that one uh there was a drop off in
tackles yes do you think he was one of
the last few Elite ones left for the
state absolutely I thought he was
obviously the best athletic tackle I saw
that you had Donald Penn as a cop that's
fantastic he is someone who is super
talented you just got to get him going
in the right direction and I think
that's going to be the key for him is
get him going in the right direction I
think that's going to be the Steelers
job that's going to be a big part of it
and you mentioned that division the
scariest thing is the Steelers own that
division for so long yep and now the
Bengals are not a joke
the Ravens are going to continue to be
good and the Browns are the Browns seem
like they're trying football yes they
are so you have to you have to get that
you have to shore this up I love it it's
a good pick it's a smart pick it's not
that it's not the heart pick
but it is an absolutely good pick so I'm
gonna he was my I thought he was
probably the most athletic attack I
thought Swarovski was the most
technically sound so I'm gonna go A Plus
on this one because you get a guy that I
thought was going to go in the top ten
you're able to get him at 14. Michael
I'm going to come to you in a second
Calais you watch this guy on film what
did you think
yeah you know um this guy is um you know
just I think he's the best run Blocker
in of all the tackles I watched he was
the most physical in the Run game and I
think Naji Harris has got to be looking
at his chops thinking like man you know
we're about to pound the ball and the
way they played the last eight games of
the season last year uh the way they
pounded the ball and really warning I
mean I don't know how Mike Tomlin always
does it but he always gets these winning
records uh you know after starting the
way they started you know but it's
because they run the ball well you know
then it opens up for a Young quarterback
in the play action and get the ball
where you need to and I feel like this
guy right here allows him to be so much
better in the Run game I think it's a
great pickup you know if it's it's a
scheme fit what they do is what he does
well and I I I uh I mean uh if I was
still with the Ravens which I'm not in
uh but I know those guys there are going
to be having their hands full because
this guy can play in the Run game he's
physical at the point of attack thank
you Calais Broderick Jones they had him
in the draft they added Isaac semelo
from the Eagles so they really are
putting a lot of work on this offensive
line what'd you think of this guy uh
great pick I thought it was very
aggressive athletic that's what you need
uh stairs are actually actually a really
good stream team especially with Naji
and they like to get the ball out to
their Playmakers like Deontay and things
like that so great value pick I thought
was a really good pick and you know he's
going to get better even though he might
be a little stoppy he's going to go
against cam Hayward TJ wad Alex High
Smith so I mean he has talent I mean his
divisions loaded with Miles Garrett yes
I mean he's gonna have his hands full
but he has those guys so you can get
great work with in practice so I mean
great pick fundamental you're going to
you got time to get him up to the
standard mini cam I mean OTAs and
training camp but throughout the year so
I think he's going to turn out to be a
really good I think the reason I love it
the most is he was projected to go to
the Jets at this next pick in every mock
that I saw and to to go and jump them to
lock it in with all of those young guys
on offense I think is genius jets are on
the clock right now of course they go
out there the big news this week Aaron
Rodgers is joining the team I have also
seen them maybe Nolan Smith here Nolan
is still on the board Jackson Smith and
jigba still on the board if they want to
go wide receiver where else could they
go here Renner they could go kalijah
can't see would be an interesting one
that I've kind of put to them in a few
times when the tackle run doesn't you
know goes ahead of them because that
defensive line already pretty scary but
still has kind of a need at the
defensive tackle position that could be
addressed Elijah can't see a unique
athlete but a guy who probably can make
an impact on third Downs you're one you
know he is that skilled that gifted as
an athlete that you just put them in
that mix it takes your d-line from
I would say a top 10 unit borderline top
five through right up there with the
Eagles for one of the best units in the
NFL what's your guess man I love the
idea of Nolan Smith I think that he is
super talented we still don't know what
he is though and so when we get right if
he's the pick we're going to get to talk
about talk kind of talk our way through
it because of the way that he plays but
if it's Nolan Smith it's Nolan Smith I
man I just watching these things that's
play like they've got it the Jets got to
figure something out especially because
the window is is closing on Aaron
Rodgers it's one two years two years I
mean he's old what like 104 million
dollars next year which is you're going
to get that money it's going to be sweet
just don't forget us okay okay uh key
additions for the the Jets uh obviously
Aaron Rodgers they also added two wide
receivers mccole Harman and Alan Lazard
a little familiar action for Aaron
Rodgers uh Quentin Jefferson the d-line
Chuck Clark at safety uh they did lose
Sheldon rankins uh which makes me kind
of think Sheldon rankins maybe a three
technique uh what could they do here but
jets are on the clock Micah what's your
prediction
I think when you start to make the run
at DB uh DB uh I don't necessarily think
they'll take a receiver just because
they're free agency but they might but I
think this might be the DB tight end run
within these next two picks especially
with I mean three picks especially with
Washington they might want to go get
them a nice vertical tied in with their
loaded offense and the Patriots let uh
trade in Joe new uh Janu Joshua Smith
yeah so I just think this might be the
Run uh I could see them taking a tight
end or interior I think but this might
be the run I mean we've seen last year
all the old linemen just went just like
last year all the receivers went so I
think it's about to be the run I'll say
this Christian Gonzalez fall to
Washington at 16. I don't think they
thought that was even possible yeah
right I think they because the Jets
aren't taking the corner with DJ Reed
sauce I I would doubt that Washington
they might run that card and we might be
talking about both picks back to back
here uh yeah I'm also wondering if the
Jets are trying to field calls I see Joe
Douglas standing up right there if he's
trying to say hey you're trying to get
in this Christian Gonzalez Nolan Smith
sweepstakes but the Jets are a team
where Dwayne Brown's going to be a free
agent after this year Makai becton who
knows what he's going to be but that's
why I said when everyone's like oh they
didn't give up too much for Rogers going
from 13 to 15.
when there's a lot of guys teams right
in that cluster that needed the
offensive tackle I wonder right now if
they're kicking themselves about
Broderick Jones and not being able to
get them do you think they need do you
think they need to get air in order some
more help I think that Green Bay just
didn't do it would be very funny if they
go defense and Aaron Rodgers still
doesn't get right would a Jackson I mean
they went out and they signed Nicole
Harmon and Alan Lazard but sure I do
like the idea of a move tight end right
now yeah a tight end I mean I wouldn't
be too mad at a receiver they have Tyler
he's on a longer deal but I mean for the
most part you still have an elite one
with Garrett Wilson right everyone knows
Rogers loves the Czar big handsy good
high point in the ball and you got me
Cole a nice Speed Demon I don't see the
reach for a receiver I see you know
tight end interior maybe Corner run
right now
I do think Dalton Kincaid in this
offense
is a guy that can take the next level
right away too yeah yeah Rogers likes
tight ends too
wow very interesting the jet select Will
McDonald defensive end pass rusher out
of Iowa State Will McDonald the fourth
so there have been rumors the Jets
wanted to continue to add to that pass
rush Robert Sala of course liking to get
after the quarterback Will McDonald 54
games 23 starts 34 sacks Iowa state
record 10 forced fumbles 34 career sacks
the most in the history of the Iowa
State program kid didn't play football
until his junior year of high school I
am curious though Renner picking him at
15. is this where you thought he might
go this is not where I thought he might
go I think he could I thought he could
sneak in I am 39th on my draft board I
thought he could sneak into the back end
of the first round but he's he's a
unique dude in that he goes to Iowa
State he's playing a a lot of four and
five Tech head up over tackles but he's
238 pounds you know he is not that and
at 238 pounds at six foot five he's
skinny I mean he looks like a wide
receiver out there rushing the passer
but his get off he got an 11 foot broad
jump at the combine the guy is explosive
and playing that much inside he learned
how to play physical at that undersized
ability so I think he can be an every
down dude but he just kind of is still
doesn't know too much what he's doing as
a pass rush you saw him kind of have a
disappointing Senior Bowl I thought that
could drop him to the back end of the
first round but jets are taking a swing
here I I would have gone elsewhere but
they're just adding that defensive line
like I said earlier trying to make it a
dominant one of the best units in the
NFL great we're gonna go with a C flat
on that one
yeah I mean kind of a head scratcher I
see the Julian akwara player comp
another long player that plays with
speed and does the whole goal for him is
please don't touch me please don't touch
me like that's you he cannot you can't
let them put the pause on you my man but
the thing that's interesting to me is
watching Will McDonald the fourth play
at Iowa State is the way that they play
what was asked of them in terms of
physicality in terms of effort this is a
group that played a very unique defense
and there was no way they should have
been as good as they were but they were
and he's a big part of that so for me
for with Will McDonald I'm looking at a
guy again he's going to give you effort
he is lean he's a lean football player
so he's gonna have to figure some stuff
out of where he actually fits in the NFL
but if you like a guy this much to draft
him at pick 15 then you must have found
something that you really fell in love
with uh for me I am going to give it I'm
going to go I'm gonna go with the C2
because
he's a good player but this is not a
player that anyone had on the board in
this round in the draft room over Nolan
Smith you know similar types of players
and it's hard for me to watch Nolan
Smith tape and then McDonald's tape and
say I'm going McDonald's in that
situation I think Nola Smith right here
maybe Washington especially not picking
up Chase Young's fish what do you think
of McDonald over Nolan though for the
Jets
that that one's a little uh that's a
head scratcher I mean you look at the
pig and say oh that's a decent pick but
over Nolan Smith I don't think that's as
wise I see potential on this kid I do
see potential I think we also have to
realize that I'm looking at the Ben he
has from a five if you change that and
you put them out to where I'm at on the
seven six now he and I'm seeing that
little move that he hits him with that
little hard jab what I like to do I mean
he's putting these guys on Stakes he has
speed get off lean I'm seeing him rip
all the way through so you see potential
I see great tangibles in this dude he
has the jab he has the quickness he's
making up and unders he's ripping
through he has he's violent at the top
of the rush and that's what you want to
see in guys he's a well-taught football
player yeah I'm I'm not mad at the pick
I can see why guys like oh there's
better players but if you're talking
about rushes and how he likes to rush
with that bend and you got you got Quinn
in the middle right yeah I like it all
right I do you think it's interesting
Joe Douglas making this pick I think
back part of the reason why Howie
Roseman lost the ability to draft for
the Eagles 2017 he took Marcus Smith in
the first round a very light pass rusher
that everyone said we need to get back
to football I do find it ironic that Joe
Douglas is taking him at this point of
the draft but he wanted to go out there
and get another pass rusher we'll see
Washington now up 16 and you said it
earlier they got to be sitting there
going how did Christian Gonzalez come to
us and did he
no oh they go a different cornerback and
now I'm sitting here going what's going
on with Christian Gonzalez now I'm
wondering about Medicals now I'm worried
about testing because it doesn't make
sense uh that we've gotten to this point
Washington going secondary Emanuel
Forbes the pick uh 16 Washington able to
sit there and take Emanuel Forbes Jr he
goes by Junior second team All-American
first team all-sec has more passes
defended than starts 35 pass defended 34
starts the second youngest of 10
children and listen to this had 14 picks
in college six of them he returned for
touchdowns a record every time he picked
it off he returned it for an average of
28 yards what do you think of this guy
at 16 here Runner he's a ball Hawk go
into a defense that's going to allow him
to play off with his eyes through the
receiver to the QB so it's a scheme fit
for sure it's maybe a little rich but
there's not a better Ball Hawk in this
game Quest he had the best instincts
when it came to finding the football in
the air in my opinion the worry I have
166 pounds he is the lightest six foot
plus Corner taken on day one or day two
of the draft by 10 pounds you know
unique outlier in how skinny he is but
he plays a little more physical than
you'd expect for a guy that size I still
do worry once you get to the NFL you're
facing AJ Browns of the world you're
facing 220 pound wide receivers he's
given 60 pounds up to those guys that's
just that's going to be tough to
consistently win at the catch point when
you're giving up that much my only worry
for that because on tape he's going to
be making plays he's going to get his
hands on footballs it's just is he going
to be that lockdown consistent guy on
the outside at that size when you factor
all that in what's the grade I'm going
to go with the B plus there what do we
think Felder I mean he is I mean the
length he's so long and you put the tape
in and everybody's worried about what's
he going to do in cover what you're
going to do in coverage but what I see
is someone who wants to be aggressive
wants to be physical and he wants to
come downhill and make plays so when you
have that part of your game I I think he
kind of reminds me a little bit of
garlic sauce Gardener not as obviously
not as big as sauce right sauce sauces
wait a little more but you look at this
this is a guy that's not afraid to stick
his nose in look at his legs yeah oh
yeah I know
but look at this you're right he's not
afraid he's not afraid I think he's
gonna be okay he'll get bigger in the
NFL for sure but the big thing for me is
the way that he triggers the way that
he's again as you mentioned a ball Hulk
and then the fact that he has this
capability to turn defense into offense
and I love that about him so I'm going
to give this one an A minus okay I don't
I don't think I think it was a little
earlier than I expected him to go but
certainly someone that is not afraid to
play Corner he's not afraid to come
downhill and again one of those guys
that just has a nose for the football uh
I'm gonna go to AJ Brown because you
mentioned guarding AJ Brown and I'm told
that when you said that AJ Brown left uh
what do you what's so funny AJ
I did laugh uh I do think it's a great
pick though I think uh he's a he's a
corner cornerback who wants to be
physical and and that's what you want at
that position you know you can talk
about size and weight and all that stuff
but the guy has heart and that's what
you want from a from a DB standpoint and
for me personally I don't want to go
against longer guys they make my job
difficult but uh but like you said
everybody's not 225 and got all these
muscles like me in the NFL so I think
the kids are going to be finding a great
pick uh but I'm definitely uh smiling at
this matchup though all right so AJ let
me ask you you're gonna face this guy
twice a year uh what's he what's he got
in store facing you
hello oh man a guy can run every route
in the route tree uh the guy just
kind of does what he wants when he want
to do it so uh he has he has a handful
and so do I so should be a good matchup
uh Micah you said that Emmanuel Forbes
is in for hell when he faces AJ Brown
It's only yeah it's only 60 pounds
difference nah boy listen everything
cool you gotta remember this is the NFC
like AFC yeah you could love to pick a
whole lot more AFC way more passed down
but you talking about a guy who wanted
to come up and take on a pull and Kelsey
or Johnson like this is a NFL is a grown
man eventually it's starting to get cold
it ain't going to be warm for about six
weeks I'm That 160 pounds Circle wet
gonna have to make a business decision
and get some big dudes man like the
leaks is a little different man I'm
sorry 160 pounds that that size Make a
Difference like regardless I see effort
out of 200 pound guys who don't want to
make that business decision you know
it's a business decision when you're
going against so how do you how do you
mix he clearly is a ball Hawk yeah he
really got hands and he's electric with
it and that side because he's got talent
so what do you think of this overall you
know you kind of got to look for more
passing Downs second and long starting
long right mix them in but as a true
first round corner you want like uh
especially around what was that 16 you
want somebody Gonzalez on the board you
want to be a guy that's going to be an
every down player and it's just hard for
me to say that you know a guy at 160
pounds is going to come down and hit a
McCaffrey every time I say Quan Barkley
every time we don't got Zeke but I'm
pretty sure he ain't gonna make that
business decision against Zeke every
time but Tony Paul is still gonna put
the shoulder down so it the game's
physical and you know especially in
blocking can it come off blocks can in
that aspect especially like the idea of
when AJ Brown It's a run play yeah Brown
comes off the line it's violent yeah put
his hands on you can you get off the
board yeah like it's one it's up in the
air but we'll see I see him twice in a
year you know but that size and the NFC
at least like you got teams that's gonna
run it 20 25 30 times a game it ain't no
50 attempts over here like
okay uh manual Forbes Goes to Washington
New England is now on the clock they of
course drop back with Pittsburgh from 14
to 17. I don't know if the comp has been
announced yet but the pick is in and the
New England Patriots are still there it
goes there he goes
we traded down
Washington didn't take them and we're
still able to get it
Belichick able to pull this off
Christian Gonzalez was seen as many as a
top 10 selection 30 Games 20 passes
defended four interceptions all of them
this season uh his entire family is
world-class athletes and track stars
only three pass interference penalties
the last few seasons uh so good that
Mike has got to go take a piss
but Renner Gonzalez to go to the
Patriots here at 17 your thoughts I mean
it's a steal unless there's some medical
thing that we don't know about this to
me is the steal of the draft so far he's
young not even 21 years old yet he turns
21 in June can't even celebrate this
with a drink and productive I mean he
got his hands on the football a ton this
past year with his pasture whether it's
at Colorado two and a half years as a
starter 438 speed 41.5 inch vertical
11-1 broad jump with that athleticism
the best all-around athlete at the
corner position in this draft in my
opinion and with that kind of production
I just don't see how this guy comes to
the NFL and just doesn't fit in right
like we're we're naming how how
Witherspoon could have maybe have some
issues how Emmanuel Forbes with his size
could have some issues I I don't really
see the issues with Gonzalez maybe it
doesn't turn into a stud Jalen Ramsey
whatever
but his floor is just a starting good
solid NFL quarterback and you're going
to the place that develops cornerbacks
better than anyone you know he's going
to a place that Bill Belichick has
always had the Midas touch with
developing DBS you gave him the guy with
the best tools to develop in this draft
class I I would not surprise me if he
turns into an All-Pro Someday I'm
guessing it's an A plus so we're gonna
go a plus there uh he's joining Jack
Jones he's joining Jonathan Jones uh the
big man Kyle Duggar but this is a guy
that run a 4-3-840 man he can run with
anybody in this yeah he's got speed I
see that Dominique Rogers chromatic Pro
Comp I went with the Rivas because of
the way that he's a grabby guy like he
is he's a handsy football player that
wants to be in contact with you all the
time like I was watching him and I was
like man this reminds me of like my
four-year-old it just has to be touching
you all the time and it's one of those
things it's a good quality to have as a
corner he's gonna have to reel it in
just a little bit but I love the way
that he tracks the ball when it's in the
air I love the fact that he's able to go
out there and sometimes turn some
defense in an offense but the key for me
is I think he's probably the best man
and Corner in this draft he's got the
ability to do that but he's also not
afraid to come up and try to make some
plays I'll say this right now watching
him he looks pissed that he got drafted
this late yeah
not look happy he looks like he's about
to go to the gym after this and get a
workout in because he is not happy with
where he fell did you give a grid oh I
didn't give a grade yet there we go I'm
not supposed to give my grade until
after we come out of the b-roll
a plus a plus come on
Felder knows how to follow directions uh
AJ Brown uh you I'm sure have watched
this guy we all thought he could even go
in the top six top seven he falls to New
England here what do you think about
where he went and him as a player
um I think he went to a great place uh
most importantly uh Billy Jake
basically
groom DBS you know and uh he produced I
definitely see all pro in his in this
guy's future man I definitely felt like
he was the best cornerback in his in his
draft
um really I know we play him next year I
know it's going to be a tough tough
matchup uh but uh the guy the guy like
you said man he wants to be Hands-On um
he's a great ball Hawker in and out his
breaks man the guy has he's a he's a
total package man and he couldn't fall
to a better place than New England I
want to ask you AJ I look back at your
draft uh you went second round DK went
second round Debo went second round guy
like Christian didn't fall as far as you
did and I'm sure you thought you were a
first round pick what would you say to a
guy like Christian Gonzalez who's
probably upset right now that he went
lower than he thought he would go
man there's nothing to be upset about
you know uh you're blessed to play this
game at the highest level
um you just took care of your family's
family uh don't worry about it don't
worry about where you fell in the draft
you got to start over and you got to
prove your work day in and day out uh
but uh just watching his film that it
speaks volume um the kid is a he's a
he's a great athlete he's gonna do
wonders in uh
with the Patriots uh by the way if
you've ever seen that viral video of the
quarterback David Blau going nuts when
his wife is running the Olympics for
Colombia that's his sister there we go
this is a this is a family of speed uh
Micah you're joining us back now
Christian Gonzalez going to the Patriots
like great big
what is it like when when you you know
you went to a team that ended up being a
lot of star defensive players but for
Christian Gonzalez the further you fall
the better team you go to and I feel
like this is a good situation for him
yeah like I said Michael Irvin told me
yo yo uh he said you don't fall you land
on the star like you land on that and
you know those Pat the early picks is
good because you know it's like oh most
money yeah but you are gonna go to a
medium team like redis close to being a
really good team I think he adds value
especially in that back end he has Jude
on up front yeah he has Baltimore he has
a nasty up front yes um so it's gonna
make his job a whole lot easier plus
with his aggressiven the Bellatrix
aggressiveness yeah I think this is a
perfect matchup uh and now on the clock
is a team that we thought could have
taken Christian Gonzalez in the top ten
right Detroit Lions with one of the
Shockers of the draft going Jamir Gibbs
the running back out of Alabama and now
we sit here and we wonder where could
they go they have needs on the d-line
they still have needs at cornerback what
are you thinking here Runner I think
d-line is where I'm looking with Nolan
Smith still on the board just continue
to load up on past rushers that's where
that's where the failing was last year
this was a top five offense in terms of
points per game they could not stop the
run Nolan Smith is a dog against the Run
he's going to bring it every single snap
even though he's undersized I I think
that's where my head's they could go
anywhere they could go Dalton Kincaid to
replace Hawkinson as you were saying
before they can go kalijah can see and
that's a meet up at the middle
I just really think they stay offense
they defense played at such an insane
level towards the end of the year like
they were just clicking like
I just don't they switch the DC to Aaron
Glenn
it was interesting yeah even with that
they got the pieces but we'll see
Runners smiling
oh wow linebacker that's a Dan Campbell
uh I'm gonna be honest guys
uh Brad Holmes the GM for Detroit is
shocking everybody they go running back
Jamir Gibbs and now they are going Jack
Campbell the linebacker out of Iowa now
listen man is accomplished first team
All-American Bacchus Award winner
two-time team captain he was a captain
in high school college Kirk feren says
everything he does he goes hard he's the
first Iowa player to win the academic
Heisman the William V Campbell trophy he
started 27 games he averaged 10 tackles
in all so the man is around the ball the
value here though
at 18. yeah that's what do we think here
Runner he's a super high floor
linebacker yeah I mean he had for my
money the best tape last year of any
linebacker in the country that was draft
elves but like solid between the tackles
Mike linebacker Plug and Play you know
what you're getting high instincts High
motor going to make plays now he's just
not a super high-end athlete right four
six fives what he ran that's
traditionally not what goes in the first
round of that linebacker you're just
worried about what's that guy going to
look like when he has to cover tight
ends that run four fives at the NFL
level or when he gets unmatched up on a
slot wide receiver what's that going to
look like but I do think the need was so
desperate they were so unhappy with
their linebacker play a season ago that
they went ahead and just said we're
gonna get a high floor here we're going
to get a guy we know is going to come in
and be a good player for us and I think
that was the first two picks guys they
want to make an impact this season on
the roster Shamir Gibbs Jack Campbell
Plug and Play Day One starters that
maybe you could have shot a little
higher for the moon for a little bit a
little bit more upside but these are
guys that you just know are going to be
impact players right now Detroit's
defense last year 30th against the pass
29th against the rush what do we think
about going Mr Campbell here I like Jack
Campbell I think he's a good player but
man
he is slow like he's like he's not he he
played let me put it this way he plays
faster than he runs like that's that's
the key part of that is he studies
that's what he looks like erlacker look
at his face he does look like erlacker
doesn't run like erlach no he does not
but that's what he's this is this is the
guy that's gonna you're gonna put him in
the middle of your defense and he's
going to be there for a long time like
he understands especially with the way
that Iowa plays football well-taught
football players guys that understand
what they they own they just do their
job look at him right coming down hill
that's amazing that's a great play he
understands how to sift through the
trash look at the way he gets out on
coverage boom and then he's fast enough
when you when you do things right those
Corners are forcing him back inside and
he's closing that Gap so he has the
opportunity to do that I think he's also
going to be a steady piece but
at the value I still think you could
have got maybe Drew Sanders so I'm gonna
go be uh B minus I
for me he was maybe linebacker number
three or four and the reality of it is I
definitely didn't think he was gonna
hear his name called tonight to me he
reminds me a lot of Logan Wilson as a
prospect Logan Wilson went top of the
third round that like the middle of the
seconds where those guys go right
traditionally it just is a super weak
linebacker class though yeah if you want
that Jack Campbell is there's no other
guy in this class unfortunately feels of
a little desperation that's kind of what
you were and then you got to the NFL and
they need you to rush the passer what do
you think when you watch this guy you
know I'm not mad at the pick at all I'm
not mad at it uh just because he fits
what the NFC is right and as downhill
linebackers you got to be able to come
downhill violent hands I mean can we
really be I compare him to Leighton
vanderish right you know greater Lane
he's not going to give you everything
and that's my dog but he comes downhill
he gives you heart soul like great
teammate smart Leighton helps me out
line getting everyone lined up you and
you talk about the academics you've got
a Luke Kuechly mindset I'm a watch film
The instincts you can't coach those
right so I'm not mad at the pick the
value of the pick we've got Leighton
back that was huge for us this off
season so get in there they're middle of
the field is huge and it comes to and
you know if you look at the trend the
teams that have that middle of the field
like dominance are usually winners right
I mean I want to say this we talk about
his speed and we make jokes about his 40
but he was Elite in two other drills of
the combine uh Jack Campbell ran a six
seven four three cone and a four two
four short shuttle both number one
against all amongst all linebackers of
the combine so quick area short area
that's the most important for football
but what you said is yours ever 40 does
not matter unless you're me chasing down
a title which is Detroit a 4-3 unless
you're crazy unless you're chases down a
tight end 30 yards downfield to stop
someone for a touchdown that's the only
time you're gonna need that 40 but he's
dominated the short area quickness
that's all you need and we're not going
to sit here and act like long speed
makes you a good football player because
we don't see nose fell in the draft
especially long speed at the middle
linebacker you know what he's he's
trying to keep everything in the Box the
worst thing I want to go I want to get
the chance to get to the sideline Tampa
is on the clock I feel like the pick
might be in I think it is
uh 19 this is a Tampa Bay team that is
completely rebuilding Micah said it's
got to be Nolan Smith and no they go
kalijah
a little Warren Sapp actually going on
with Nolan I mean they might I'm truly
shot I'm I'm not mad at that pick but
I'm shocked that he's falling like this
Tampa Bay sat there at 19 and they are
taking Pitt defensive lineman kalijah
cansey a unanimous All-American uh ACC
Defensive Player of the Year LED all
defensive tackles in college football
with 14 and a half tackles for losses
this is a guy that played for
Northwestern in Miami was winning state
titles uh 27 and a half tackles for loss
in 25 games the last two years this is
someone that I feel like people were
saying in the beginning of the draft
process Runner he's a top of day two but
I think everyone knew he's a day one guy
yeah you flip on the tape and you just
keep seeing him make plays make plays
make plays and then at the end of the
day when he checks in 6-1 281 you're
like
I can still work with them that can
still win at the NFL level we saw it
with Aaron Donald the pick guy now he's
not Aaron Donald Aaron Donald was much
longer much stronger coming out of pitch
but he's that level athletically this is
for my money the most impressive DT I've
seen on tape in terms of the quickness
in terms of the get off he was at
quarterbacks before his Edge guys were
even engaging with offensive tackles at
times I mean it is truly impressive the
way how easily heat can move I think
he's a football field
knows how to rush the past two he has
moves knows how to separate off blocks
but you're going to have to allow him
that freedom if you're asking him to
hold up to double teams and just say
play your B Gap he's not going to be
that guy you're going to have to see
when he gets a double team go go get
around it you know go do whatever you
can to not engage against that guy which
is tough not everyone's willing to allow
that flexibility but if you do dude's a
playmaker grade for him at 19. I'm gonna
go a plus for this one I really like
this one yeah I think he's a heck of a
football player and obviously I come in
I I live in the ACC country I watch a
lot of ACC football I've seen him play
uh has a little bit of uh Grady Jarrett
to him is that right Grady yeah that
that's sort of a guy that if you can if
you can let him play in that one spot if
you can let him uh not by not one as in
line up at one but play as a one Gap guy
not being asked to kind of grab hold
because he's not as long as some of
these other guys but that's listen Grady
Jarrett's making me making a hell of a
living doing it so I think he's got that
skill I really like the fact that as you
mentioned the takeoff you see them there
using him on Slants using him on stunts
I mean we should we just showed a video
of him on a stunt coming from like a
coming from the inside going all the way
outside and as you mentioned getting
there before the the fast the fat quote
unquote fast guy even got there so yeah
I'm gonna go with an A on this one I
think that he's a heck of a football
player and I get at this point with this
draft Yeah if you if you like it take it
so the one thing sub 31 inch arms he'll
have the shortest arms of any starting
defensive lineman in the NFL Micah you
had 31 and a half inch arms coming out
you have like one of the smaller for an
edge guy how do you get around that as a
defensive lineman your quickness and
he's going to have to use that and he
has to be quick with his hands right a
lot of guys are going to know how to try
to get on him quick but he has to be
quicker keep his hands up keep him
ruling and he's very violent with his
hips if you saw it in one move he's he's
moving in motion all simultaneously I
mean is is almost you know effortless
for him I think it's a great pick uh
Calais is joining us Calais when I think
of the Bucks and I think of Warren Sapp
and Booger McFarland and now I think of
this can see kid next to Vita Vega I
kind of like that combination they got
in Tampa Bay yeah
yeah you know I think uh Tom Bose don't
know how to use it the right way you
know I've played his uh defensive game
before and it's a lot of movement you
know a lot of long Scoops you know uh
Slants inside yeah and he has a
quickness to be able to do that and I
think he has good um instincts and
knowing like when to shoot the gaps
we're using hands knocked out hands uh I
mean you know you see the quickness on
tape I mean it stands out uh but it's
it's more than just quickness though I
mean he has the the instincts to be able
to set his guys up and uh and just know
the timing when to go by a guy and that
speed that you have you know with the
instincts he has and just he's a knack
for rushing the pastor you know if I I
wouldn't be surprised if he was a good
basketball player back in his day
because when he was the pastor he has
that kind of wiggle like getting to the
hoop and dunking on somebody you know
and so I like his I like the pick I
think he's a good player I think he's on
uh you know he's in a good scheme that's
gonna allow for him to really benefit
all his talents coleus thank you uh I I
want to say this this dad also jumped
out to me
47 percent of his tackles were in the
backfield right so half of the time he
makes a tackle it's behind the line of
scrimmage Tampa Bay when they made that
run sure Tom Brady unbelievable but it
was that d-line menacing jpp getting
after it this is a guy that can do that
and and to get him here very clean at
number 19. uh Seattle now on the clock
number 20 their second pick second pick
actually you know what I mean that Devin
Weatherspoon pick at five was shocking
as well we all kind of thought that was
going to be joking no it's a great pick
he wouldn't have made it that far look
at that I don't know what's been going
on with the DraStic shock I mean I think
it's a great it was a great pick they
got their guy right and now they can get
another guy at this picture there's
still guys left if they go a Devin
Weatherspoon Nolan Smith that's right
that's their draft it's a heck of it I
think is there anything I want to be a
little chaotic is there any chance they
go will levus
is there any chance they lock in that
fifth year option and they don't know
Gino's it's like a one-year deal any
chance I mean they already got Drew lock
I don't know why I'm saying that yeah I
don't think I think they want I just
want to win now I think they won okay
I'm gonna make a prediction
I think they're going to go Jackson
Smith and jigbo I was just I wouldn't
mean that a wide receiver's been drafted
they're gonna we have not seen a wide
receiver you got DK you got locket with
him in the middle and this is perfect
because with Gino I would love that
Seattle needs a receiver the charges are
in
crushing native Receiver right right
this is going to go and Ravens need one
yeah this literally might just go
receiver receivers Vikings are right
there too yeah like the run this is the
run that we are is there going to be
Nolan or receive this reminds me of the
Malcolm Kelly draft we're like oh man
Devin Smith we're like wide receivers
weren't coming off um yeah all right so
Seattle uh they went Corner kind of
shocked us they do need d-line help but
I don't know if there's a d lineman that
that fits the bill Renner on your big
board what makes sense here yeah Jack
Smith and jigbo the top non-quarterback
available at this point as you said like
they have that slot positioned wide open
in Seattle that just makes too much
sense you immediately have a top three
to four wide receiver core in the NFL if
you had Jackson and he helps you
tomorrow too he's NFL ready I think
tight end too with Noah fan you could
add Kincaid have two different guys to
do some stuff with or Nolan Smith those
three there right at the top I would be
floored if they go any other way those
guys all just make too many too much
sense maybe I'm miles Murphy if that's
your type that defensive end at the edge
but to me Nolan Smith like the cliff
evil they haven't had that in a minute
yeah they just haven't had that guy
didn't get out I just thought can we see
Runners props really quick I just want
to see how they're doing they were not
doing great no sorry nowhere nowhere the
scaronsky miss the Jones missed we were
right on the precipice of all of them
missed them all and then I think the
wide receiver is looking cash yeah under
four under four and a half we need the
QBs to move
no QB is gone it's over I call it you
think it's going to be three
quarterbacks and that's it yeah I don't
see no team let's check in this is
actually the Seahawks chat so on the BR
app uh each team is going so Witherspoon
plus Tariq is fire so they're hoping for
that yeah Kobe Bryant Trey Brown like
they're loaded quandre I wouldn't be mad
at a safety they go safety rusher at
this pick or receiver what do you think
about Brian bressey
I think he can man you all said that
name three different ways
17th player of my board I I think he's
got more than what he put on tape and
and I think obviously it's Andre my
Jones
still could use and by the way his name
is Brizzy
brace is cool
what did I say
I said bressy Green Arrow saying please
know Levis bro Seattle straight
panicking on this well I will say of all
the picks I have not seen the clock go
this low usually its pick is in with a
minute or two yeah this is Mark Van Reef
saying hope the pick is good yeah mark
um but Seattle it doesn't look like
they're on like on the phone right now
using the whole clock it says it's in my
home son I do think though for Seattle
here Chargers next Baltimore and then
Minnesota this felt perfect for them you
know they're gonna get all get one of
their wide receivers or tight end that
they want like I think this is ideal for
them and even if you're that Kirk yeah
hear that Mr cousins looks like there
could be some weapons possibly coming
your way in the next few picks but
Seattle's pick is in as soon as we get
it we will announce it
um
yeah three quarterbacks it it makes you
wonder could will anyone trade up to get
a Levis
I don't know I think Rams are top of the
second I could see that the Liam Cohen
connection OC oh you're right Kentucky
from Kentucky went back and now he's
back at Kentucky but we shall see oh I
got the pick here for Seattle you do
yeah you can announce Jackson Smith and
jigba wow they went ahead and did it and
they played this draft
perfect to a t Seattle this was as good
a first round is so a bunch of teams
came in with two picks obviously we'll
see what the Eagles do but wow Seahawks
have to be right up there with the
Eagles in terms of how this draft
started the Seattle Seahawks in this
draft get arguably the number one wide
receiver and the number one quarter
Jackson Smith in jigba oh you remember
that Rose Bowl MVP he had 347 receiving
yards 2021 was his big year 95 catches
over 1600 receiving yards and nine
touchdowns did have a little bit of a
hamstring injury but guess what nearly
90 percent of his snaps have been in the
slot and now with locket and with DK
Metcalf a heck of a three-wide receive a
rotation yeah he was in that Ohio State
Room back in 2021 that has Garrett
Wilson 10th overall pick Crystal Lobby
11th overall pick and he just went ahead
and now produced both of them as a
sophomore at 19 years old and came back
this past year obviously a hamstring
injury but he was 19 doing this stuff
like there was physical development that
happens as we saw which Mark Chase as we
saw with Justin Jefferson from his
sophomore to a junior that we just
haven't seen from him and he was this
productive at that age I think he's an
NFL ready route Runner his cut coach
there at Ohio State Brian Hartland
called him the second best wide receiver
he's ever coached with only Marvin
Harrison Jr being better than him wow
and we'll see him probably go top five
next year but he's just crafty the cop I
have from was Julian Edelman just
because he knows how to get open he
knows how to manipulate space knows how
to manipulate you with his stems to then
just get that little separation and then
once it's in his wheelhouse he's not
dropping him
Dave Plus
love it I I love the Edelman comp the
big thing for me the thing I want to
talk about with Jackson Smith and jiggle
we talk about getting open and doing
this I think that he has this running
back quality to him when he gets the
football in his hands this is not a guy
that he does not want to run out of
bounds he wants to run through people
run he we saw him on these clips his
ability to give somebody the stiff arm
his ability to to run through traffic
shake off things we talk about play
through contact yeah we talk about
playing through contact you see here
this is fantastic but then he wants to
find the end zone let's go let's go get
off me get off me come on and I think
that's a quality that is great to have
in a wide receiver he is not a catching
Fall Guy that you see that right there
and watch he's going to give this guy
the stiff arm go ahead and try to get to
the end zone I love this thing like he's
ready to rock and roll like he can do
all those things that you want and again
he's playing out of the slot knows how
to get open understands Zone verse man I
think that's something that's great
coming out of Ohio State no one went to
sit down knowing when to run and he can
do all those things so for me yeah he's
a lot of people's number one wide
receiver I'm giving it an A plus you get
this guy at 20. I thought maybe it was
gonna be 12 or 30. we thought it was
exactly we thought it was gonna be much
earlier uh AJ Brown this guy had the
number one three cone and short shuttle
at the combine for wide receivers what
did you think of them on tape and what
do you think Gino's getting
uh I'm over here smiling because finally
a wide receiver off the board and and
what a good one man Seattle got a great
Wide Receiver right here man uh
he just has an act for just getting open
man I like to call him a player like
he's just a football player you know
just give him the ball and just let him
do what he do and uh route running is is
very special I think he's a NFL ready
wide receiver like day one Plug and Play
you know uh so if I'm a fantasy owner
I'm definitely drafting this guy because
when he gets the ball in his hand he's
not trying to go down he's trying to
find the ends on and that's a trade that
I love and why receivers because you
know that's what it's about it's not
trying to create a highlight tape and
and this guy wants to get ends on so
this is just a great pick for Seattle uh
Micah I feel like you think you could
have been a wide receiver uh if you
really tried what do we think what do we
think of this guy when you watched him
oh man you know hey
if you play corner and I play receiver
what you think will happen be honest
I'll lock you down oh man hey let's
let's bet that backplate money so I can
get my Twitter Blue Back come on talk
about Jackson talk about Jackson because
this can go on forever hey
um no Jackson's Elite uh ever he was
always top three wide receiver in this
class it was just a matter of time which
Robert she was going to come first I
love that point you got DK you got Tyler
Lockett you try to lock it they all have
deep speed now you have a guy that could
get open underneath that could recover
this man versus his own like you talked
about give Gino that check down because
he's got to go against the 49ers that
that pressure defense a guy that can
read inside and get open that's gonna be
huge for Seattle all right Seattle goes
out there and they take the number one
wide receiver in this draft to many
people's opinion now we are at the LA
Chargers who are sitting there with
every other offensive weapon they
flowers say flowers is there a prototype
Runner fast runner I've heard a lot of
people talk about this the Need for
Speed on this Chargers team someone to
go deep I know people have liked Jordan
Addison how fast he is
um with that 40 what did he run he ran a
4-4-9 high at around a 4-4 Zay ran that
4-4-2 or could they maybe go a tight end
here what do you think yeah I like
either say flowers here or Dalton kids
Zay is like the electric thing that
they're missing right they have a bunch
of possession wide receivers in that
receiving room you need some guy that's
going to at least make the defense
respect his deep threat ability right
and that's a big reason why Justin
Herbert wouldn't go deep is just that he
doesn't see guys separating at that
level of the football field it's hard to
trust uh you know a guy who has someone
else hanging off of him that he's going
to consistently make plays like Mike
Williams and Keenan Allen do when they
run go routes it's just they're not guys
who can just blow by you Zay flowers can
so that's what I would like him there
but then they also could use a tight end
that's reliable over the Middle Field
just because that's where Justin Herbert
likes to Target that's kind of where he
likes to uh just throw is those kind of
dick routes middle of the field don't
Kincaid has the best ball skills in this
tight end class so for my money it's
going to be one of those two I would bet
good money it's one of those two and if
you're a charge fan you're happy as heck
that it is what do you think Felder say
flowers is good man I and then we I
think we all everybody up here we agree
that we all like Zay flowers and he he
does give you some quickness there's
some there's some um suddenness to his
game that I really appreciate and he's
coming from Boston College okay they
like he was super productive at Boston
College yeah like that's not easy for a
wide receiver to do and so what he we
look they're known for running the
football they're known for playing good
defense but they're not known for their
wide receivers and their wide receivers
consistently have trouble separating at
BC this guy did not have trouble
separating so I looked it up okay
Zay flowers would be the first Boston
College wide receiver drafted since
1987. wow Calvin Martin by the Dallas
Cowboys that's incredible uh yeah I I'm
glad you looked it up because I was
trying to go back through my mind and
I'm like am I forgetting somebody no I'm
not forgetting you no all right pick is
in uh and the Chargers are selecting
Quentin Johnson wow
so they go size over speed and the
Chargers they said you know what we like
Mike Williams we'd like to double down
on that Quentin Johnson two-time
first-team all Big 12 averages 19 yards
per reception both parents Army vets he
played x and z receiver at TCU and he
was number two in college football in
Yak going to the Los Angeles Char Los
Angeles Chargers we know they needed a
wide receiver almost all of them were
available what do you think of them
going QJ here I really like Quentin
Johnson I had him as wide receiver too
in this draft class I think he's
something unique in this class that Zay
flowers talking about the Deep speed
deep threat
six foot wingspan though Quinn John says
a six foot ten inch Wings wait Justin
remember Quinn Johnson's a six foot
wingspan six foot ten inch wings okay
State flowers had a six foot wing space
Oh wow he can make plays outside of his
frame but he isn't consistent at it not
consistent enough playing through
contact just yet over 10 drop rate in
his career you worry a little bit about
the ball skills but the athleticism is
unique over a 40 inch vertical over an
11 foot broad jump the guy is explosive
in everything he does
awesome after the catch 45 broken
tackles on 115 career catches Debo
Samuel in college 40 broken tackles on
148 career catches so he was more
elusive in college than Debo was who is
now the most elusive receiver in the NFL
that's something again that they don't
have is that yak dude in that offense
and with Justin Herbert
not the most accurate of dudes you're
gonna have to play a little bit outside
your frame at times I think Quinn
Johnson fits what they want to do and
still adds that deep threat element to
the mix great
we're gonna go we're gonna go with an A
on that one what do we think here Felder
I love him you do yeah absolutely he was
my wife he's my wife Super One really
yeah so we were just talking about Zay
flowers and the whole time you've had
him number one yeah I love this kid he's
amazing like watching him play through
contact watching a guy that's that big
work through work through screen action
he doesn't have to have build up speed
like this guy if he puts it all together
and you mention some of the
inconsistencies yeah this guy could be
like Megatron like he's like you see
this short pass elusiveness he's got the
ability right here okay bye I'm gone no
not you sorry buddy like this is good
that's good footballer man he's a tough
guy you can't just be throwing out
megatronics
like I was with you like okay he's okay
but here's what I'm saying if he can put
it all together he is a high ceiling
player and the highest ceiling player
that we've seen is his Megatron I don't
think he's going to get there
but listen if he gets in in the same zip
code
he's going to be he's gonna make
somebody he's gonna make this tea he's
gonna make the Chargers very very happy
I'm going a plus he's my top receiver
listen when I I got to compare them to
people you know
I mean I mean you could have said a lot
of other guys AJ Green okay I could I
could go with AJ Okay you can live with
AJ Green
that's the thing I just want to say and
this is not a shot of you father he's
62208 around a four five Megatron was
six five running but but I understand
either six two he was taller than six
two I have six two he was almost six he
was like six two and like three yeah uh
AJ you're listening to this I hear you
kind of disagree with him being wide
receiver one what do we think of of uh
Mr Quentin Johnson going to the Chargers
um he wasn't my wide receiver one but uh
he's he's a really good wide receiver
man I think uh charge that's a great
pickup for him I think they went and got
another Mike Williams man yeah and I
think the special thing about it is he's
violent after the catch you know he's a
guy he's not gonna just let one guy talk
to him he's I don't know if he's gonna
give give the blow so I think it's a
good good pickup uh the the Megatron
comparison was a bit absurd but
um I definitely think he his ceiling is
very high in the NFL and he's gonna he's
gonna Sprout AJ I want to ask you though
I know that you're a big Zay flowers guy
would you have rather have gone Zay
there
you know I was thinking Zay flowers but
to be honest uh I just didn't know where
he would he would fit in the Chargers uh
wide receiver room uh they got Keenan
Allen who's a Shifty guy who who gets
open at the highest level and you know
that's he plays in the slot you know so
unless you just putting Keenan Allen on
the outside and
for good that was just a that wasn't a
really good place for him you know but I
think Zay flowers is why was he born uh
Mr Micah Parsons Quentin Johnson what do
you think of him as a player and where
he went in comparison to the other wide
receiver um
I think he's a good player I'm not like
them I don't absolutely love him I think
he's not a pure catcher in NFL you got
to be a peer catcher yeah he either and
with the highlights he's catching them
with his body in the NFL you're not
going to be able to catch it with your
body ask AJ you gotta put your hands out
you got to be able to reach out and get
it tuck it secure it
um it's a lot more hands in the pros and
then you take away the lines too it
might be a little questionable but I
wouldn't necessarily take someone who's
not better than Mike Williams himself
okay you know so and then if you you say
kid and Allen you might not want to pay
him or you might let him go soon well
that's why I would have took a Zay
flowers instead to replace Keenan
someone that can understudy him not
selling Queen but quit is good though
I'm not I don't necessarily love the
pick but I think they could have had a
better value of player with Addison or
flowers They're not somebody he could
prove me wrong he could get his hands
better and he can reach a AJ Green
ceiling but we haven't seen that we've
seen AJ Green dominate at the high point
of the ball we don't really see him High
Point the ball for six two six three
right that's why I couldn't agree with
the mega charm Megatron was high point
in the hell out of him that's all he did
every every single yeah so and he was
great after the catch so after the catch
Yak is cool but you know at the pro
level there's not a whole lot of space
unless you're a wide open on bone
coverage right for you to afford to do
late hand like you know double the
double catch yeah yeah I noticed that
too the body double double catch I'm
looking at 10 drop rate yeah that's he's
he he's someone that I think has the
ability to get there the thing that I
really love about him and the reason why
I had him at one is because he has this
ability after the catch that you don't
usually see from bigger guys right he
has the ability to make people Miss he
has the ability to play through contact
he has to be he he's got a lot of
ability yeah and we can go AJ Green I
think it that's that's in him we've got
to work on these hands though I totally
agree with you and he's the only wide
receiver in this draft with size he's
the only one the only one uh I want to
go Kirk so Kirk I know you've been
waiting because all the quarterbacks
went in the top four but the Baltimore
Ravens are up uh you are uniquely
qualified to talk about what it's like
to have to think about money and a
contract year after year and when am I
going to finally get job security it
happened to Lamar tonight he is
officially the highest paid quarterback
in the NFL just mindset wise what is
that going to free him up having gone
through a similar experience
I was happy for him it's been a long
journey he's earned the right to a great
contract and his record as a raven has
been uh
so impressive so in his production
League MVP it was time for him to get a
great contract and he got one so uh
great things ahead for him but uh it was
kind of a no-brainer for them to get it
done and figure it out and I know he
wanted the fully guaranteed deal I don't
think he quite got that structure but I
think the structure is still pretty good
for him oh yeah I think he'll be okay uh
Thank you Kirk we don't know if we're
gonna have to talk to you again uh but
we might have to talk to you in two
picks see if the Vikings get you some
weapons uh Baltimore is up Renner do you
know the pickup you know the pick
already I will let you announce it it is
the guy we just talked a bunch about Day
flowers perfect wow so we go wide
receiver wide receiver wide receiver all
the options for Kirk's Vikings are
coming off of the board but Zay flowers
goes to Baltimore Baltimore this off
season the big signing of Odell Beckham
Jr they lock up Lamar Jackson and now
they get in some people's minds the
number one wide receiver again first
Boston College receiver drafted since
1987 didn't miss a game in Four Seasons
the 11th of 14 kids okay this is uh he
had 78 catches this year a School record
you do not see that at Boston College he
was training with Patrick Mahomes
everyone loves this kid uh Renner where
did he rank for you and why receivers
yeah I had him as wide receiver three in
this draft class behind Johnson so I got
it right on the board right now but I
think it's just that dynamism like he's
a poor man's version of jail and waddle
and Tyreek Hill like what we're seeing
down in Miami he can bring that to your
offense it just if you're gonna have to
stay with this guy for three four
seconds in that Baltimore offense which
you often do with Lamar Jackson because
no one wants to rush him everyone's just
trying to keep him in the pocket this
guy can do some dirty things on double
moves he's the guy that's going to
separate down the football field and now
gives you this Trio with Rashad Bateman
with Odell and he's kind of that chess
piece that you move across formation you
put them in motion and eyes the safeties
the linebackers they're looking they're
praying don't get him matched up on me
because you don't want to see him
running at you I think he gained about
10 pounds from last year to this year
added some dynamism to his game and that
Raven's offense now is one that just you
don't really want to go face on a weekly
basis I'm gonna give that one today uh
ran a 442 Felder his 10-yard split you
don't see this a lot
149 in the 10 yard split the man could
get off the line of scrimmage and that's
that's the cool thing about him is he's
going to be off the line of scrimmage so
you're going to have to try to play like
a catch technique with him and guess
what he's already out of the way he's
super Shifty so I love swag man yes you
can see it oh yeah you can see it he is
I understand why a lot of folks have him
as wide receiver one again one of the
things that I noticed watching this
watch where he's catching the football
he's catching it obviously in the middle
he's catching it at the edge but the
throws are not all great no the throws
are not all like this guy he had stop to
catch the football there like and he
still finds a way to make it work for
him I think that's really impressive I
think it really speaks to what he's able
to do as a player especially coming out
of Boston College who hasn't had a guy
drafted since goodness gracious so this
is going to be really interesting to see
for me I'm going with an A plus you get
a weapon you get a guy that's going to
fit too I think that's the coolest part
because now you got Lamar resign yes so
teams are gonna have to worry about
Lamar
teams are also going to have to worry
about Odell Beckham Andrews JK Dobbins
this is Aguilar as well yeah this is an
elite offense yes and he becomes a chess
piece that you can use in that jet
action he because the chess piece that
you can use off the line you can line
him up in the backfield we saw that and
then let him get out and go yeah I think
this is a really really really good pick
for them AJ Brown my producers told me
that you were clapping when this pick
was made but what got you so excited
because when I was just watching film on
this guy man what stood out to me that
he's a dog man he he wants the ball he
wants to contact uh he gets open uh he
just kind of played with that tenacity
of
I'm the best one on the field and that
show is all over the field and to
pairing with Odell Beckham Rashad
Bateman uh that offend is definitely
offense definitely going to be lethal uh
but this is my wide receiver one man uh
I just think he's a special man he's a
human joystick he can turn around and
look at you and take off running man he
he has this type of speed
I think
the sky's the limit for this guy
Mike I know you love them too I love
this pig really he's big yeah now this
is the pig I can condone and say I love
it uh just because of who you're pairing
him with but sure before Bateman's
injury he looks so promising right and
now you out at the route running of
Odell Beckham and you're talking about
this loaded AFC side
I mean and you put them in there with
Mark Andrews you give
now it's like now you pay Lamar you
bring them back and now you give them a
new two new weapons which he desperately
needed right mixed with Andrews and you
got Dobbins and Edward I just this
offense could really just go through the
roof and it's going to bring so much
trouble to the AFC side I this was a
great pick in value of a month Lamar
Jackson went from feeling disrespected
and didn't think that they had ever
given him weapons so now he has a loaded
offensive core and he's got a heck of a
lot of money in his pocket yes and this
is the speed he needed he never had
right Odell hey I don't know if Odell
still has his slant ticket 80 speed well
he had Hollywood Brown he he had he has
higher he still has that high end speed
if you look at his workout videos yeah
but this Zay flowers he might run a 4-2
but he plays four three four two right
and he's going to and he's that deep
threat Lamar needed to take it over the
top hey you're not going to be able to
sit in this box no more or are you going
to say right the problem when they had
Hollywood Brown was that he had to be
the guy on the outside he had to be the
route winner whereas now you have two of
those you have Bateman you have Odell
they can be your outside guys flowers
can be your move hybrid weapon and it's
an arms race in the AFC it's a race to
30 plus points per game if you're not
doing that through three games in the
AFC you ain't winning the Super Bowl uh
I'm gonna put them on the spot Minnesota
Vikings are on the clock uh Kirk Cousins
uh I'm sorry bro I gotta do it who do
you want
well I was excited to get the Alabama
running back but he went so so much
earlier than I thought he was going to
go to a you know division rival and then
with three receivers on the board three
picks ago I would have thought that
maybe one of them could fall to us but
we went three for three with receivers
in a row so at this point your guess is
as good as mine uh you know we've we've
been a little uh thinned out on defense
the last few years kind of hovering
around the bottom five in the league in
yards the last three years in a row so
at this point you know I'll take
anything to get you know a defense
that's in the top half of the league in
yards giving up and uh
um you know on offense we'll take a
weapon I'm open-minded here whatever
whatever we feel we got to do to win uh
yeah if they want to do some double
tight end sets you do have Kincaid you
do have mayor they're falling a little
bit defensively Nolan Smith is the guy
that we are now focused on as what is
going on uh this is a 4-3 pass rusher
that was the number one recruit that has
been like the guy his entire life I
don't think he'd make it past 25. so we
did terrorist pack this past season
right right and obviously didn't do any
bench or anything pre-draft I do wonder
if teams came back with that Peck injury
and just are a little wary of it
yeah I just can't see him falling past
the Giants the Jags desperately need a
rusher I know the Jags will be happy or
they need to slot but
I I mean I can see the Vikings going
they highest cylinder board you give
them a deep threat outside of Jefferson
get some people away from Jefferson and
make them lean a little bit to the right
you have a theory sometimes that like
some people's names they just like look
like they should go somewhere I kind of
think Brazil just kind of looks like a
viking name to me I know this is like
not rooted in anything fact but like I
see him on the Vikings roster so that's
gonna pick who's gonna yeah that's my
take I'll roll with you really let's do
it okay let's do it I'll say I'll say
Jordan Addison four straight ones wow a
run of all runs or high higher Addison
or we could see a detail oh yeah Jalen
well we know that Giants are going to
take a receiver for sure
it's the right one still there
so we went we went three wide receivers
in a row yeah we also had uh Gonzalez
and Emmanuel Forbes go that was the the
two we've had three cornerbacks go uh
after we had that run of offensive
lineman where we had right skoronsky
Broderick Jones we have not had any more
offensive lineman go
um also we had our first linebacker ago
that was a shot I mean the Detroit Lions
have stunned me
um
and they like to Blitz a lot and that's
what they're known for with bar before
he left in his prime bar was a prime
maybe a joey Point okay you're here Joey
reporter Jr I could really see a lot of
Defense start to go yeah I love I love
um
in Greek knives because remember his
name Drew Sanders yeah I think he's
Arkansas that was my our lb1 are you
talking about blitzing downhill speed
that was the guy that I thought had a
lot of similarities I am and with Brian
Flores coming over they're gonna be
different like it's gonna be it's gonna
look a lot different than it did a year
so what does that mean under Brian
Flores you're probably going to be more
Blitz and more coverage than we saw last
year that's Joey Porter that's also Drew
Sanders
what's up with Miles Murphy miles Murphy
just did not have great tape last year I
mean he's a heck of an athlete but just
the tape was lackluster wow a fourth
wide receiver let's go right to Kirk
Cousins Kirk you just got yourself a
wide receiver have you seen anything of
Jordan Addison
I haven't seen much of his tape yet I'm
excited to take a look now all right
then here's here's what we're going to
do Kirk we're going to do the video and
then we're gonna come right back to you
to get your take okay the Vikings select
Jordan Addison won the balitnikov as a
sophomore at Pitt then he went to USC he
has punt returner over 3 000 career
receiving yards 29 touchdowns at Pitt
had a hundred receptions for nearly 1600
yards and 17 touchdowns don't go to Kirk
yet because I want Renner to break it
down even more he's the only three-year
player in the draft with over 3 000
passing yards what do you think of
Addison here to me is the best route
runner on the outside in this draft
class he just understands that unique
way of
separating against corners and he did it
like he's not a super physically
imposing dude he didn't test off the
charts athletically he just has that way
of moving that's just graceful and easy
and the game just comes to him naturally
and that's how you produce to the level
he did little banged up this past year
but he's a guy who was a route winner
that if you see man coverage he's
one-on-one you can trust that he is
going to get open yeah what's what's the
grade we're going to go a with that one
yeah I love it he's a good player and
I'm glad you mentioned the ease that he
plays with because he does play with
there's a casual ease to his game he's
able to separate he's able to go out and
make plays and the thing I really liked
he did it at Pitt and Pitt is one thing
right yeah yeah but then he went to USC
still did it and the cool thing and the
reason I really like it and I'm sure
Kirk can speak to this too you can hide
him a little bit too he doesn't have to
just be an outside wide receiver he can
hide you can hide him a little bit like
we just showed him the clip they played
him and they played him in the backfield
and then he you know catches a wheel
route so I think this guy's kind of like
a great value Tyreek Hill in terms of
speed ability watched it like I mean
this guy never had a chance yeah I never
had a chance on and so when he gets
loose I think he's going to go out and
make plays especially if you hide him a
few times you keep them there in the
slot nobody can get hands on him he
scores a touchdown so I think this is
going to be really interesting to see
how they use him because he's definitely
got a super high ceiling you see there
playing through a bad throw from Kenny
Pickett go pick the catch uh go score so
yeah this is an easy one that's
something I want to see how to quit
knows
a plus from Felder yeah this is it this
is this is great especially if you're
gonna use especially if they use them
the way that he's been used previously
in his career I want to go now before we
go to Kirk Kirk it's great to see you I
want to go to AJ Brown uh AJ Brown tell
Kirk Cousins what he is getting in
Jordan Edison
uh nickname for me was Smooth Criminal
man everything just was so easy just
watching his film watching his tape man
he's a guy that can run any route uh he
makes the game look looks effortless and
and to be honest I'm happy uh Kurt got
another wide receiver because he has to
throw the ball somebody else other than
Justin Jefferson so that helps guys like
me out too because that that's that's a
stealing the job that's a really good
receiver so you know crazy got your
hands full now all right Kirk you've
heard the analysis now what do you think
those are all really good takes I agree
with everybody I think that uh he is a
natural wide receiver I've played with
some guys throughout the years who were
great athletes they can run well they
could jump well but playing the position
of wide receiver just didn't come
naturally to them and you'll always want
that natural receiver over a great
athlete and he not to say he isn't a
great athlete but a guy who can attack
the football with great hands adjust to
the ball well run great routes that's
pretty exciting to be able to get that
kind of Polish right away when he shows
up for OTAs so and I agree with AJ's
take that you know we were targeted
Justin a lot last year and for for a
good reason he's one of the lead
receivers in football but this should
should help take some pressure off of
him along with KJ Osborne and TJ
Hawkinson but um the more that we can
divert coverage away from Justin that's
only going to help jets with his ability
to uh to to wreck the game in a good way
and Kirk do you have a welcoming message
for Jordan Addison
really just welcome the team first of
all but more importantly I'm ready to
get to work you know there's a lot of
work up ahead and I think he's going to
love it in our locker room we got a
great group uh he's going to fit right
in and uh if he's a worker if he loves
football if he's ready to commit to uh
to being the best he can be he's going
to be a great fit and excited to get him
out here and see what he can do awesome
uh you want to talk about him really
quick because we do have a trade oh
there's a trade Giants traded up one
pick with the Jaguars I don't I don't
know why they felt they needed to trade
up one pick unless they I don't know
I've never understood that I mean the
Eagles did it you were happy yeah and so
it worked out so I understood that and
we all understand so I guess my question
is who could the Giants be be being like
we don't want to mess around we want to
get this guy we've had four straight
wide receivers go off the board Jalen
Hyatt
Jalen High could be Joey Porter Jr Joey
Porter Drew Sanders Darren desperate
need of a linebacker
are you saying they're linebackers are
trash
they let go Martinez and they just never
really Crowders been okay but they never
really filled it and they bring in uh
Jalen Smith to try to help Philip but
they need a definitely a starter it
factor and that second line of scrimmage
for sure they do I was going to say
tight end but they traded for Darren
wall yeah nothing really makes sense
here for me I will say this though about
the wide receiver run we just saw I
think all of those guys went to the
exact perfect position for each other
Jack Smith and jig by I thought you know
he's he can play outside but I want him
to go to a place where he can just play
the slot right Seattle he can just play
slot Zay flowers you know I like him if
he wanted to be like a number one but he
gets to go to a place where he gets to
just be the the gadget guy and then
Jordan asking gets to go to a place
where he's just a number two and I love
that for all those guys so uh
interesting that the Giants felt they
needed to go up there were rumors that
Jacksonville was going to need a
cornerback or a secondary guy but the
Giants have traded up one pick to go
with Deontay Banks I talked to my guy
Chris Sims who knows the Giants and this
was his favorite player for the Giants
from Baltimore went to Maryland kid is
quick run a four three five forty had
the best vertical of all cornerbacks of
the combine a 42-inch vertical
he missed all of 2021 with a shoulder
injury but you know what he does have on
film he looked really good against
Marvin Harrison Jr and not a lot of
people did Deontay Banks the pick for
the Giants yeah and he played in the
scheme at Maryland that asked him to do
a ton of different stuff and you
mentioned 2021 only plays two games 2020
only five games because of covet so
didn't play a ton of football after
starting as a true freshman there at
Maryland and then this year just a
massive breakout I love this right here
he's one of the most physical tacklers
in this draft class only missed one
tackle this whole last season I think
the sky is the limit for this guy that
you mentioned the athletic measurables
there they show up on tape routinely you
don't see Corners this big that change
directions as well as he does every day
I thought his agility is tremendous and
exactly what you want to see at the
position he really like he just didn't
have enough tape in my opinion the
injury from 2021 to get himself into
that top 10 top 15 sort of category but
he truthfully physically belongs there
what do we think Felder I love him still
can play brother you love everybody at
this point yeah I do that's that's the
one that's listen that's the role that I
picked I love I love everyone and um
with Deontay Banks what you get though
is in I kind of equate it to the guys
coming out of Illinois too you get a
really well taught guy and I usually you
mentioned a render that he didn't have
all the as much tape as some of these
other guys but certainly when you do pop
it in you see what he can do you look at
a guy he can play and press okay no
problem and I love this look at that
patient feet I wish he would have got
hands on him but guess what he still has
speed to play down the field I think
this is a really good pick in terms of
what they're getting from him a guy that
he's willing to come up and make tackles
which is a good thing uh something that
you have to have especially
um in the at the next level he long
coverage here which that's hard to do
yeah cover for that long on the scramble
and then uh okay
I hope you also help you on the teams
too so this is going to be this is an
interesting pick I'm gonna go with an A
on this one too I think that oops I'm
not supposed to hit it yet that's my
fault but yeah I mean this guy can play
he's a good football player and again
the big thing that I keep going back to
I like these guys we always talk about
Ohio State we always talk about Penn
State we always talk about Michigan
let's talk about
um you know Alabama Georgia whatever but
there's good coaching going on other
places and this is a prime example of it
same thing with the guys coming out of
Illinois playing in the secondary
there's good coaching going on other
places that aren't just the top brand
name schools uh I would say Micah we
talked earlier about another cornerback
going to the NFC East that you thought
was a little bit too light this guy
doesn't have that issue super aggressive
uh great I love physical DB standpoint
because that's what you need in our
division our division is physicality big
receivers big Runners like you've got to
be able to come up and playing for the
Giants to come and get him late at a
value of a pick around 24 25 is great
value on a guy like you might not know
but it's close to the second where you
can afford to take a risk on a guy like
this and hopefully it turns out for the
best and you're the Giants Wink
Martindale DC the blitz heaviest team in
the NFL when you Blitz as much as they
do right you better have reliable
corners or else they're going to get
toasted yeah so Jacksonville move uh by
the way is there a more really cool NFL
name than Deontay Banks yeah it just
sounds I mean he's going to make some
mad bank if he played good in New York
you play good in New York taxes yeah so
so the Jaguars went back to 25 24 to 25.
then they're going to move from 25 to 27
because the bills are moving up what are
we thinking here for the bills Runner
what what could be jumping off the page
that they need to move up and jump the
Cowboys the Cowboys so why do you jump
the Cowboys so you would think maybe a
tight end to jump the Cowboys right for
one of those guys but but then again
they have a Dawson Knox I I think
they're comfortable with that unless
they want to go allow two tight end sets
um all the wide receivers are gone not
that high is still there Hyatt is still
there yeah
um Nolan Smith's still there Nolan Smith
is still there Corner uh Joey Porter's
still here now bills do need a
linebacker they did lose Tremaine
Edmonds
um and you could be sitting there with
the guy that you guys are saying Drew
Sanders you would look really good in
the Buffalo Bills Jersey yeah yeah and
they also do need DTS Ayo for Z mozzie
Smith um she takes mozzie Smith that's
my guy that's my guy that's who you want
to go that's my guy so if the so if the
Eagles go and they get Jalen Carter and
then the bills jump the Cowboys and take
Mozzy this is like a worst case scenario
worst case but if we get Joey Porter Jr
or Mazi Smith then you're happy I'll be
extremely happy
you know we only get Gilmore for one or
two years right so we need an outside
solidify especially trying to hold
because we can't afford to keep paying
high-end Corners to come in right so we
need a guy outside Trayvon Diggs knowing
we should we have to pay him realize you
were such a salary cap Guru man I really
you're thinking I really try to learn
the game and try to put the best team
available to win Super Bowls like and
he's about look he's got to make the
money yeah oh I totally get it yeah like
this is I think the bills are a very
interesting situation as a team 13-3
Super Bowl Contender they were the
favorite before the year they're hosting
the Bengals Joey burrow comes in there
and you're sitting there as a Buffalo
Bills fan you're like the hell just
happened you know we really threw them
off you know
your prayers for Demar Hamlin sure but
we saw what was heading towards that
game the way the Bengals came out yeah
they just continued it they didn't get
that game of adjustment wow and they
jump ahead of the Cowboys to take Dalton
Kincaid the Buffalo Bills want weapons
and they're okay with a too tight end
set Josh Allen I want to introduce you
to your new weapon First Team all Pac-12
third team All-American LED FBS at tight
ends in receiving yards and catches he
grew up in Vegas two years at San Diego
then went Utah against USC 16 catches on
16 targets for 235 does have a back
injury but this is a heck of a weapon at
tight end Runner this is one of my
favorite picks of the draft this is the
bills seeing the landscape of the AFC
that we talked about earlier and saying
I need weapons I need someone I have a
Dawson Knox oh I have a tight end Ray
that I like here's the Titan that you
love they can get on the field still
with Dawson Knox because he's so
athletic that he wins down the football
fields like you're seeing here I've not
seen a tight end with as good a ball
skills come out in my A-Plus years doing
this as Dawn Kincaid I mean off
outside of his frame inside of his frame
he's plucking the ball out of the air
you do not have to worry about him
dropping one even though he didn't drop
on the end zone against Florida only two
drops though his entire collegiate
career this physical comp for him it's
Travis Kelsey he looks the way Travis
Kelsey does I'm not saying he's going to
be that good but this is a guy that can
bring the things that Kelsey does in
terms of those option routes just give
him the freedom to create space over the
Middle Field and he's going to do it for
the Buffalo Bills this is a weapon in
her offense a chess piece to add to
again an arms race that is the AFC and I
think they now have the sort of horses
to compete is it fair filter to say
let's remove the position of tight end
they took the best pass catcher
available
yeah I think so I think that I think he
I mean he's
not high on him no I'm super high
um but no I think that the the thing I
like the most about him obviously we see
those catches the catches in traffic we
see the catches with people draped on
his body we see a little bit of run
after the catches which is something
that that's something always with tight
ends that I look at and think about
because so many tight ends are catching
Fall Guys yep and he's the guy that
wants to stay on his feet and wants to
pick up some some yards after catch 16
broken tackles eight catches at 25 or
more yards and here's the other thing
I'm gonna go a plus here but here's the
thing
I love the fact that everybody knew that
he was going to get the football when
you played Utah everyone you don't catch
16 balls against USC and you're like
it's not a surprise they're not sneaking
him out yeah everybody knows he was good
everybody knew he was gonna get the
football and he's still delivered so
that's what I really like about this guy
knowing the score he understands hey I'm
gonna they're gonna have to do they're
gonna have to deal with me and it's one
of those things where it's like um with
Dalton Kincaid it's like I'm not I'm not
trapped in here with you you're trapped
in here with me and he just goes out
there and makes plays after play after
play you like this pick or do you want
to focus on Dallas one dinosaur okay
he's on down two tight end nox whatever
see him later this year I need to see
who's going to help us beat them I'm not
even gonna okay Dallas Cowboys
what do you want I need Mozzy or Joey
Porter those are the two guys those are
the two guys we need a guy that's gonna
go Michael Mayer you need to replace
Stelton Schultz I'll be so pissed well
no I mean it's gonna be your teammate
you'll still like him but I mean we have
I thought Hendershot and I thought
Ferguson played really well when Schultz
was down I didn't feel like it was such
a crazy drop-off right at the tight end
position I was very comfortable with
them I thought they stepped up I thought
they did everything they possibly do to
stay on the field throwing shots was
just our franchise tag guy you know so I
don't see the what if it's a Nolan Smith
uh I wouldn't be mad at that either
I wouldn't be too but you really want
mozzie I need yeah we I think what is it
about him that has you so like excited
big body run stopper push the pocket
like that's gonna help change all the
rushers right It's Gonna Change It's
Gonna Change make life easier for you
because they got to worry about him on
the interior so we're going to make life
easier for the linebackers because he's
going to be able to eat double teams I
mean and you're talking about we
struggled in the run I mean you know we
we just got a whole bunch of pass
rushers but to get that combination of
size and pass rush would be just huge
and you know that like that Bruce
Feldman freak list yeah yeah Mazi was
number one on that thing yeah well you
have Intel do you have Intel like did
you know should I see what's going on
yes I think you should like FaceTime uh
Dan Quinn like like what is going on
right now like
are you nervous
I am bro
I'm talking at talk us through what you
feeling right now
hold on hold on hold on hold on you got
bubbles
this is too important yeah who should we
call who should you call who should you
FaceTime we should try to call Dan yeah
you think he'll answer there's only one
way to find out
yeah you just gotta put it on
speakerphone
I can't mess this one up
tell me the way he answers no he answers
I doubt he well we're gonna learn a lot
about your friendship maybe you don't
love me as much as I think he does
realization oh he loves you as much as
you think
you know
well you can't mess this pig though we
can't no there's no way watch we're
going we're going to get what if you go
will love us
why even play like that like because I'm
a Birds fan I will be so thrown off like
I'm like what direction are we going we
want we want to win now like what is the
Eagles you don't get Gilmore and Cooks
like we don't trade for the players we
trade for to not win now right like I
need someone who's going to come and
help us win now like yeah Gilmore Cooks
um like we need to turn Dallas into like
the two players that you guys have been
mocked are on the board mozzie Smith and
Michael Mayer are the two guys that you
guys are watching we're not taking
Michael Mayer
I don't know yet
this will either say mayor's good if if
you draft Michael we got a good dude
he's he's like Captain America he's cool
he looks like a NCAA 14. he's cool
it's cool but I think we can get a
Michael Mayer later like you can get a
Darnell Washington that's what I was
going to say you get someone in a second
that we could trade up like yeah I don't
think there's the draft room come on
Jerry come on man
McCarthy's like I need mayor no no Mike
I I see that face going red
Dan where you at say something dead
I really hope they're like man Mike is
calling me you're like why yes he is I
should be caught I think I still got the
number they called me from or shoot him
a test
come on yeah so the Cowboys uh got rid
of Zeke got rid of Dalton Schultz
man
oh my gosh
come on come on come on come on
that defense really is just like you put
a nose tackle in there that's a every
down nose and you are complete yeah
yo you know what uh mozzy's nickname was
on the team
gorilla we need a gorilla Perfect come
on Moz because apparent apparently in
the weight room he was doing like crazy
stuff yeah I think him and Osa will go
and we lost Carlos Watkins so I don't
see how it wouldn't make sense
you know but who knows bro I don't dude
I've been watching this Blitz game
yeah I was winning I wouldn't be mad at
a receiver if we went and got like Hyatt
I wouldn't be mad at that you wouldn't I
wouldn't be mad at that there'd be a
small part of you that would be mad at
that it would hurt me inside but I would
not be upset about Hyde because we need
a pure well I didn't say like I'm really
proud of you it is so cold in here it's
a little freezing I'm freezing
you got a wool coat yeah like I might
have played it smart who would you want
as an Eagles fan who's like your dreams
I want Micah to be happy because he's
been so good and he's been so much fun
uh at the same time come on Jerry we
can't wait to the last minute picking
I got I have to imagine that there if
I'm the Cowboys what I'm doing is I'm
calling everybody else and I'm going do
you want to train up for a quarterback
because we look man I I know that we
don't think that much of will love us
somebody might and we're at that point
of the draft and you want to lock in
that fifth year yeah I mean we can see
uh
I just I will say that Jordan love
situation I it will come out later if
the Dallas Cowboys won a Dalton Kincaid
okay and the reason it's interesting to
me is the Eagles did this to Dallas when
they jumped ahead of them and took
Dallas Goddard right and that was their
tight end because this is an offense oh
okay so they're clapping
they love it all right take a seat take
a seat well of course they're gonna love
it
all right
why everybody's shaking and I don't know
let me get uh can we get program on the
monitor I want to watch us again
it's mixed signals like I don't know
like what's going on okay
everyone seems extremely ecstatic like
you're nervous man I'm starting to warm
up my palms and sweating
Cowboys Nation these week are the
championship pick right here okay okay I
have the pick
okay
they've told me to wait
you guys tell me how you want to do this
okay they are confirming it's not
official don't be looking at your phone
no
they had it and then they said they need
to confirm so I'm not leading you on
we're gonna find that on TV no we are
not I promise you we're gonna beat it
okay the pick is in
and with the 26th pick in the NFL draft
the Dallas Cowboys select mozzie Smith
let's go
Dan wouldn't let me down man
let me down read the text what does it
say
you want me to read it
Michigan DT you texted him today at 3 27
and he responded I'm all about that life
with six exclamation points and you
wrote please
that life
how do you feel muster Micah Parsons
no more qpsc AJ
wow
huge huge huge huge that's how we do it
Cowboys Nation
man uh AJ Brown uh what do we think
about Michael Parsons reaction
yo I think I think he he has every right
to to be excited this is a great pick
for him uh
but we're the Eagles and we do we do
what we want we're going to QB sneak
whenever we want you can't stop thinking
uh let's let's take a look at this film
and we'll break this down uh mozzie
Smith 6-3 323 defensive tackle out of
Michigan uh First Team all Big Ten team
captain I'm ready to tweet
get on that tweet we'll do the video
um whenever y'all are ready to roll that
that footage let's do it ranked number
one on Bruce Feldman's freak list uh 25
pressures in 2022 uh led the team Micah
Parsons overly ecstatic uh Renner what
do we think of Mazi here at 26. yeah an
ascending player right so he only gets
to start 2021 okay you mentioned the
freaks list that the most powerful dude
in this draft class and you finally saw
it in 2022 this past season the last
three games are what sold me Ohio State
Purdue TCU unblockable in the Run game I
mean his ability to hand control
interior offensive lineman what he did
to Luke whippler a guy from Ohio State
the center that will probably hear his
name called tomorrow is a was a crime I
mean he he little boy them
single-handedly hurt his draft stock
because he's just that powerful he's the
guy who's going to come into the middle
of your defense you're not going to have
to worry about him in the Run game and
against the pass he will push and walk
back centers he will
give his all being that Spike man on
stunts throwing guards to the side I
mean just a pure Power Player for my
opinion for my money the strongest
player in this draft and is a guy that
you're just gonna love at nose tackle
great hey
what do we think Felder is you as
excited as Michael Parsons is not as
excited as Mike is but man yo yo no no I
don't know what type of fan he is but he
loves everybody but my opinion
I love him oh I love this picture I love
this
because I'm still lucky he just doesn't
love as much as I can love it as much as
you I do love the pig
you ain't starting to last 25 picks like
that don't start my pick like that that
was talking about that like that oh this
guy is a mountain of a man and I think
it's going to be good for you it's gonna
be good for the rest of that football
team in Dallas because he again he's
humongous he is a mountain of a man he
is impossible to move I love the fact
that he listen they've moved him around
too and they let him work on some stunts
they let him work on some of those feet
that allow him to move and that's what I
was gonna say he's got good footwork
he's not just his hands he's also has
good footwork and I love that he's look
at the way he's got that guy right yeah
not bad I absolutely love it I love this
this is a great pick this is a guy that
you can sit in the middle of your
defense and he's going to go out there
and you see him perform that's literally
how Linville Joseph all those guys you
know he we're going to work on the get
off we're going to get that right yeah
he's locking out and he's like I dare
someone to run down here I'm a long arm
you I'm gonna drag you down like that's
what we need that is the type of run
stuff he gave it an A plus look at that
are you okay with it now he ain't love
it all right he did not fight you from
my feelings that's why he did it you
can't start what I said I don't really
love it then give it an eight plus all
right so you love him I didn't say I
didn't really love it I said I don't
love it as much as you yeah because
you're I don't have trouble I'm not
playing with it I don't have to play
with him I'm an a punch so you don't
love it as much as me that's like an A
minus a b all right I want you to do
this I want you to look in that camera I
don't want you to give a message to
mozzie Smith
Mozzy man listen
yo welcome to the team you somebody
wanted to be a part of this organization
I love the way you play I just hope you
ready to be a part of the best d-line in
the NFL
I'ma help you get sex you're gonna help
me get sacks let's start together and
get this Super Bowl and get paid man
you happy I'm super happy man if you
were upset earlier you're happy now yeah
I mean it still hurts with Carter but I
mean I'm cool though you got your big
guy I I'm teasing a little bit I got my
guy in there I got my guy yeah guy yeah
he gonna take me for ice cream man I got
my God I got my God
uh that was fun I'm happy for you I
didn't that would have been really bad
okay Jacksonville is in now uh remember
they traded back with the Giants from 24
to 25 then they traded back with Buffalo
from 25 to 27. uh could we see the first
safety off the board
I
that's what everyone's been marketing
there's like one need on this roster and
it's slot safety it was Brian Brandt and
Brian branch is that he's as good a
prospect as you'll see in that mold
obviously you know you can swing for the
fences at other positions but offensive
lineman you know what we just had a
suspension earlier today yes we did what
uh we had offensive tackle cam Robinson
got suspended four games for Peds and
now you wonder is this going to be the
guy that fills in because they also this
off-season lost Juwan Taylor so they go
out there and they get Anton Harrison uh
big offensive lineman 24 starts 23 of
them at left tackle uh very young he
just turned down just turned 21 years
old Renner what do we think of him here
at 27. yeah it's insurance for cam
Robinson the fact that he's going to be
suspended you have Walker little getting
his first taste of starting at right
tackle and now Anton Harrison's kind of
like your swing tackle to start off with
uh you can let them develop there that's
when you want to draft an offensive
tackle is the year before you're
probably going to need it and to me he's
not as much of a project as maybe some
other guys in this draft class I love
the way he used his hands he's really
lighting his feet I thought his play
strength took a massive step forward
from 2021 to this season I I think he's
a guy who maybe is not the ceiling that
guys like Darnell Wright or Paris
Johnson have but I think his floor is
pretty high and floor is really all
you're looking for a tackle you don't
want liabilities at that position I
think Anton Harrison feel pretty
comfortable saying he won't be that
great I'm gonna go with an a for this
one I I was pretty high on him I had him
in a similar tier to those guys I'm uh
obviously goes way later than them but I
think just at the tackle position what
he does well pass protection hand usage
is what translates to the league yeah I
think that this is a player that he's
going to come in step in go play I think
the cool thing with him is he's got a
lot of reps like in pass Pro a lot a lot
of reps in pass Pro I do think he plays
High sometimes but at the end of the day
he's also still a kind of a tall guy at
uh what is he six four six five so the
thing for me is want to see him figure
out how to get a little bit lower but at
the end the day this is a quality pick
and look it's the Jags right yep what do
the Jags have a franchise quarterback
what do you have to protect your
franchise quarterback yeah how do you
get that done we've said it multiple
times on this show
you either go out and fix your offensive
line
you go get weapons or you fix your
defense and they've they've opted to to
go lean on the offensive line so I think
it's a great pick I'm gonna go a this is
a guy that just he's I expect him to
come in and play can compete for time
early he's gonna have to with everything
going on there uh Mr Calais Campbell uh
you know that team well what do we think
of Anton Harrison going to the Jags
yeah I think it's a great pickup you
know um when I was watching the tape I
mean you guys send me a list of guys to
watch and I never really heard of them
and I mean I watch a lot of tape on I
was just a football fan but I never
heard of them so I put the tape on I was
like wow this guy's pretty darn good you
know I like this contact balance you
know a good hand placement physicality
in the Run game uh honestly you know I
feel like he's you know as good or could
be as good as some other guys that went
earlier an office line position I think
especially start now I think you know
like you like you said you might have as
high of a ceiling but right now his
floor is low and I see the same thing
you know why watch table Mario this guy
can play football right now in the NFL
you know I know if he's gonna be all pro
but he's a good player you know and so I
like his athleticism I like what I see
on tape I think it's a chance to be
pretty good player and he's in a great
he's a quarterback who can make plays uh
running games and be on point a lot of
receivers I mean he's just surrounded by
Talent so you go in there and just put
your hand in the pile and try to make
your presence fail hell yeah thank you
Calais uh Mike I feel like you watched
the offensive tackles and you're already
thinking about how you're going to beat
them around the edge yeah how are you
going to beat man I'm gonna try to set
him down a little bit uh you know
aggression can also uh be a downfall
when you're overly aggressive your goal
is to try to get your hands on me as
quick as possible to slow me down so I'm
gonna try to use that to my advantage a
little you reach I teach moment yeah you
know and you know he's he's coming from
a great School of great offensive
Legends yeah of offensive tackles so I'm
pretty sure he's really well coached I
think he's going to come in and be super
helpful to Lawrence losing Juwan until
the losing Kane Robinson a guy who could
probably see the field day one
um so I think this was a great value
pick for the Jacks uh Bengals are up
right now pick 28. uh and and I wonder
you know they were marked mocked a
little bit of Anton Harrison as well
yeah there are two other tackles uh one
other tackle at least in DeJuan Jones uh
that I think possibly and that would be
in Ohio State to Cincinnati connection
right there there is also an opportunity
here for a Michael Mayer and the pick is
Murphy wow okay they end up going a
little defense here the Cincinnati
Bengals I don't like that pig okay well
let's start a little positivity and then
we'll get to that Cincinnati Bengals go
with Miles Murphy out of Clemson lined
up all over the defensive line this was
a top 10 high school recruit man is
physical 405 bench press 38 games 37
tackles for loss there is a rumor in the
NFL some people are worried about
Clemson guys translating at the next
level yeah but what do we think of
Murphy here to the Bengals yeah the
Bengals are in a position where and they
said this last year when they drafted
Jackson Hill they don't have a lot of
needs on this roster besides their
offensive line which at this point you
know it's depleted so they said we're
just going to take guys that we think
are at valuable positions that can make
an impact in the future there are four
looking positions so that you know when
uh Sam Hubbard's contracts up maybe we
don't have to resign them we have miles
Murphy Hendrickson's a free agent after
next and Trey Hendrickson there you go
we don't have to re-up them we have this
guy waiting in the wing so it's a
Forward Thinking pick for a guy who is a
project miles Murphy needs reps he has a
long arm and that's about it and that's
great in college it can work it can be a
little productive but in the NFL you
need a little bit more than that so he
needs some refinement to his game but
you don't find athletes like this guy
too often he ran a four five three at
268 pounds he cooks off the edge I had
to comp there Rashawn Gary he's just a
big strong dude the problem is as you
mentioned the Clemson stuff his tape was
better as a freshman sophomore than once
as a junior that's not the way you want
a guy to be going and that's why he
falls to this point draft Yeah gotta go
a still though because I I just think
his what he can be those guys usually go
higher than this yeah I when I look at
him I see a guy that should be better
yes and you mentioned that his early
stuff was a little bit better than his
later stuff I think that also has to do
with teams identifying him as a problem
and the way that he's being used so this
is going to be interesting to see how
that works there's that long arm that
you just mentioned it's his best move
it's got long arm he can get it done so
I think the big key is going to be how
does he work on bending the edge how
does he work on getting to the
quarterback in more efficient ways but
this is a guy I really like I like I've
liked him since he was in high school
yeah this is one of those things where
you look at him you watch him play you
see that I think that there's an
interesting element to his play his body
developed too he was smaller and Slimmer
as a freshman and was able to get a
little bit more penetration was able to
be a little bit more of a speedy player
I'm going to go ahead and give this an a
though because this is someone that I
thought had the opportunity to be in the
top 20. and you're getting them at the
back end of the first round so I think
this is a fantastic pick for them your
first reaction was I don't like this
pick why yeah I mean you know trying to
go for quality of pigs especially this
late I thought they would go in a
different uh Direction I thought they
might reach for Corner safety right
especially losing some backing guys and
your Corners being your especially with
Eli Apple's over your Corners being a
little borderline suspect I thought
there were still a couple quality guys
still there right that you could have
took
um and then like you you're getting
almost the same guy with Trey
Hendrickson and Sam Hubbard like I
thought you might want to go a little
bit more speed right around the edge get
you a dimensional you got a Joseph osai
over there would you rather see Nolan
Smith go here I would have much rather
known Smith with the pick I believe like
you should like you should have a speed
guy you should have a power guy because
everyone's Rush can't be high or
everyone's Rush can't be power that's
how slips outs happened QB's got outside
of pocket it has that balance rushers I
just think you're just getting the same
guy that's guys that you have I just
realized and by the way miles Murphy
Clemson going to Bengals I do think to
see that Trey Hendrickson is a free
agent after this year that made sense to
replace it
um
Saints are on the clock now
how do you feel if the Eagles Take Nolan
Smith at 30. I think that would be
pretty crazy but it doesn't so like I
don't know hold on I gotta change this
up that would be that'll be messed up we
got to talk about the Saints like I
can't do that to Saints fans because
they're here the Saints stream in fact I
want to shout them out let's get the
Saints chat up on the screen while we
start talking about it what are they
what do the Saints fans want yeah I want
to know who the Saints fans want this is
a team that lost their top pick uh to
the Eagles because of that trade last
year when they moved up
um but this is a pick that has gone from
San Francisco to Miami to Denver to New
Orleans uh what are we thinking here
um
not many needs on this roster right it's
it's still a pretty darn good roster at
least like they're starters you got
tight end DT wide receiver I could see
all qualifies needs places you'd want to
address Michael Mayer on the board you
got Brian brzee on the board wide
receiver Jalen Hyatt probably on the
board so I think I think Sanders or of
Russia go cam Jordan's getting older
um you might want to come here David's
getting older too yeah and then you lost
uh the other rusher and free agency
um Davenport yeah Davenport so I could
see a rusher come off the board or tight
end
um you did resign Juwan Johnson but a
bigger more run blocking tight end which
is Mayor what we could considering what
they like to do yes and they said you're
having Derek Carr and he likes the tight
ends yeah right so I mean or we could
see a Darnell Washington right here
a gut shot shocker right here like you
know we just yeah but especially with if
we're talking about Washington and we
talk about them over there he's it's
like having another offensive tackle on
your on on the field right she switched
off at stacked honestly he's like
literally watching watching Georgia play
and watching the 12 Personnel sets with
Washington and Brock Bowers and then
when they go Broderick Jones
Darnell Washington Brock Bowers that
side of the line was undefeated you
couldn't there's nothing nobody could do
anything with that thing so I think it's
gonna I think it's an interesting spot
for Darnell Washington if they don't go
with mayor uh Saints going QB let's go
Hawks got that dog in him no QB needs
we're not going QB okay Brisas te ain't
needed okay Caitlyn Kailyn G said Jalen
Hyatt yeah I will say Levis here is
interesting also right because you got
Derek Carr but it's like uh it was
stopped up you know it's a trial it's a
trial run listen
this pig I just don't at these last
three picks did somebody say we're about
to do something stupid yeah no those are
my favorites for QB
you know you take a QB trade up maybe
around 20 to 24 but at these last three
this is like chance pick like you're
you're getting late
Lamar went last he went last
but they took a chance on him but then
yeah that was a chance that turned out
to be gold
and the pick is in we got Brian Brian
brazee okay
all right Brian for C
the Saints they sit there at number 29
and they go Brian brazee we go back to
back Clemson players second Team all ACC
21 starts 15 tackles for loss good three
technique coming out of high school he
was the number one recruit ahead of
Bryce young that is how serious this man
was perceived had a ACL tear in 2021 uh
had we talked about this before the show
that strep throat infection really threw
it off but the potential is there what
do we think at this point of the draft
Yeah so this guy like you mentioned
five-star number one recruit comes in as
a freshman has about as good a freshman
tape at defensive tackle as like I've
ever seen he looks like he is going to
be what Jaylen Carter is right now and
goes to the combine and tests like you
know he ran a 486-40. he had 28 bench
press reps he he is a physical monster
it's just tours ACL 152 snaps into the
sophomore season has a whale of a junior
Year and that the strep throat at the
beginning his sister tragically passing
away having to miss a handful of games
from that but then by the end of the
year North Carolina game and then their
bowl game against Tennessee he looked
back he looked like he had me sold on
that that's why I have him still as a
top 20 player cops come to Nathan
Shepard who was uh I believe with the
Saints now he is he is just a special
athlete who's still trying to figure it
out and if you flip on this tape this
past year you're not super encouraged
but but I do think the potential is way
more than you usually see at this point
in the draft great
I'm going a with it I like what the
Saints did they're just playing the
board not trading up and getting a gun
yeah this is a good pick he's a good
football player and it's all about
getting it out of him he was incredibly
disrupted this season and what I'm like
obviously you mentioned the tragic loss
of his sister you mentioned the the
strip and it took him a long time to get
back to what he was and but what he is
and what we're seeing here is a guy
that's strong at the point he works on
he works on doing his job and that's
something I do like about Clemson guys I
know we've talked about
people having knocks on Clemson guys
what have you but this is a guy that he
does his job and he does his job really
really well and for me that's the mark
of a good football player is a guy that
doesn't try to do somebody else's job he
just does his own job you see him there
with a little quick move he's got the
ability to do a lot sky's the limit with
him I think they're getting a player who
probably starts out rotational but he
certainly has the ability to go out and
make plays I'm going to give it an a i
this is a player that I like probably
more than other people but probably
because I've watched a lot more of them
than other people because I'm right
there and he is someone
legitimately
this isn't the same as like Christian
Wilkins but he certainly has the ability
to go out there and be a force
especially on your rundowns uh Calais
Campbell you've heard our discussion
what do you think of Brian brzee going
to the Saints
I like his potential you know I feel
like uh you see the flashes on tape you
know I'm a production guy man I like to
see production and uh you know I feel
like he didn't have nothing but I didn't
realize the adversity he went through
and you know that plays a big role you
know having to deal with the ACL and
then having your sister die I mean I
couldn't imagine you know it's just a
tough situation to go through but it
sounded like after he got you know some
more time playing ball he started
playing good at that level again and so
I feel like um you know uh he has a
chance to be a pretty good player I
think the Saints do a really good job
have they like the big deal I'm in who
they can uh develop and really turn into
good good players and he has a lot of
good leadership around him who can help
bring the best out of him and so I think
it's a good chance man I like his
potential you know I'm not sold on him
as being like this great dominant player
but I like his potential
uh Mike I'd I'd let you talk but I'm
going to be honest the Eagles are on the
clock that's cool I'm not obsessed with
the pig we can move on uh so uh let me
get a little little split screen with AJ
Brown uh AJ what are we thinking do you
have anybody that you really want right
now
uh
uh if you want I can break down my
thoughts
I'm gonna say somewhere on the defensive
side because you know we want the ball
and and our defense is is instead of
rebuilding and reloading so uh give me
your thoughts though okay so here's what
I'm thinking uh number one the thing
that I want the most is I would love to
find a team that wants to come up for
one of these quarterbacks and get a
first round pick next year I like this
investing in the future for first round
picks that's option number one number
two
I getting Nolan Smith and just having
all of the great Georgia football
players having Nolan Smith Jordan Davis
nicobi Dean and also Jalen Carter that
would be incredible uh number three the
thing that I'm thinking about
I wouldn't be upset with Brian Branch
the safety I know that we kind of have
some holes on the on that side right now
I'm not I wouldn't be mad with Drew
Sanders I know that Howie doesn't
normally draft linebacker but this is a
team that lost a lot of linebackers in
free agency
um
and then last
that big offensive lineman like a
Matthew Bergeron from Syracuse or a
DeJuan Jones from Ohio State guys that
might be able to play guard since they
did lose somalo that could maybe move to
tackle whenever Lane's coming to the end
that's kind of my thought process out of
those things AJ where would you go
I like I like that Nolan Smith let's put
let's put the Georgia band back together
you know uh who did you say so I said no
one you said Nolan Smith
okay it's in no it's not in yeah
okay so I have the pick let's let's
split screen Micah and AJ Brown so we
can like have them on there together I
haven't been told what it is yet so how
do you get this is gonna be a knockout
because I have an earpiece no I do too I
think I should get the pick okay so cap
who is the pick
that's Michael let Micah say it
okay uh and with the uh 30th pick in the
first round of the draft the
Philadelphia Eagles have selected Nolan
Smith Edge rusher out of Georgia
I doubt that happened
That's The Knockout blow for Michael
right there I doubt that happens making
it up he's ready to leave do you oh so
he's ready to leave that is it it will
upset me the most I'm just it just
doesn't make the most sense it just
makes sense
it makes perfect sense it makes perfect
sense
how how does that make you feel he
doesn't know what to do
he doesn't know what to do
he's ready to go
his night his night his pick
it's not nowhere near close to this
wait so there's no pick 32 this year no
because the Miami Dolphins lost because
of Tom Brady's stop trying to change the
top the Eagles yes
so Micah come on he don't know what to
do yeah what do you what do you think of
this player so disappointed I mean I
love Nolan like I've recruited Nolan to
Penn State like I I was his host like
Nolan's my guy his ceiling is high I
think for where he's gone like you see
that production like what we're talking
about for where he's gone this is a
great pick in production wise it
definitely I think he has a chance to
fly through the roof right being in a
system where it's going to be more
towards him a five-man front
wait Jordan Davis Jalen Carter and
Hassan and Josh and a bunch of cars I
mean they just got Fletcher Cox Brandy
Graham 2.0 right like they just reloaded
there yeah I mean
my Lord I mean their future said I mean
how do you feel AJ
I'm loving every bit of this AJ they
can't be able to pay you he does not
you he he needs some tissue he needs
some tissue he he he really that show is
over he's ready to go home
yo see he's trying to take shots at your
pocket right yeah yeah that's cool you
know what you gotta play he's paid he
got two years left hey you know what bro
two years to win the Super Bowl this is
not about me this is not about me listen
to the Super Bowl this is about the the
Philadelphia Eagles and and Nolan Smith
that pick along with Daniel Carter yeah
I want to see his footage you don't know
what to say let's see Nolan Smith this
is a man
uh four three nine forty uh this is a
man that had a one five two split this
is a band that had a 41 and a half inch
vertical all of those were number one in
the combine for the front seven uh not
only that the team says Nolan Smith is
the most vocal player in the locker room
the energy of the defense may I say one
of the greatest college football
defenses of all time and on that defense
Not only was it Nolan Smith it was Jalen
Carter it was Jordan Davis and it was
nicobi Dean and all four of them are on
the Philadelphia Eagles what do we think
Renner he might have gone top 10 and
they get him at 30. yeah Smith is a heck
of an athlete I still you know work in
progress as a past Russia but the effort
I mean this guy loves ball he brings it
every single snap to be 235 pounds
playing against the run the way he does
you have to because every snap he's
taken on tackles that he's given 60
pounds to and he's the one walking them
back I think his Quicks his get off it
is exactly what you want if you are
going to be an undersized guy and right
there I've not seen a prospect as good
defending option runs which is a real
thing you have to do in the NFL nowadays
I I know Mike has to deal with it week
in week out pressing down that line
having to get back out to that
quarterback sprinting around the edge he
can at both ends of the option when he's
unblocked
and it's just Child's Play for him I
mean a freak athlete through and through
with the high ceiling I'm a big fan the
the eagle you push the a plus button for
me really quick what they did in this
thing was just Master Class thanks hey
uh Felder what do you think about Nolan
Smith at 30. I mean this is unbelievable
he is a player from that one I'm still
trying to figure out what he is okay I
saw the beer and Browning comp I'm still
trying to figure out what he actually is
at the next level 238 pounds I don't
know that he's in if like I don't I
don't know what he
can look at the screen
he's got tissues for you call the
wambulance
yeah
everyone got their guys
I'm not for sure what he is going to be
at the next level if he's going to play
more linebacker is he going to be more
dedicated Russian but I know that he's
got the potential listen I do a lot of
recruiting yeah this dude's an A plus he
has the opportunity I mean look at this
he get off of me let's go get there oh
fumble yeah and the thing I like the
most about him
it's not the moves it's not even the
combine numbers the thing I love the
most about him he suffers an injury
right yep a lot of guys they would go
train for the draft and just work on
that yeah stayed at Georgia
he was at like the the coin flip every
game yes he was and at every single game
you saw Nolan Smith with his towel out
calling out calling out the offense
calling out the defense letting people
getting people lined up from the
sidelines being a leader he's the leader
in that locker room and he was someone
that the way he handled multiple
situations the way that like when he
he's someone left I'm gonna tell you
this yeah tell him I already said a plus
he is someone that's going to be a
decade-long guy that's the centerpiece
of this team like he's got I don't think
he plays the same position as Luke
Kuechly but he's got Luke Kuechly energy
for a locker room and I think that's
good I think that's remarkable because
go ahead I was gonna say and I'll say
this about Howie Roseman like he is
drafting guys to learn from veterans
last year he did it with Cam Jurgens and
Jason Jason Kelsey like that's the
perfect guy to learn from in that mold
you have draft Nolan Smith to learn from
Hassan Reddick the perfect guy to rush
the pass through the high side speed
rusher that's who you want him to learn
from and that's just how you build a
team they are set up now for incredible
long-term success with the draft they
had last year the draft they had this
year and the Jalen hurts contract uh
it's going to be a tough division NFC
East it's going to be what you're
looking for over there Micah
foreign
never in my wildest dreams did I think
they were going to get Jalen Carter I
thought they were going to have to go
with Nolan at that pick I thought they
were going to have to take Nolan with
that pick at 10. I know they moved up to
nine
I
AJ what a night baby what a night look
at us hi AJ look at us
look at us look at us wow who would have
thought uh so I guess Kansas City the
host of the draft they have a pick uh
whatever uh good for them uh no but
Kansas City is up we have to finish
strong Eagles Nation what a night
um
Kansas City the team that actually won
the Super Bowl and uh what if Porter
fall he'll probably go to first pick
tomorrow to Pittsburgh
oh oh yeah if they don't pay if they
don't pick him yeah
who else is available from an addressing
standpoint now it got weak Felix Andrew
DK uzama is the top one on the board
available again State rusher and then
it's kind of like
we got to go aways I think after that so
it's it's that was kind of it all right
I think one of the most interesting
things about watching the Super Bowl
this year yeah was how no one could get
to the quarterback well they think
apparently that feels awful yeah yeah
yeah did you see it did you you didn't
see the shot of all the cleats I was at
the game oh so you didn't see it I
didn't see nothing no they had they did
you see the shot of the cleats the
Eagles cleats just like steak everybody
had to change cleats yeah you got I mean
I mean I mean even we like even Green
Bay same way anytime you plan that slick
grass yeah you gotta get into more of a
grass Clique yeah is there is there any
chance here the Chiefs maybe go with
Hyatt I can see it is there any chance
here uh uh they don't really need could
you imagine if they went Michael Meyer
and did a little double tight end with
Jason with uh Travis Kelsey Kelsey for
as good as he's been he's still what 34
years old yeah he's like he is not he
should not be doing what he's doing you
cannot count on that if you are the
Chiefs to happen every year and you
can't count on a prospect like mayor to
be available every year because I could
also see them going a Bergeron or a
DeJuan Jones right now they're starting
to write tackles Lucas nyang
um they did lose Orlando Brown they did
bring in Juwan Taylor
um but the the knees that they have wide
receiver obviously they lost Juju they
lost Michael Hardman uh offensive line
and all the changes there and I think
with them just getting constant d-line
depth is always something they could go
for
yeah I would
I also like the top player on the board
right now is you know obviously will
Levis but then Brian Branch Alabama
safety I know it's not a massive need
for them but you're in a position where
you can kind of just luxury luxury picks
and just get good players on that
defensive side I think Brian branches
are the best defensive back in this in
this draft and he's he's like the safest
he just you're gonna get a good football
player no matter where you line him up
yeah and I think that's the key I think
as a corner he's probably
sixth seventh best corner but as a that
safety or as a gadget piece I think he
becomes a high value defensive back if
you're going to use him that way you
cannot draft this guy to play corner you
can draft into play
a safety you can drop into be that
Gadget piece Big Nickel type thing
Smith bro you got mozzie yeah I'm good
I'm good I'm good I'm good I'm good I I
don't know that you guys are good for a
little while for sure
so you took him on a recruiting visit
yeah and you were like man if you talk
to Nolan Smith yeah I'm talking about
are you talking about you have a great
time I'm the guy you want oh you're a
good like yeah you're a good hang you
take him around you show them oh my gosh
if you actually got some ice cream what
he thought of his Penn State visit he
said he literally said bro if I was if
it wasn't down in Pennsylvania
I'm not going to say nothing else okay
but there was a reason why he chose
Georgia and it's been going on for years
George Alabama all them other schools
but hey nil yeah before nio I don't know
but I just know he should have been a
Penn State I think that's statute of
limitations Kansas City Chiefs
officially select there he is the pass
rusher Felix and adike ozoma wow
the Super Bowl champs close it out
and you DK uzoma second team
All-American he was the big 12 Defensive
Player of the Year what's crazy is he
considered giving up football After High
School and then two days before Signing
Day Kansas State called him up and says
we got you led the team in sacks tackles
for loss and forced fumbles the last two
seasons 27 starts 20 and a half sacks a
pass rusher for the Chiefs this one is
one I mocked a bunch because he just
feels like a Steve spagnolo defensive
end you know how he loves those guys he
can kick inside they're versatile they
have Bend reminds me of a guy who would
fit in that Giants line back when they
won the Super Bowl with them he just
great been to him uses hands really well
just not a super high-end athlete that's
why he falls this point in the draft is
because he doesn't have quite the get
off quite the all-around athleticism but
I think it's just going to be a
productive player him and Carl Loftus on
two ends you don't have to take those
guys off the field they can play The Run
they can rush the passer you can kick
him inside uh I copped him there to
Harold Landry because of that Ben but
he's just he's a guy that you really
like maybe he's never going to turn into
an All-Pro bowler but you're never
really going to complain about him
either yeah what grade
hey yeah I mean at this point in the
draft if you get guys you get these guys
you have an opportunity enerdike Zuma uh
when I watch him play yeah I thought
about um
Matthias Kiwanuka yeah there you go wow
yeah you there's no do you remember
Matthias Kiwanuka
yeah that's what I thought about um that
was actually my first and my only bowl
game that we went to yes was against BC
before they joined the ACC actually but
same type player just a steady Eddie a
guy that's good he's going to give you
every snap that you need out of him he
doesn't have to come off the field he
does he's going to have moments and it's
probably going to be match-up dependent
but he's gonna have moments where he has
big games and I think that's going to be
the key and you watch them there you saw
the motor you saw the energy you saw the
fact that he's willing to chase things
down from the back side yeah so for me
yeah I'm gonna go with an a
okay well
yeah I'm gonna go with an A but I love
watching him play he's super powerful
and that's one of the things that I
really like about him is he's super
powerful able to walk guys back to the
quarterback wants to be involved in
every play and he was a super lowly
recruited guy he had a blue shirt to
even get to Kansas State and then by the
time he sees the field as a retro
sophomore all of a sudden he's
double-digit sacks like he is an
ascending player that was not supposed
to be coming out as a true Junior wasn't
even supposed to be like a prospect when
he was coming out of high school all of
a sudden had some weight turns it on and
you got a player I think he's ascending
and I think he's a guy that for the
Chiefs long term great pick we know uh
what Chris Jones as possible George
carloftus was a solid DN for them last
year Frank Clark currently a free agent
I could totally see him re-signing with
the Chiefs maybe at like a veteran
friendly number but this is a guy long
term have you watched this guy at all uh
he's not necessarily a guy that I
watched off of everyone I've seen but
just based off the short clips I see
exactly what you guys good Ben uh being
able to transitional Rush he's going
power then he's able to right keep
continue to rush I think that's the most
important not just getting stuck on your
first move right retreating but the
continuation of the rush because you
never know what's going to happen if a
play break down or anything like that so
to continue to rush the effort all look
very good and Anton Harrison just went a
few picks ago they had a head-to-head
matchup I thought Felix and gk's Mama
came out on top of that sure yeah he
went to uh Jacksonville that is the
first round but now we have to look at
how everything went we have to pick some
winners but first let's see how Runners
props did we just hits a few yeah we
definitely did I know you hit Dalton
Kincaid here we go uh will Levis under
six and a half doesn't even get drafted
in the first round
you had him going under 10 and a half
wow that's a killer he went 11.
Broderick Jones under 13 and a half or
over he went 14 couldn't be more perfect
Quentin Johnson under 26 and a half he
goes 21. Kincaid first tight and drafted
a little bit of a shocker mayor not
drafted at it all in the first round
over four and a half quarterbacks
drafted it hits three under four and a
half wide receivers boy that was scary
four in a row by 23 and not another one
when and you sir went four and three and
they made money it means we paid money
congratulations here we go uh it is time
we should pick our winners of the first
round and this is the draft recap Bryce
and and all that uh but let's do some
winners uh I'm gonna let Micah go first
okay uh so Micah who is your big winner
of the first round of the 2023 NFL draft
um I would say the first winner is pride
of Houston Texas hmm dumb training up
and getting her to their guide to lead
the way for their defense the next five
six years and their guy on offense to
probably leave for the next 10-12 was
huge for them you know and especially
for how uh the transition they obviously
want to win right now so that was kind
of I thought that was huge moves and
they got the value at their picks at the
right spot so CJ Stroud and Will
Anderson makes the Houston Texans your
winner yeah yeah that's that's a
no-brainer right I'm going to come to
you guys last I want to go to our our
guys that have been out there in the
trenches uh Calais Campbell our our
advisors still with us Calais uh have
you had a chance to think who is your
your winner if you had to pick a winner
yeah remember man uh you just took my
same one I go to Houston Texans as well
uh but I guess it's uh I mean it makes
sense I mean they got two of the best
players in the draft I mean how can you
you know lose the draft when you get two
uh generational talents and I think
that's you know CJ Stroud is going to be
a great quarterback in this league you
know he's going to develop and I think
he has a high selling uh I think we'll
understand is you know I mean one of the
best deal I'm you're gonna get you know
over you know a 10-year period you know
I think uh just what he can do a rushing
the pastor I mean especially with Demico
Ryan's defense and the way he's going to
use them he's going to get the best out
of him I think that just their scheme
fits and um they're just you know
generational talents and uh you know you
can't it's hard it's hard to lose a day
or you know when you have two of the
best two of the best players in the
draft uh Kirk Cousins has uh was with us
boy we really worked them a lot those
first four picks and then another
quarterback uh Kirk who would you say is
your winner when you look back at
tonight
certainly the Texans had a great draft
but I would give you two other teams
that had two first round picks both the
Seattle Seahawks I think hit with their
corner and the receiver and then the
Eagles who you obviously have talked
about at length but I felt playing them
last year the biggest reason they were
so dominant of all the different success
they had was the d-line and to be able
to reload at that position and and
continue to make sure that that d-line
is not going anywhere for years to come
as a fellow NFC here I mean that's
that's going to be a challenge for us
playing them so um doesn't look like
dirty lines going anywhere anytime soon
Kirk thank you so much uh AJ Brown
who are you going to pick as the big
winner on night one
you better listen to Kirk Curry no those
those sacks they add up and they hurt he
knows he know who who won tonight and
it's the Eagles come on man Jalen Jalen
Carter Nolan Smith man big big two two
big new additions uh
the d-line is already lethal just add no
two guys man the sky's the limit for the
d-line and it gets to give us the ball
more so you know we like to score
touchdowns and they get sacked so the
more sacks they get the more touchdowns
we get so the Eagles uh I just want to
say a big shout out and a big thank you
to Calais uh AJ and Kirk thank you for
the time thank you for the Insight you
guys killed it tonight uh appreciate
y'all all right Felder your big winner
from uh night one you know what I'm
gonna go with the Pats in Christian
Gonzalez great one the guy that we
thought might go in the top ten they're
able to wait around wait around wait
around and then get them a little bit
later I think that's a good one and I'm
gonna I'm a college guy right so I'm
gonna go I'm going with Georgia getting
getting all those guys drafted the best
advertisement for your program is
tonight yes talk and when he walks in
when when Kirby Smart walks into
somebody's house
he's gonna put down that list he'll say
look at what we've been doing Yep this
is what you come to Georgia this is
what's going to happen and then he's
probably gonna show them the Rings too
and absolutely uh Renner you're a big
winner I'm gonna give a shout out to the
Panthers so like getting Bryce young
yeah and as Panthers fan like getting a
guy who's like fun you know at the
quarterback position you've had not a
lot of fun since Cam Newton left at that
position he's a guy who's just exciting
but I'll also say the Buffalo Bills
Dalton Kincaid I had him as the 12th
best player in this draft it's how do
you get over the hump in the AFC what
what do we change because we had the
best defense you know we had we had that
we have Josh Allen we have Stefan Diggs
what takes us to the Super Bowl I think
that's a piece of that can Dalton
Kincaid is a piece that can get you over
the hump that can do a little something
different that can give you that slight
Edge because that's what you need in a
loaded landscape so I I love that pick
for them I think that's a guy that's
going to make an impact next season uh
uh you know how I feel at the Eagles I'm
going to say three quarterbacks that
were winners number one I'm going to say
CJ Stroud I think it was been a really
long month and a half where uh when you
talk about this S2 test when you're kind
of calling a guy dumb for a month and
and for him to to not have any of that
and to go second overall I'm really
happy for him uh number two I'm gonna
say Kyler Murray uh his team moved down
from three to six got him a tackle and
then picked up a number of draft picks
for the next two years so that when he's
recovering they're gonna be able to
build around him I thought that was good
and I also think that Lamar Jackson's a
big winner yeah Lamar Jackson got paid
finally and not only that they get Zay
flowers to go along with Odell Beckham
Jr uh but of course I mean the
Philadelphia Eagles and Howie Roseman
and the Philadelphia Georgia Bulldogs
are uh pretty uh literally Philly
Bulldogs
um uh AJ Brown uh chimed in on Twitter a
little bit ago uh and we just kind of
want to give him a little Spotlight
about his social media play so maybe you
could follow AJ Brown but Micah is
hurting right now I love it yeah I love
it yo oh that's so good yo that's crazy
that's crazy that's all good I'm gonna
see y'all in Vegas yes you will you'll
see hey make sure you go since you
laughing make sure you go eat Philly
cheesesteaks with him in Philly while
I'm in Vegas picking up my trophy how
about that uh Micah Micah you you said
the same thing last year I don't think
you need to speak too soon hey AJ to be
honest with you you know damn well you
ain't want to see us again y'all beat a
half a team well no we're gonna see it
twice every year well y'all gonna see
that but they want to see us in that
playoff game I promise you that they did
not want to see us well maybe if you
would have won we wouldn't hey whatever
helps you sleep good at night whatever
helps you sleep good let's go hey good
for you yeah y'all know what y'all know
what's coming
in all seriousness no no you know
uh in all serious Micah uh it's been an
absolute blast having you here uh you
came prepared you brought the juice uh
and I just appreciated working with you
man it was a really good time you killed
it all right man I appreciate it now I
think you guys for this great
opportunity Mike
yeah I Felder you know yeah
we gotta work on it we gotta work on
this today I'm gonna come in I got
another winner
I think yeah yeah
boys you got your guy Mozzy Smith yeah
there we go yeah we got our guy look at
that
um and I I also want to say so uh thank
you thank Kirk thank coleus thank AJ uh
tomorrow day two it will be us three
we'll be breaking it down let's take a
look at best players available still on
the board your guy Joey Porter Jr is one
of them uh here are the best players
going into day two Renner break it down
for us yeah Will Levis obviously like I
think the Rams fit makes too much sense
at this point Brian branch is just the
safety value right and I think Michael
Mayer too like mayor's hurt by a deep
deep tight end class you know a lot of
teams in the teens I think had a
decision do I draft a tight end or do I
wait because one's probably gonna be in
the second round so I think that's where
that is Porter is the biggest surprise
to me to fall out like that guy feels
like a press Corner that thrives at the
NFL level the only thing is they're
going away from press kind of as a whole
a lot more off coverage you're seeing
nowadays than maybe four or five years
ago when everyone's doing cover three on
the outside so that maybe hurts him is
that his kind of scheme dependence that
he has to go to a certain spot
um and then the interesting guys I want
to see is uh the Northwestern DT uh to
me we're out of our yeah he's just freak
athlete all-time athlete for the
defensive tackle position where he comes
off the board at this point it will be
intriguing if he goes to the Eagles too
we might have to uh just you know not
play this season uh that is all for us
here the Gridiron draft show thank you
all so much for joining us we hope you
enjoyed it thanks for joining us in the
BR app and in YouTube and we'll be right
here tomorrow have a great night and I
hope your team got the exact player that
you want see y'all because we did
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you